it's the chair opening the session for
the criminal justice and public safety
committee
it is february 5th of 2021
[Music]
903 am before we start the first public
hearing i just want to address
a few things
so
with the exception of two members of
this committee we're all in our second
term or more we've been all the veterans
of this body
and
to those members and including myself i
think we set a bad example for those the
new members of
this body and the new members of this
committee and i just want to say that
just to make sure there's no
misunderstanding but the parliamentary
rules that we all
fall in this committee and we're in the
house
and a member of the committee wants to
speak whether it's to ask a question
or if whether we're going to discuss a
question that's uh open in an executive
system the member needs to be recognized
by the chair
if the member speaks without being
recognized they are speaking out of
order
and that's how a committee meeting can
turn very chaotic very quickly
if a member has a follow-up question
or they wish to speak further on the
issue
that's
open
they need to be recognized for a
follow-up question when a member is
recognized
and
it's not they're not being recognized to
ask a question and then debate the
question thereafter
they need to be recognized for further
discussion
i would say that that rule is something
that's followed in every committee there
should be no exception
if someone has if a member has a
yelling out or
saying mr chair mr chairman mr chairman
even that is speaking out of order
because you have to recognize the speech
it does interrupt
the hearing
i have no problem seeing the hands in
the room i have no problem seeing the
people on the screen
so
if someone has their hand up
and it it's at the chair's discretion to
recognize the member which as you can
tell i will do my best to recognize each
member who wishes to speak
but speaking out of order
is not appropriate
i would ask the people who are
participating remotely
if you have a question
it is also sometimes a delay so please
try to keep yourselves muted unless you
can recognize your speech
and if you if the member is recognized
after they ask the question they should
they should mute themselves before even
i going forward i am going to strictly
enforce
that rule because i believe
it didn't set a good example i think
that you know we're all capable better i
know that and i think the public
deserves better too they shouldn't watch
us
in this committee
argue
like that amongst ourselves especially
we're not following the problem
so
and then in respect the points of order
which when generally that point of order
is raised
the chairman is
is required to address the point of
order but the point of order is to
really ensure
it's that the parliamentary rules and
procedures being followed
a point of order is not appropriate
would say if a member has
their hand up
and they haven't been recognized raising
a point of order about a question about
when to submit a committee report
is not an appropriate point of order
so
what i would say to the point of order
is if there's an issue with the
procedure and i'll give a good example
of a point of order that was appropriate
there was a
the first executive session we had i
didn't actually categorize the
announcement say the motion that was
proper the question that was being
presented i did not word it correctly
representative o'hearn
caught that
and
raised the point of order and said don't
you have to do this first
that was an appropriate point of order i
agreed with what he said
and that was that
and the rule was that we corrected our
procedure
if you disagree with the point of order
by the ruling on the point of order
the per the procedure is not to debate
that point of order any further the
ruling has already been made
there is a procedure to
challenge that ruling i believe that
remember raising the point order
on how they want to go forward with that
but what we want to do is not raise
point of orders that do not question the
rules of the parliamentary procedure if
you have a question about
you know a committee policy when you
submit your reports
that's not a point of order and in
regards to the committee reports
i'm in my second term
i only was guided a single chairman last
term
the policy that the chairman who sat in
this position prior to myself
that policy was to submit your reports
at the end of the day by 10 pm
i've never
served under any other policies now i
understand that maybe because that was
the prior chairman's discretion but not
a single member had any objection to
that
i never heard anyone object to it
on this committee so when i hear people
now challenging or objecting to that
policy
especially the people who serve in the
committee last year
i'm just going to say if
it was good enough for the chair lasting
that policy was good enough for the
chairman last time i would hope
that policy is acceptable under the
current chair i assume that no one
would change their position just because
the chair is a member of different
pockets
so the reason why we want to get those
reports in is not
it's not meant to be given a hard time
it's just those i need to sign off on
order approve those reports
sometimes you make the calendar there's
a lot of things that happen we all have
a lot of things
going on in our lives
it is a good practice to get those in
as soon as possible they can be emailed
to cameron so that that's something that
can be done
it's actually easier if you do that
because you can then cut and paste it
we're going to begin the oh we're going
to open the first public hearing
on house bill
representative newman speaking out of
order
if you all join me in studying the
[Music]
before we begin the public
as the hearing
of the criminal justice and public
safety committee i find that due to the
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the copa 19
pandemic in accordance with the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-0
this public body is authorized to meet
the electronics
this is a public hearing with the
potential for executive sessions to be
held throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the state of
emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate
in this meeting
by the zoom platform
or by telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general core
website the notice of this meeting
uh complies with household and rsa 91-a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
or email hcs
leg.state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting
assisting us brad grievan
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also state whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
longer
the clerk will now take a roll call
accounts
that's chairman welch
yeah
representative burke
yes and i see gary hopper here with me
representative hopper
yesterday representative here too
representative greene
representative pratt president
representative martin here
clerk here
representative harriet gathering
president
representative panamakis
representative board may
present by myself
representative muse
here and i'm by myself
representative bolden
representative
here and i have um my husband in the
room as well
representative bradley
chairman
president
just
so we have i will say that we have a
quorum so we can begin the public
hearing
one thing i just want to address too for
the members participating at home
for the rules that apply
to what you can and can't do while
sitting in your
committee seat
i i believe that those same rules would
apply if you're at home so for example
if you were sitting physically present
in the room you would not be permitted
to eat so if you were at if you're
participating remotely
i would believe that rule would extend
to
the members who are remote and
for the members of the public testifying
i would say that
i would find that distracting but we're
going to begin the public hearing if
anyone has any questions we can just we
can get those but we are
it's 9 15 and we have nine o'clock
public area so we're going to start the
so the chair now opens the public
hearing for
david king yes he's here does not have
mr chairman um
if i may ask brad greenland
that i don't have any options here to
mr care i can take care of that um i
also wanted to let you know that there
are two uh there were two members with
thank you representative i i do
acknowledge that there's two members
that have their hands raised i can
address those questions but we are
running behind schedule in respect to
judge king who
already tried to testify last hearing
because we ran behind schedule i believe
i would really want to have that as a
respect for the judge and as a member of
the public to let that member test that
remember the public testify
representative is there a way to
allow
the video feed for the witness
uh i can promote uh judge king to be a
panelist and judge king will have the
option of turning his video on or
turning it off but we should be able to
and these are these are the continued
public hearings
judge king you may need to unmute
yourself
okay am i good now
yes thank you all right thank you very
much uh good morning mr chairman members
of the committee my name is david king
i'm the administrative judge of the new
hampshire circuit court and i i did hang
in with you last week until about noon
and then i had to jump on another
meeting so thank you for this
opportunity to come back
in the meantime we did judge neto and i
did submit some written testimony so i'm
assuming that you have that and i'll hit
some high points and then
i'm happy to answer any questions that
you might have
i did sign in in opposition to the bills
not to be difficult but we do have some
concerns about both of them
i was involved as were many of the
sponsors of this bill in the senate bill
112 committee a couple summers ago that
senator carson shared
and i think one of the things we talked
a lot about was getting bail
commissioners paid and we are in favor
of that
there's a fiscal note that we prepared
that would
estimates the
amount that the court would have to pay
to be about 850 000
that's based upon the number of criminal
cases that the circuit court and
superior court have and an estimate of
the number of folks who are indigent i
do want to make this committee aware
that there's a another bill that might
affect that fiscal note senate bill one
two one two two would raise the bail
commissioner's fees from forty dollars
to sixty five dollars
in the event that that bill were to pass
the fiscal note would jump to
approximately 1.4 million dollars so i
just wanted you to be aware and
sensitive to the fact that that bill's
working its way
uh through the legislature as well the
concerns that we have are more about the
process for appointing bail
commissioners and the fact that this
bill would set up 10
separate commissions around the state
each
staffed by at least one superior court
judge
as well as a county attorney and a
public defender
our one of our concerns is that having a
county attorney and or a public defender
overseeing bail commissioners
seems to be a bit of a conflict i heard
some of the testimony last week that one
of the concerns is if a bail
commissioner for example were
continually setting pr bail and the
state didn't agree with that that they
could be removed so if you had a county
attorney who wanted to have an effect on
how bail was set they would have an
ability perhaps to remove that bill
commission that seems to be
troublesome to me
one of the witnesses last week who was a
bail commissioner did
testify that in the event that the judge
or clerk sees bail orders coming in from
bail commissioners that appear to be
troublesome
judges are not shy about getting the
bail commissioner in and speaking with
him or her about
those issues
the other thing that i think
you should understand is that it's the
police that actually make the phone call
typically in the middle of the night to
the bail commissioner and our experience
is if there are bail commissioners that
either are not responsive
or are not
operating effectively
the police stop calling them and we get
a we get a call and we're asked to try
to find another bail commissioner
there was a suggestion that there's a
there's difficulty finding bail
commissioners we haven't really had that
issue i appointed a couple within the
last week or so
um one in nashua that i remember signing
last week and and judge neto i and i do
that together
um
the other thing uh i guess with regard
to the
the issue that i'm hearing and reading
about it with
pr bail being said in more serious
matters i know there are some bail
reform bills working their way through
the legislature as well and
maybe those would have an effect on that
the bill would transfer a lot of the
administrative duties over to the
superior court which
would be fine with me and our staff
but the committee should know that
the circuit court has about 65 000
criminal cases a year the superior court
has about 9 500.
so we have about 90 percent
of the bail orders and it seems fair
that we do
90 of the administrative work they're
currently 112 bail commissioners in the
state of new hampshire it's a five-year
term
so about 20 to 25 bail commissioners
come up for renewal each year
and we process those applications we do
criminal record checks we make sure that
they have a current justice of the peace
appointment which is a prerequisite to
being a bail commissioner
and we issue the
the card that they get and that work is
done by circuit court administrator the
administration
um
another concern that we have with the
bill is it seems to be written in such a
way that if someone
claims indigence that that's the wording
in the bill then the court shall pay
so it doesn't really seem to require
that someone has to be indigent it just
seems to suggest that if they say hey
i'm indigent then the requirement is
automatically shifted to the court and
we have to pay
there's no definition of indigence
and so we have a concern that a lot of
people would be getting
their bail commission fees paid by the
state when perhaps they weren't
uh in a position where they that they
may have been able to pay the
the fee and that they weren't indigent
there was also a suggestion that the
office of cost containment could pay the
fees and we've explained in the written
materials that we sent in last week that
that's not the way occ works we would
have to pay the bail commissioner fee
they would have to be enabling language
or rules to transfer the responsibility
to recoup that to occ
and then they would get the money back
into their funds which would go to the
general fund so they wouldn't pay the
fees in the first instance it would be
on the court to do that
and with regard to house bill 469
if you shorten the term of the bill
commissioners to two years as opposed to
five
you basically have increased the work by
two and a half times because we'll have
to go through that process every two
years
instead of every five years
i think the five-year term was chosen
because it coincides with the length of
time that the
jp
runs and it seemed to make sense to have
a five-year term
we do and have removed bail
commissioners for doing
um things that are inappropriate in the
past so we have the ability to do that
and take them off the list and as i said
if they're not effective or they're not
responsive they just don't get called by
the police so i think those are our
concerns i'm happy to answer any
questions that the committee has and
right here
[Music]
okay thank you thank you for uh taking
so when a
person is
brought in by the police
and they call the
the bail people
do they always check
with
you know you or one of the judges
thank you for the question
representative no they they never check
with us before the bail is set they are
quasi judicial officers and they are
empowered by virtue of their appointment
to make those
bail determinations
on their own
so typically the calls are
not during court hours if it's during
court hours the police would generally
bring the person to the courthouse to be
bailed so the call comes in let's say a
midnight
and the bail commissioner
speaks with the state the police officer
interviews the defendant and makes a
decision about whether the person
is a danger to themselves or others or a
flight risk and if not typically we'll
set pr bail
and then there's a review process in the
court if someone's not satisfied with
the bail that was set by the bail
commissioner but it's they act on their
own once they're appointed
all right thank you mr chairman
uh judge you mentioned that you had a
problem i think with the bail
commissions and maybe how they worked
and maybe the number of them
and you had
concerns about five years doubling uh
two and a half times the uh the work
if we shorten the term
and i also think i remember you're
saying that you have an issue of the
shall pay issue
and how the payment of incident
indigent people are paid without proof
if those items were modified or removed
um
would then
you still be opposed to the bill or do
you think that it can be approved or
it's workable
i think representative newman that the
portion of the bill dealing with payment
can be made workable
um
i just don't
want to see the court in the position of
being required to pay a bail fee simply
because someone says
i'm claiming indigen they could be
you know gainfully employed and paying
all of their bills but if they say i
can't pay this
the bill seems to suggest that they
automatically get the payment from the
court
so and there's no definition of indigent
so
we have a definition of indigency be
before we appoint counsel
for a defendant
is should it be the same definition or
should it be a lower standard we i think
most of our judges feel that most people
should be able to come up with forty
dollars the bill commissioners are doing
a huge service by getting up in the
middle of the night and setting bail so
that they can
most of the time be released on their
own recognizance and forty dollars is a
pretty small fee to pay
and our judges are hopefully working
much harder to get the bail
commissioner's fees paid now
i know they don't always get paid and
someone should pay them in the event
that someone is truly unable to come up
with the forty dollars but i think
the legislature should at least consider
whether you
should tell us what indigency is whether
it should be the same standard as a
pointing council or should it be a lower
standard to pay that forty dollars and
we'd be happy to try to work with you to
try to figure that out but the way the
bill's worded right now i think a lot of
people will begin will be getting a pass
on paying their bail fee at our expense
when they should probably be paying it
themselves
represent you many of the follow-up
questions
i do i do have a follow-up i'm sorry i
was unmuted mr chairman i was not
anything may i have my follow-up
yes
um
judge
i remember an issue in the last hearing
about the bail commissions the number of
them
and uh and how they could you just
elaborate just a little bit on the
commissions
and on the five-year versus two-year
issue
okay if i understand the question
representative newman we there are 112
bail commissioners on the roster right
now that service both the circuit and
superior courts because it's a five-year
term in their staggered appointments
between 20 and 25 a year come up for
renewal
and then we go through the process of
that and as bail commissioners drop off
in a region for example the monadnock
region is now short
mid-stream we may be asked to to round
up a bail commissioner or two and we
typically ask the local judges for
recommendations because they they're in
the communities and then we do the
screening and make the appointments
i'm not sure if i answer your question
seeing no questions i want to thank the
judge for your time and your testimony
mr chairman i see nobody with their hand
raised let me double check but i do not
no
seeing no members of the public with
that would definitely close the public
hearing on house bill 469
and
to the representative joel alexander who
has had his hand raised
we apologize for our the chair as well
as the
technical assistant we apologize for our
oversight but once we close the public
hearing it's uh
we would have to re there's a process to
reopen it
oh
mr chairman the hand was not raised it
was raised after you closed it he raised
it well i i know but even if it even if
[Music]
representative newman do you have the
i'll get the mute on the unmute figured
out here shortly
at the time that the hearing was closed
i had my hand up both on the screen
and both and on the computer
and and that's okay but i i think that
we need to kind of smooth out the
process of
how you're able to recognize people that
have their hands up should it is it most
if you have a question of how we're
going to conduct the hearing we can do
that
while the hearing is not well not during
a public hearing
if you want to if you wish to testify on
behalf of the bill you can sign to
testify and do that whether you remember
the committee or not if you're speaking
representative newman you were not
recognized for a follow-up question i
opened the hearing i opened today's
session by explaining
that in order to ask a question or to
speak the member must be recognized by
the chair
to speak if if they have a follow-up
question the member must be recognized
for the follow-up question that's a
long-established parliamentary rule that
is followed in every committee it was
fought last year
last term in this committee so
i assume there's no misunderstanding
with that i do not want to keep
addressing
representative knight you have a
question
uh yes mr chairman with respect i have
three so if i can pause and then ask you
follow up there's just um
the first one is the title for the bills
on the on your zoom
you just had it up and i think that's
great i just wanted to make sure that's
up for the public
um so
thank you for doing that that's not
really a question anymore it wasn't up
at the beginning so if i may just go
right into my second question
so
this is how we're gonna you'll recognize
it for the first question and it was not
a question
so
again we if you're gonna if you have a
question you put your hand up to ask a
question
and you're recognized for a question not
a statement
we need to follow these rules of this
this committee is the chaos the entire
term
it's going to be strictly enforced i
should not keep warning members
about how the parliamentary rules are
representative knight you have a
follow-up question
thank you mr chairman for learning
purposes this is my second term and all
committees have different chairs with
different rules if we have a question on
fairness in the interest of time
and
the the rules on parliamentary procedure
applies in every committee
where a member needs to be recognized to
speak some chairs may be more relaxed
than others
and i'm not going to speak on behalf of
any other chair i'm telling everyone
that i'm going to strictly enforce that
rule
after especially after what happened
and the only exceptions those rules we
have two technical assistants one is
representative muse
one is representative birth and then the
clerk other than that there should be no
exception
and if we want to talk about
listen we have a lot of work to do what
we're going to do i'm not going to
recognize any more hands we're going to
move on to the executive session
we don't want to fall behind schedule
mr chair you had asked me to remind you
uh
to uh read the people supporting than
the people opposing
each of these bills uh my question is
would you like me to read the uh the
totals for hb 469
thank you representative and
first of all thank you for reminding me
and i i did tell you to remind me and
thank you for doing that and uh yes if
you don't mind if he's reading
the
numbers of support for each house bill
for hb 469 we had two people signing in
uh in support uh and two people signing
and opposing
for
hb uh 498 we had three people signing in
in support and we had one person signing
thank you representatives and if and
throughout the day if i do forget to uh
provide that information to the public
please
let me know and we'll make sure we do
that
so we are now going to open the
executive session for house bill
and the chair recognizes representative
you're good
thank you very much uh mr chairman
i'd like to move that the bill be ilt or
expedient to legislate
is there a second representative marston
thank you mr chairman for second in
motion representative
thank you representative
representative teslan would you wish to
speak on your motion
as the judge
just said
this would
change his workload by two and a half
times as far as the review of
commissioners
uh i think this is too much
we they're already having difficulty
filling some of the slots although he
indicated they can fill them
i think
monitor their performance and
and uh
you know tell them in direct and
indirect ways that how you're setting
the bail or not setting the bail is
correct or incorrect this is the wrong
the chair will now open the question for
discussion do any members wish to
speak
seeing no further uh seeing no hands
raised there's no further discussion the
clerk will call the role
if you are in support of the motion to
itl
or unexpedient legislate
please say yay
vice chairman welch yeah
representative burke yes
representative popper yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman
yes roy yes
representative pratt yes
representative morton yes
the clerk votes yes
representative pantholakis
yes
representative o'hearn
i apologize
representative a
yes
representative muse
representative newman
yes
representative bowden yeah
representative connolly yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman avis
by a vote of 20 years
zero nays
uh the motion of any kid's relationship
past
passes
would that like would that be going on
representative newman you recognize for
i
well help me understand are we still in
a public session right now or is this
the appropriate i asked i was going to
ask the question about how to be
recognized
if that's inappropriate i'll wait until
the appropriate time and i appreciate it
if you tell me when that is
in the executive session you would raise
your hand if you wish to speak on the
question that is open for discussion
during the public hearing it's the same
process you would raise your hand
if you wish to ask a question of the
witness testify
if you want to discuss questions of
the policies and how the committee is
going to conduct itself
it's the chair's position that can be
done
at a time that's not necessarily
during a public hearing but if your hand
is raised with the question
of the witness
you will be recognized for the question
to question the witness
if during the executive session if you
have if you wish to speak or make a
motion you can raise your hand to be
recognized
may i ask a follow-up question
representative newman i will say if you
have a follow-up question
rather than speaking and saying i'm just
asking the members to simply raise their
hand i can see
very clearly on the screen that right in
front of me when you raise your hand and
i have a tv
i would say it's about a 42 inch
television i can also see that and on
that tv the setting is that whoever is
speaking
it's enlarged so it's almost as if
you're sitting in the room so i can see
your hand raised
i will recognize you for a follow-up
question
i will do that i'm just saying do not
speak and say mr chairman and because
that is interrupting and that is
speaking out of order and i've already
addressed that issue twice today already
so if you have a follow-up question
please raise your hand and i will
recognize
representative newman you're recognizing
mr chairman i understand everything you
said today i'm not trying to delay
anything
what i
i i know you say you can see the the
hands and i
twice now i've had both hands up and
didn't get recognized maybe that was
the discretion of the chair
or maybe there is something missed and i
know the technical person
said hands were not up when they were up
in the computer so i i would just like
to
figure out how to straighten that out at
some point in the future when you tell
me that that's appropriate
and i appreciate your consideration and
i think overall that this hearing i was
just trying to help
with smoothing out some of the processes
of this committee and i apologize for
that thank you
representative newman in respect when
your hand was raised you weren't
recognized i did say clearly
that i acknowledged that members had
their hands raised but i wasn't
recognizing them so
i didn't mean any disrespect by not
acknowledging you but it's not that i
could not see your hand raised i made it
clear to the members that they it was
not oversight that i could actually we
were just moving the hearing along
and the other part i just want to point
out if if the member understands the
rules of being recognized and went to
speak then i would hope that the members
follow those tips
thank you mr chairman for that
qualification
we are now going to move into the
executive we're not going to open the
executive session for house bill
and chair recognizes representative
burke for a motion
thank you mr chairman i would like to
make a motion for house bill 498 ought
to pass
second
representative wallace you wish to
second that motion and representative
wallace i just remind you that if you
wish the second
second most please raise your hand and
representative do you wish to speak on
this motion i do mr chairman thank you
and
mr chairman committee members uh the
reason i feel ought to pass on this is
is it is a good bill
the
bail commissioners need to be paid
i feel the courts have an avenue
to
make the individuals pay this
um
because they can you know basically
stiff the bail commissioner and and
there's nothing the bail commissioner
can do
yet
you can't stiff a court
you know if i get a speeding ticket i
better pay that ticket because if i
don't the port's going to come and get
me
and
you know they have a lot more different
avenues of collecting money so that's
why i support this bill and not to pass
thank you mr
um
after listening to judge keane's uh
testimony i
can't support this bill
at least as it's written today
either it should be amended or it should
be uh
retained our other choice would be to
representative muse
i i have to say i agree with uh
representative gordon a um
the
[Music]
the elements of the bill that deal
specifically with uh paying bail
commissioners uh do seem to be fixable
uh in an amendment and i think one of
the
the frustrations of the process for all
of us this year is going to be the fact
that
we just don't have the space between
hearings and executive sessions that
we've had in previous years to fix
things
um
judge king did indicate a willingness to
to work with us on specific language
that would fix that part of the bill
there really does seem to be a a real
need for this
and this actually would would solve a
real problem uh for bill commissioners
out there right now who are having huge
issues with getting paid
um
but some of the other elements of the
bill uh as we've learned in testimony
are pretty problematic so
uh
it's going to be very hard for me to
support the bill in its current form
um and i'm not sure if we have any
options
other than just simply to
to move on the motion um but i i did
want to note that this is not
this is probably an issue that is going
to keep popping up again and again
where we have bills that normally would
be
would be very fixable that we could act
on
where we may be acting on them
prematurely
representative
thank you mr
chairman uh i do find that this bill has
some problems in it as well
and
i was kind of hoping that we would ipl
it but
10 i think they want 10 different
districts to oversee this
and i believe the judge spoke against
that at some point or maybe it was his
representative last time we were here
talking about it
i just think the bill needs some work
and a lot of amendments so i have some
thank you
representative
yeah
[Music]
i think could be exchanged if you just
deleted all that just left uh
if i just may ask a question uh
representative muse i i understand that
there was
at some point there was a commission
that was
created in
on that commission representatives you
remember that and i believe a lot many
of the bills
the sponsors is built out of that
commission right correct when i say that
representatives
that's correct
so i i'm just now just asking a question
but
when that commission met i assume
that
was just i would judge king in
participating in that
those those hearings
yes
the main focus of those hearings was
really on how to get bail commissioners
paid uh there were also some issues
around uh bill commissioner training
that we were trying to address
uh
the there are some things in the bill
you know for instance the setup of the
of the ten
county-wide uh uh commissions that were
not part
of those hearings so there's some there
are some things in this bill
uh that are uh that are different from
what we talked about i um i was uh i
decided to co-sponsor it uh because i
thought we might we would have an
opportunity to fix some of those things
or address those things or ask the
sponsor
uh you know a few more questions around
what the thought was behind that so
um
but i i do think that the bill in its in
its current form
uh
kind of goes above and beyond what we
talked about in the commission in some
respects and
uh and
the the whole issue of trying to get
uh
trying to get bail commissioners paid i
think what everybody wanted out of that
was a better process for defining in
agency and making sure that people who
are able to pay uh were paying
but the the problem remain and i think
we heard testimony from one witness
during the public hearing
where he hasn't been able to collect
nearly half the fees uh that he was
eligible to collect over the last five
years so
there's a there's a pr there's a
lingering problem that it would be great
to address um and and i think we we
tried to do that and we've been poking
at it um and this pill probably
represented
you know
one of the better chances to do that but
as we found out from judge king
there
there's some things that should be in
the bill if we're going to do that like
defining in
indigency that do not appear in the bill
so
it makes it a little problematic to pass
it at this point
representative hughes may ask you a
follow-up
oh sure
not to put you on the spot but if if
there was an amendment that you would
consider
may i ask what about the bill in its
current form
that you would seek to amend and the
issue with this bill just you know
it does have an early deadline
so
we
just something to keep in mind
i would
with that in mind i would i would
basically strike the things that don't
involve the payment of bail
commissioners um and work with judge
king to come up with uh language that
would be uh appropriate for the court
and uh that would uh
result in at least that
this one part of the issue being
addressed um
we had our commission meeting you know
almost two years ago this issue with
bill commissioners not getting paid has
been going on for a long long time
and
it would be nice if we could
find a solution to help these folks get
paid
thank you representatives for
yes i i i agree that we should probably
do something in in the form of some kind
of
amendment or other pro uh parliamentary
procedure that would allow us to do some
correction with this bill
however based on the fact that we're in
with the pandemic and
people being remote
and time crunching all of that i always
support whatever could be done to do
that but i think that
we also really ought to try to figure
out if there's some way to get the
people paid
representative roy
thank you uh
i'm
here for the first part of this
apparently but
based on the testimony i heard from the
judge regarding the definition of
english yeah i would be hard-pressed to
support this as well
once the defense markets gets the word
out that all you have to do is say
you're engineering indigent there will
be never any bail paid again
because there's no definition so
cool
it's really problematic
not all defense attorneys would do that
but well
so right now we in order to introduce an
amendment we do need to have a positive
motion
presented which we have one
and watch it pass
we have a deadline of february 18th
where this needs to be
reported we are meeting again on monday
on february 8th
so if
representative music there is a
amendment that you
offer
i would i would say that we could we
could suspend the executive session on
costco 498.
i'll give you an opportunity to get that
amendment or if you're able to get today
we can even reopen it
but i wouldn't i would be
inclined to at least suspend the
executive session
until
monday
february
does the motion have to be withdrawn
yeah
so the point of order is
by representative welch is that the
positive motion needs to be withdrawn
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman that i was going
to offer a withdrawal of my second to
representative burke do you wish to
withdraw your motion about the pass yes
i will mr chairman thank you and
representative wallace you wish to
second that motion
yes
you must take a roll call vote on the
motion to withdraw
anyone wish to speak up on on this
representative
thank you mr chairman um i will will you
know i will support the withdrawal of
this and so that way we could um
hopefully draft an amendment before
monday or wednesday when we meet next
um
nevermind
thank you
representative rhodes mr chairman i
think you may ask just for one minute to
converse with representative burt just
so you know further discussion on the
motion to withdraw
the motion about to pass yes
once the court is not getting
clarification from the technical
technology member
the course will call the role if you are
in favor of
the motion to withdraw
the motion ought to pass if you say yay
vice chairman welch yes
representative burke yes
representative hopper yes
representative green yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative roy
representative pratt yeah
representative martin yes
the clerk votes yes
representative harry harriet guthrie yes
representative hannah lopez
yes
representative
representative muse
yes
representative newman
representative bowden yes
representative connolly yes
representative klein knight
yes representative bradley
yes
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
mr chairman 20-0
by a vote of 22-0 the emotion of a
motion to withdraw the motion about to
pass
masses
i think just so just for the record and
the public understands when members are
voting uh remotely they are required to
have the video on on their electronic
device
but i will just state to the public that
representative testerman representative
holden representative roy
represent conley they're physically
present in the room so that actually
would not apply to those members however
it does create a little bit of confusion
to the public so maybe
if you don't mind leaving the device on
representative knight
hi thank you chair
i was just a little confused so are we
going to get an amendment for this bill
and then um
see that or am i that's not happening
what
what well i'm not going to guarantee
that anyone's going to do anything but
my understanding is that representative
muse who is a co-sponsor of the bill
uh
raised some concerns about his own
about the bill itself and
wishes to
bring in uh
present an amendment to this committee
considering that we are meeting uh will
be meeting again on monday
february 8th
the chair believed that it would be best
to rather than have a bill
fail
if
the amendment could be brought forward
to address some of those concerns
i didn't see a problem doing that
follow-up chair so we can have exec
again on that
representative knight
we're going to go this one last time
if you have a follow-up question
you don't need to
say speak out of order and say i have a
follow-up question by doing that by
simply speaking and saying i have a
follow-up question you are speaking out
of order
what i ask is
you put your hand up i can physically
see you on two different screens at the
same time so there's two of you in the
room where i can see not one you're
there and you're here
all right so i'm not i'm trusting i can
see you just fine
but i don't want members speaking out of
order if it keeps happening
i'm gonna i'm gonna personally go down
to the speaker's office myself and
request that member be removed from the
committee because we have a lot of
important work to do
we have a lot we have a lot of bills in
this committee we're not gonna have time
to get to everything because everyone
wants to speak out of order this was not
a problem last year in this last term in
this committee i can't believe it's such
a problem this this term so please
do your best
just raise your hand
you will be recognized including for
your following
representative knight you have a
follow-up question
thank you mr chair apologies are we
going to exec the bill
under the
presumption that representative muse may
offer an amendment
representative pantalavis
mr chairman
i certainly hope so
it should
what what has been happening is the
amendment is being will be emailed
uh wherever
i'm not sure what representative museum
have an opportunity to
uh
speak with uh
legislative services to obviously get
that amendment presented to us but we
will be able to exec
open the executive session any point in
time on
the great games so if we have time to do
it we'll we'll make sure to squeeze it
it is up against the deadline so it
could take priority over executive other
bills
representative muse i'm excuse me
thank you mr chair
if if no amendment is forthcoming it's
my understanding that we will execute
the bill
as usual it will resume on on monday is
yes
the reason
i will say if no one's going to offer
them and we might as well execute the
bill right now we do have 25 minutes at
the next public hearing so i would
certainly hope
and i trust that representative muse
would not have
he represented to me that he intends on
coming forward amendment and i have no
reason to
think that he will not
representative muse
my intention is to try to get an
amendment um
uh worked out
at some point today and uh to try to get
that over
to uh ols uh
uh on uh on monday morning the issue is
uh how quickly they'll be able to act on
it um but
if we could tentatively plan on
executing the bill at the end of the day
on monday
um it may or may not give us enough time
but i think we owe it to the folks
thank you representative
and in respect
the executive session on house bill 498
it will be recess
to
at least monday february 8th
20.
i and i i asked the members
that are in the room if when you well
we're in recess when you get up from
your committee chair to please turn off
the video recording on all of your
equipment i also want to remind the
members that if when you are not sitting
in a community chair please make sure
you are wearing
a mask in accordance with the rules as
described by the speaker's office thank
you
oh
if we're on break can i ask a question
of the chair we're not on recess
we're on a recorded zoom so we should
66.
that does not revert we'll
thank you mr chairman
an absent of the prime sponsor
i would like to introduce
house bill 66 an act relative to the use
of deadly force by law enforcement
officers
do we have any of the
responses
uh mr chairman
yes um being the
zoom tech guy
uh i do see
you know a couple hands there if you
want me to unmute one of them just call
their
name we have two well this is this i
have difficulty seeing the screen yeah
so
if you'd like i could call it
representative edwards is the first one
we have two people listed to speak
in for it
i've got that yeah
so aren't they supposed to talk to us
well mr chairman um
if i may be recognized yeah um from what
i understand is representative edwards
is on the bill
so i think he's going to speak
you know to the bill in behalf of the uh
representative true that is the prime
sponsor and that's usually customary is
that we would let them speak
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative bert
representative true couldn't be here
today so he asked me to introduce this
bill it's already been introduced so i'd
like to just go ahead and speak to it
i believe that this is a
a pro law enforcement bill
a lot of people will see it differently
but but
please believe me when i say i think
it's actually pro law enforcement this
past year
we've seen
examples of excessive force
causing great disturbance in
violence to domestic tranquility
and what this bill does is it looks at
reforming uh law enforcement rules of
engagement and
and i i use the term rules of engagement
when we were in afghanistan we were
authorized to use deadly force
but in order to use deadly force we
needed at least three things to be true
we needed a specific target
we had to identify the target as a
threat and that we had to ensure that
there would be no collateral damage if
we shot and missed
so so unless those rules of engagement
were all met
we could not return fire
so um so i see this bill is essentially
rules of engagement for law enforcement
consistent with the new hampshire
constitution
uh article 18
that says all penalties are to be
proportional to the offense
and so so what what representative true
has done in the writing of this bill
is to say
dear law enforcement officer if you need
to use force to prevent the escape of
somebody that you believe to be a threat
to society
you're able to do that there's no change
however if your only goal is to make an
arrest
then you should not be using deadly
force to affect an arrest
and
representative abramson i think has an
amendment that he's going to introduce
to this but
i i
i did want to explain
um that that overview that we
don't view this as an infringement on
what law enforcement would do in the
field
other than to say
in this excessive force scenario
don't use force because it can cause all
kinds of social distress
well beyond
um the uh
the moment
so uh with that i i can take some
questions um this bill was looked at
last year and did not pass just for what
are there any questions
papa
thank you mr chair uh thank you
representative edwards for taking my
question
i don't know how well you can hear me so
i'll speak up
um
have there been instances in new
hampshire
where the police have used deadly force
to apprehend somebody who was not a
um
that's a that's a great question
as a co-sponsor i didn't dig into the
side details i think i'm generally aware
of a case about three years ago
where uh somebody was uh
dealing narcotics
in in and fled the scene
and was shot as they were fleeing
um i
only think that that fits your your
description in your question but i i i
can't tell you that as a verified truth
i i think i think that's an example
thank you
representative
you're muted sir
thank you for taking my question um
uh
one of the things that i'm trying to
figure out as i look at this bill is why
is it okay
to shoot
a fleeing person
you know who
wouldn't seem to be
an actual threat to the life of the
officer um
but
not okay
to
you know to uh you know to use force um
when affecting an arrest i'm i'm sort of
in in the camp where i'm not really sure
where i see the need for either one of
these things
um
and my other question would be
uh the question first okay
so i i think we're actually in agreement
as i listen to your question uh it
sounds to me like you're questioning
uh
why use deadly force in order to arrest
somebody
and unless you think they're a threat to
others and you're trying to prevent
their escape you should not use deadly
force but if you do think they are
trying to escape
and they are a threat to others or to
yourself
then
deadly force is still permitted so we're
so we're changing from the current
standard of affecting an arrest can lead
to deadly force we're just removing that
portion of it
so so i i think you and i are in an
agreement based on my understanding your
question but but then i'll take a second
follow up mr chair yes further questions
um part of the bill also repeals section
uh rsa uh 627 uh colon five
uh roman numeral eight that basically
says uh
uh if the officer reasonably believes
that the arrest is lawful and there's no
other means of affecting arrest
using reasonable force
it basically seems to
require the officer to use a reasonable
force if necessary and
i'm curious
why that portion of the of the uh of the
rsa is eliminated from this bill
hey that's a great question i don't know
your answer uh i can uh ask
representative true to get back to you
on that though
thank you
wrap it down roy
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question
my question is a i guess i'll put it in
a scenario format um i'm gonna say i'm a
police officer and i'm carrying a taser
and i'm trying to infect arrest and the
suspect takes my taser
under the way this was written it says
that i can only
use
lethal force if i believe that
and someone's about to use deadly force
on me
while a taser isn't considered deadly
force but my training experience would
tell me that if i'm tased i'm going to
be unable to defend myself further so is
it the position of this bill that if
someone were to take my taser
or my baton
i'm not able to deploy a firearm against
them
so so uh thank you for the question uh i
think i'm neither of us are attorneys as
i understand and so i'm looking at
um the the
roman numeral two b 1
and it it's it says
to me that the use of force is
authorized if the uh the person
upon which the force is exercised is
likely to seriously endanger life or
inflict seriously bodily injury
so so in the scenario you painted
uh if a perpetrator has uh
a taser from the law enforcement officer
you taken
i i would think that uh
reasonable people would say that that
that perpetrator is uh is now a threat a
serious threat
and you salute lethal force in that
scenario would be authorized by this
bill by this
bill yes
that's my interpretation representative
roy
another question
yes please
thank you representative i'm incorrect
neither of us are lawyers however i was
i was a law enforcement officer and i
have a little bit of experience in this
arena the the
one of the arguments law enforcement
uses in favor of the taser is that it's
not
a uh lethal weapon and it does not cause
serious bodily injury
so my concern is that we we're leaving a
kind of a gray area in here that's going
to be left up to the courts
to decide where we should be deciding
so
would you would you agree that
that it has been positioned in law
enforcement that tasers or not do not
cause serious body injury
i will occasionally have a smoke smoke a
cigar and have a drink with my law
enforcement buddies and in all of those
conversations i think it's all agreed
that a taser is not deadly force
the the the point of inventing the taser
was to create non-lethal force and so
i i wouldn't think the use of a taser
would uh violate this law if passed this
thank you mr chair um and thank you for
taking my question
the
when you take out the affecting arrest
part and and just leave in the escape
part
do you think that that erases the line
between um
affecting an arrest and an escape
how does the officer tell when he's
reached
uh
that point
um and i'll clarify with an example i
just talked to my son-in-law who's a
police officer and said he's trying to
effect an arrest and he's overpowered
at what point does this law apply if you
take the affecting
arrest part out of it so i have a
problem trying to how do you find that
line
yes sir thank you representative newman
i i would i would give a very similar
answer to one i've already given where i
think roman numeral
ii bravo one
essentially says if the person you're
arresting is likely to do serious
uh is to seriously endanger human life
or inflict serious bodily injury
um
then
the green light is lit and the rules of
engagement go into effect and the use of
of lethal force in that scenario is
authorized
thank you vice chair our chairman uh uh
mike thank you for taking my question
representative
i just want to understand that even if a
fleeing person is not a risk and that is
uh proven a fact even after the act has
been committed
just the officers feelings of them being
a threat validate being shot in the back
and
i i just want to know your that is that
how i'm understanding this
so thank you for the question uh i
am in the
large group of people who believe that
we ask law enforcement to do
an incredibly difficult job
they when they're out on the patrol
they're everything from
you know somebody who would
you know look in on a kid playing in the
front yard
to having to deal with these scenarios
where deadly force may be required
and so we
we give them deadly force
and the authority to use it because
we trust in their
the selection process we trust in the
training
we trust in their judgment we trust in
their humanity to to be able to uh
exercise lethal force judiciously and
so if um
if a if the law enforcement officer uh
were to testify and say that in their
their their intent
in using lethal force
to stop
a fleeing
perpetrator was because of the belief
that that person would was a threat to
others
i think the tendency would be to believe
their
their judgment in the in the heat of the
moment
and um and of course there are bad
actors but that's why we have jury
trials so
i i i just think that this is a way of
protecting the integrity of the police
force by making sure that the rules of
engagement
are done in a way in which i think
most people would agree
don't use lethal force just so you can
arrest somebody however
if you think somebody is running away
and they're dangerous
by all means use the force necessary to
to secure the public safety so
i hope that answers your question
thank you for rep uh
thank you for asking me i do have a
follow-up
um
thank you representative again so you
just gave testimony that there are bad
actors police actors in our state don't
you think this would embolden them to
i think quite the opposite it would be
setting in in place
uh a clear
rule of engagement that that removes the
authority to use deadly force
uh in a particular scenario
that is devoid
of a threat by the perpetrator
so
so there are bad actors in every segment
of society to include the legislature so
i don't i don't think we govern
for the you know just the bad actors we
govern for
the preponderance of societal
interaction
no thank you so much and thanks for
thank you mr chair thank you
representative editors for uh willing to
entertain my question
my reading of this bill indicates that
it
reduces the number the amount of reasons
that an officer can use deadly force is
that not true
yes sir that's i believe that's accurate
yes
is there any other questions
seeing none uh
call
max abramson
you mr chair i just wanted to say i'm
going to stick around in case you you
need to call me back but i don't think
you will i'm just here if you need it
that's all sir thank you
are you folks able to hear me
yes
all right i'm representative max
abramson representing hampton hampton
falls and seabrook
i thought that i was a co-sponsor on
this bill but i think i was a co-sponsor
on last year's version of this i wasn't
able to come into the committee and
testify last year
um by the way i support the bill
not because i agree with its intent but
because the
u.s supreme court took up this issue in
and ruled in 1985
that police were not allowed to use
deadly force
simply to stop a fleeing felon
i included both the majority decision in
an email that i sent last night at 509
pm
and i also included
the
dissenting arguments by justices
rehnquist and o'connor um as i said i i
prefer the the logic and reasoning that
that was used in the minority report but
i'm just dealing with what the
the u.s supreme court tells us
um
i also just sent an email to members of
the committee
um
noting that in their notes the us
supreme court actually cites rsa 620
7 section 5 part 2 and this part in
particular as
a provision that is unconstitutional the
minority used our statute and the
statutes i think 24 other states as
justification for
half the state legislatures have agreed
as new hampshire did at the time
that if you have a fleeing felon that
the officer
needs to have some legal ability to use
deadly force to stop a fleeing felon
however the the police unions and the um
the
defending party in tennessee versus
gardner
uh was
um
they were given the opportunity to bring
in studies showing that a fleeing felon
was so likely to go on and commit
another crime
that
[Music]
that an officer would be allowed to use
deadly force because of the likelihood
of them going out and committing another
crime
not to get into the details but this
dates back to common law when a felony
uh in early times is almost always a
life sentence or capital offense it was
almost always kidnapping rape murder
some really horrible crime
now that almost everything is a felony
the
courts are now looking at a felony
differently other countries are looking
at a felony differently an american
felony is just doesn't hold the weight
that it used to
so
what we
you know a misdemeanor back in in
colonial times in early america would be
you know potentially 10 years of
prison or possibly 10 years of hard
labor
so misdemeanor had a much greater reach
at that time
um
so
the the the bill needs to pass um
in in one form or another i have
introduced an amendment that simply
changes the word and to or
so that if you had a police officer
interacting with
um
with someone right now the statute says
um oops i've lost the statute
there it is
that the
officer
the officer has made a reasonable effort
to advise the person that he is a law
enforcement officer attempting to affect
an arrest and has reasonable grounds to
believe that the person is aware of the
facts
when this same issue came up several
years ago i believe one member of the
committee or or maybe two or three
were concerned that an officer would
show up to make an arrest wearing their
uniform having their badge obviously
being an officer that they shouldn't
have to then
in the heat of the moment they shouldn't
have to also
tell the person that they're a cop uh
once it's obvious that they're in
uniform and that they're very
conspicuously serving as an officer
so that that's the reason for the
amendment
the amendment would help police just a
little bit in a life and death emergency
but i
wanted to
um
quickly read off what
the the u.s supreme court said
they said in 1985 the use of deadly
force to prevent the escape of all
felony suspects whatever the
circumstances is constitutionally
unreasonable
it is not better that all felony
suspects die that than that they escape
where the suspect poses no immediate
threat to the officer and no threat to
others the harm resulting from failing
to apprehend him does not justify the
use of deadly force to do so it is no
doubt unfortunate when a suspect who is
in sight escapes but the fact that the
police arrive a little late or a little
slower afoot does not always justify
killing the suspect a police officer may
not seize an unarmed non-dangerous
suspect by shooting him dead the
tennessee statute is unconstitutional
insofar as it authorizes the use of
deadly force against such fleeing
suspects and again they they cited our
statute new hampshire statute also
um
in this case so i don't i don't think
there's any question that that the
wording that we have in the in the rsa
right now is unconstitutional
the problem of leaving that in place
is that a lot of police departments then
go back and refer to our statutes and
assume that all of our rsas must be
constitutional that they must
stand up and you have
department policies that are being
written and insurance policies and
contracts that are written around our
our rsas
so
it's it's it's a justification
um
if the committee absolutely wants to
ensure it there's
there is a way around it
we authorize
qualified immunity and other certain
powers to the badge you can also assign
it to the person but if you're going to
assign the ability to shoot a fleeing
felon
i believe that you'd have to assign it
to
absolutely everyone
meaning that any joe shmoe on the street
if they're affecting a citizen's arrest
if they witness a felony that they would
have the authority to
shoot someone in the back as they're
running away and i'm i'm not
i'm not sure about all the
pros and cons or how the members of the
committee would see that
so the the amendment number is 225 h
and it's just one word it changes the
word and to or
boardney
thank you
thank you mr representative
um
and i know we're really talking about
the bill but uh introduction of this
lessen the effect of the bill by
changing
and or
the officer doesn't have to
consider that the
flinging felon is going to be using
deadly force uh using and requires both
of those conditions to happen
have to take place don't you agree
um
well if we're going to enact the bill as
amended the bill takes away the ability
of the officer to shoot a fleeing
suspect however the new hampshire
supreme court does allow us to
authorize a police officer
to shoot a felon if they are using a
deadly weapon and attempting to escape
or otherwise indicates that he is likely
to seriously endanger human life or
inflict serious bodily injury unless
apprehended without delay that's from
the statute so that part of the statute
would remain in place
um my thought is we're leaving that part
of the statute in place
um
here's kind of something we can do to
recognize that police officers if if
that happens if somebody's using a knife
for a weapon to to try to escape the
officer
that that officer needs to
[Music]
if they're there in uniform and it's
obvious that they're a police officer
i don't believe that they should
have to say
hey i'm a police officer before firing
when seconds count
um
you in in real self-defense cases uh
that go to court
you can have you're if you're lucky you
have five or ten different witnesses but
10 different witnesses can tell 15
different stories
and
it's very likely that a material witness
or material witnesses
are
going to relay what was said
inaccurately
has happened in my self-defense case
like i say
10 different witnesses with 15 different
stories about what was said
and the words that are spoken at the
time
people don't remember those very well
when the fight or flight response
kicks in and the adrenaline is is up and
people are wondering if they're going to
and honestly an officer might might
forget to uh to say something
or you may have a different officer on
the scene say hey i'm a police officer
even though they're both wearing
uniforms
representative
thank you for taking my question and and
pardon me but i'm i'm trying to
understand uh
the full implications of what it is that
you're
uh that you're
that you're saying so
um
as i as i read
the bill and the proposed changes to the
rsa
um
the constitutional issue isn't jumping
out at me
um
and so um
what i'm trying to do is i'm sort of
trying to mentally link what i'm seeing
in the bill itself uh to the last five
minutes of testimony regarding
what uh
you know what the constitutional issue
so i guess
representative abrams ever said if you
could speak just precisely to that issue
what in the bill uh addresses the
constitutional issue that you've raised
that would be fantastic
um i'll give you the scenario that
tennessee versus garner
was there was a lockdown and a curfew in
memphis tennessee i believe it was 1973
and officer i believe his name was elton
hyman
was uh patrolling the streets and there
was a a felon a 15 year old felon who
was running away and he jumped a fence
and officer hyman
shot him with a hollow point bullet he
hit him in the back of the head and the
young man died at the hospital later
so
the u.s supreme court had to consider
whether or not states could authorize
police to shoot someone
just for running away
and and the u.s supreme court in the six
to three decisions that no you cannot
we as a state legislature cannot
authorize
uh the 25 states that did we cannot
authorize a police officer
just based on its badge to shoot a felon
as they're running away
um
and
again the police unions were given the
opportunity to bring in studies showing
that felons were very likely to commit
another crime later and they were not
follow-up
representative
okay
so as i as i look at the bill um what i
see striked out are sections that
pertain
to affecting an arrest um
what i'm what i'm not seeing are
pertinent sections that appear to be
crossed out that would address
some of the issues you're raising around
a fleeing person
um
and i understand i may not be seeing the
full picture
but i'm
i'm
i'm a little bit at a loss as to sort of
where this
where the argument is going um
for this so
the the bill does appear to remove
sections that talk about using deadly
force and the affecting of an arrest but
it appears to allow
pretty much
in in place you know all of the language
around um
uh around using deadly force when a
person is fleeing
so
um i i would ask you to sort of help me
understand directly what
in the bill is is accomplishing
what you're what what the case that you
um
so in line well i don't have the uh
written bill but it's uh
part two
uh part two b
two where it says
um current law says he had made
reasonable efforts to advise advise the
person that he is a law enforcement
officer attempting to in effect an
arrest in his reasonable grounds to
believe that person is aware of these
facts
um
taking out
or i should use the the higher level
part b
or part two b
to affect an arrest
or prevent the escape from custody of a
person
whom he reasonably believes so we're
those are the two
options parts uh one and two
uh b1 and b2
um
b2 where he's allowed to use deadly
force just because the person is running
away
the courts have said that we can't
authorize that power
if the felon is using a weapon if
they're attacking someone if they take a
hostage if they steal a car
um
if they're driving away recklessly or
any number of circumstances
um
anything where they might in what's left
in the
statute under this bill is likely to
seriously endanger human life friends or
inflict serious bodily injury unless
apprehended without delay the officer
would still be allowed to use
deadly force under those circumstances
but not
just to arrest someone who is just
running away
so in the garner case where the officer
shot the 15 year old
um
the facts in the case and the
conclusions made at the the trial court
level were that
it was not established in any way shape
or form that the 15 year old was
otherwise endangering anyone else simply
running away trying to escape arrest
so that was the very narrow issue looked
at under tennessee versus garden and
like i say by a six to three decision
they decided that we're not allowed to
authorize deadly force
just
to enforce
our laws just to stop someone from
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative davidson for taking my
question
um has there been any recent history in
new hampshire
with
attempted arrests that have
turned into situations that this bill
um
that's a good question um i don't know
of any off the top of my head i know of
uh a few cases from from quite a few
years back but i don't know of anything
reason
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
um
my question is
similar to what
representative muse was asking
and
i i guess my question to you would be
you talked about a court case you said
the court case said that our law was
unconstitutional
and you keep mentioning running away you
can't do it running away
do you have a court case or did that
court case say it was unconstitutional
for an officer to use force when
affecting an arrest because that's the
only thing i'm seeing removed from this
bill
yes that's the narrow scope of tennessee
versus garner
uh tennessee versus garner 1985.
um i emailed you
the relevant uh
text from that case
uh last night at 509 pm it might be in
your it should be in your email inbox my
email sometimes go into people's uh
spam folder or book folder
you know one of those subfolders um but
uh
the text of that case tennessee versus
garner
um has not been overturned so that that
case is still the law of the land
um and this wording that we're trying to
delete
was kind of singled out by the court as
something that states are not allowed to
do
representative question
thank you
um
and thank you for pointing me back to
that email i'll go and find it and um
so
my question is do you just do you
recollect at all whether those exact
words that you're removing from this
document
were mentioned in that court review if
the new hampshire statute was mentioned
um and then the the
when you find the email has the the
exact quote see if i
still have it
um
which says the tennessee statute is
unconstitutional insofar as it
authorizes the use of deadly force
against such fleeing suspects um if you
do want to read the whole case it's a
few pages long but it does
uh
state
that a state is allowed to authorize
deadly force if the felon is creating
some type of imminent danger around them
at the time
but not for simply running away so if
they have a weapon in their hand
or they're trying to steal a car commit
you know we can allow police we can
authorize police officers to
shoot a suspect if they're doing
something else that endangers the public
um trying to set fire to something or
shooting back or
throwing a weapon or object but not
if i may ask a question um
they can take my question
so tennessee versus garner
known as what we you know often refers
to the fleet and felon doctrine where my
understanding the fact that the
victim was simply just fleeing and was
shot in the back
uh
you didn't say that if if
it would require something additional to
justify the use of deadly force when
affecting the rest
i understand this as
written
is using a deadly weapon and attempting
to escape
so
i
distinguish i'm just asking the
agreement you just i distinguished new
hampshire's law to require that
additional
deadly weapon to be involved in the
escape which is not what what the
circumstances were in tennessee versus
guard i'm not sure if you agree with
that
uh my reading of the statute is
um
that the
it it's an it's an
or situation
um
as i've read it 625
627 section 5. uh if you think i'm wrong
uh it is your decision i'm not on your
committee but
um
it currently says that they're simply
running away
my reading of the bill is it says if the
person is simply
running away from the person that the
officer has the right
to
let me ask
can you point to the line of power where
it says that
yep that's part two
thank you take my question
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman uh that's in i
believe max's representative abramson is
referring to rsa 627
2 a and b and those two are connected
thank you
well i'm saying that uh 627 section 5
part 2b
parts one and two if you if you read
them
um as one kind of it is kind of a long
run-on sentence
it does appear to authorize
the officer
um
to shoot a fleeing felon and
it was uh
it was cited as
a statute that uh
that had that problem
if you if you have the rsa books out
you can look at when the laws were
actually amended
there was an amendment made in 1981
another one in 1981
uh and another in
uh 2020 so last session
um
but i don't believe that
i think that that was a chokehold
position uh provision but i i don't
think that uh there was nothing made
between tennessee versus garner and
today
so
thank you see seeing no further hands
raised
good morning
yeah thank you all thank you all for the
recognition i am a um
board member my name's christine list
i'm a board member for the new hampshire
association of the criminal defense
lawyers i'm here in that capacity today
i've been a criminal defense attorney in
the state for about 13 years 10 of that
with the public defender's office before
moving into the private practice
i would like to speak on this bill
because overall it sets out the
framework for when new hampshire
thinks it's okay thinks it's permissible
and justified for a police officer
to kill a citizen of the state
that's what we're talking about and i do
think what we need to focus on is this
the bill as a as it's proposed hb66
eliminates the ability to kill someone
solely to effectuate the arrest it
leaves in place all the other
protections that officers have with
regard to um
interactions with
during an arrest particularly look
section one of 627.5 they're still
permitted to use other ports um when
we're talking about
lethal force deadly force i was thrilled
to hear this introduced as a pro law
enforcement bill because i agree that it
is
we put our officers in very difficult
situations we train them very well
i'm speaking with officers around the
state in the last few years as the
reforms have been discussed many of them
are in support of reforms um and
de-escalation and further trainings in
that they want to be able to reserve
legal lethal force when it's absolutely
necessary let's admit that it is never
necessary in order to solely effectuate
an arrest
um
when we talk about
the
process where
the bill as it stands the law as it
stands now
a law allows an officer
to kill a citizen who if the arrest had
gone forward and if the arrest was
successful they'd been brought before a
judge a judge then makes a determination
about whether or not that person is
dangerous and can stay in the community
facing charges the law as it's written
the category of crimes for which an
officer would be justified in killing
during an arrest
most covers most of our assault statute
and it is often that people charged with
those crimes appear in front of a judge
and are released on their own personal
recognition
this law as it's written allows an
officer to take that snapshot
and
look solely at am i arresting a person
and is it necessary for me to kill this
person in order to arrest them without
any other analysis
of whether they pose a future risk
whether they pose a current risk because
if they do that other parts of the
statute kick in and authorize the
officer to take the actions they believe
are necessary there are other safeguards
in place what this amendment i
believe is intended to do is eliminate
the ability to have a very tunnel vision
analysis of am i arresting
do i think it's apparently necessary and
apparently actually appears in the
statute apparently necessary to
effectuate this arrest
that we as a society should not condone
lethal force in that situation
i would like to speak just to the
question that was raised about um the
elimination of rsa
627-58 i believe that when
read in connection with the elimination
of to effectuate arrest that is crossed
out
um eight would really no
um purpose
if the
to effectuate arrest is crossed out it
essentially takes out all of the
references to when it is reasonable
and again
really opens it up to the officer making
a current analysis of the situation a
current analysis of the risk posed by
that person
rather than being able to as been
mentioned and as we've seen around the
nation and the last um
increasingly in the last few years
people being shot in the back as they're
fleeing when someone's trying to
effectuate an arrest i
don't discount that there are difficult
analysis to be made um i believe it was
raised you know when someone takes a
taser is that
are we permitted to use lethal force um
there's no go not going to be a bright
line rule that covers every situation
that my clients and officers find
themselves in on a on a potentially
daily basis but when we're talking about
a blanket permission to use lethal force
solely for an arrest it values the
arrest over the human life and submit
that that is not a place that new
hampshire wants to be and not how we
treat our citizens or our officer
and so for that reason
see no questions
thank you for your testimony
oh representative o'hare
you have a question
actually just for the for the chair um i
just want to join present now
see no further questions the witnesses
excused
calling uh
joe hannan
testify and please state
say your name or where you're from
whether you're testifying in support or
an opposition of
hp 66
hi my name is joe hannon i'm the vice
president for gun owners of new
hampshire and i'm testifying in support
of hb 66
i pretty much agree with most of
everything that's been said especially
counselor list and the other
representatives who testified um i think
that
the the section 8 that has been
discussed um
deadly force shall be deemed
deadly force shall be deemed reasonably
necessary in this section to prevent
whenever the arresting officer
reasonably believes the arrest is lawful
and there is apparently no other
possible means of affecting the arrest i
think that goes beyond just uh being in
line with removing that is better is
more than just being in line with
removing affecting arrest in the other
sections i think section 8 is is very
broad and can give an officer the
ability to
to use deadly force when they just can't
make the arrests in some way are they
the only officer on scene without backup
or they they feel like they're
overpowered and they can't affect the
arrest without having to use deadly
force it's a very broad uh section of
the law and i think that also needs to
be removed if you look back at section
four it talks about uh under the in the
same section
uh 27.5 section roman numeral four
it talks about uh
a private person acting on their own is
justified in using non-deadly force upon
another went into the extent that he
reasonably believes it is necessary to
affect or prevent the escape from
custody of such other whom he reason
believes to have committed a felony and
who in fact has committed the felony but
he is justified in using deadly force
for such purposes only when he reason
believes it's necessary to defend
himself or third person for what he
reason believes to be the imminent use
of deadly force so basically a private
person can only use deadly force
in the same situation a law enforcement
officer can if he has to protect his own
life or someone else's whereas a police
officer does not have that distinction
they have a special extra ability we've
given them under new hampshire law that
they don't need to be in danger or
someone else in danger to affect an
arrest whereas a private citizen does
and also in a self-defense situation if
someone tries to break into my house and
they have a gun
i'd be justified in shooting them in my
home and if they're fleeing my house and
running away
does that same can i still use deadly
force to affect an arrest of citizens
arrest in that example no i'd probably
go to jail if i'm shooting someone who's
fleeing the scene and running down my
street there was actually a retired law
enforcement officer in portsmouth who
faced charges for something very similar
even a law enforcement officer off duty
or retired does not have special
privileges to shoot someone fleeing that
they're trying to catch
and i don't think we should leave that
in the law i think this is something
that will benefit police officers and
law enforcement in general and the
public as a whole
and i think we need to be very specific
as to
um you know what is a la who's allowed
to kill somebody uh we've already
removed the death penalty in new
hampshire and i don't think we should
leave the death penalty intact for
officers who think someone deserves it
for not being arrested
seeing no no hands raised i want to
thank the witness for the testimony
i see no other hands
goldstein home
yes
his name's
yup can you hear me
sir
hello yes uh chief posey please please
state your name for the right
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
david goldstein i'm the chief of police
for the city of franklin and i represent
the new hampshire association of chiefs
of police
and i'll be very brief in my comments
because i think a lot of questions that
have been asked might more easily be
answered uh
with my uh presentation
uh i've been a police officer for 41
years
and i have affected i don't know how
many arrests i've affected in that time
period
i will tell the committee i will share
with the committee that i've arrested
people from
anything from a very simple
violations up to an and the necessity of
using um lethal force in in conducting
an arrest
so
i can go on from there
we oppose hb66 in part specifically the
part that removes
affect an arrest or
and the reason for that is quite simply
this is just one of the tools in our
toolbox in order to be able to do our
we are under great deal of scrutiny
today we always have been
new hampshire did adopt the tennessee v
garner standard back in the 80s prior to
that like most states in the country we
did not have it and we were able to
shoot fleeing felons just because they
were fleeing felons whether they were
armed or not and i would refer you to a
dover case that occurred just before the
tennessee v gardner uh decision
the use of lethal force and affecting
any arrest for us
is and always has been an option of last
resort
we don't look forward and i got the
impression from one of the uh presenters
we do not look forward to every day to
going out and shooting somebody just
because they don't submit to an arrest
when we tell them that that that in fact
is the case
um
this uh removal or keeping this in uh
rsa 627.5
is can does not give us carte blanche to
use any level of force that we're
talking about here
and quite frankly i think we're getting
lost in a little bit of the semantic
issue here everybody's talking about
shooting
the statute
addresses lethal force
there are other forms of lethal force
and i think we should acknowledge that
as well
all too often by the way we find
ourselves that being law enforcement
officers in rapidly developing
situations and again another presenter
seemed to think that that was not a
viable consideration well quite frankly
i would invite any member of the public
or any member of the committee to come
and train with us on how quickly we have
to make decisions at times that do in
fact result in the use of lethal force
and to my knowledge in my 41 year career
i am not aware of any police officer
that the attorney general has said was
engaged in a
in an actionable use of deadly force
therefore i would ask the committee and
we would ask the committee to find h.b
in expedient to legislate
and i would also again remind the
committee that we are accountable
whenever we do use deadly force we're
accountable to our departments we are
accountable to the attorney general who
investigates this and in my career as a
state trooper and as a member of the
major crime unit i investigated a large
number of officer-involved shootings and
to date have not seen one that wasn't
valid i'm more than happy to answer
thank you for your testimony
representative newman
yes uh thank you mr chairman and thank
do you believe that
well the sponsor stated that the nash
the new hampshire law was
unconstitutional
and you just stated that there were
intervening cases that happen between
that case and now
do you believe that the result of those
intervening cases
removed the unconstitutional aspect of
the previous law
yes
if that answers your question
representative
thank you for your testimony
chief goldstein i do have one question
do you recall
roughly in the last let's say two years
how often
was deadly force used when affecting
interest in the state of new hampshire
i don't have that exact number mr
chairman or representative but um
certainly we can find that out that's
all public information but i i think i
could once again underscore uh my belief
in my uh
that um none of those have resulted in
anything actionable by the attorney
general in other words that every time
that occurred the officer was vindicated
representative rory thank you uh thank
you chief for taking my question
while the statute as written is perhaps
unconstitutional
would you agree though that police since
the tennessee case have been trained to
the standard set by the tennessee case
and that there are other statutes on the
books that are also unconstitutional
that we no longer enforce
absolutely 110
i would agree with that uh we we adopted
it in new hampshire
and we've lived by it and i also train
um
at the i train recruits at the academy
as well as in service uh as a member of
the new hampshire state police swat unit
for over a dozen years
this was something we talked about on on
many occasions and quite frankly uh it's
thinking roy thank you a quick follow-up
so
uh what's concerning me a little bit
about the way this is written is that
the words effectuate and arrest
um
that's a in my understanding much more
complex situation than those words was
revealed so if the statute said you
cannot shoot a fleeing felon
simply because you have a warrant that
makes him a felon it would be much
clearer than saying you cannot
shoot someone while effectuating your
arrest because on the use of forced
continuum it can start at verbal and go
all the way to leave the force in
seconds
and in during that you would be trying
to effectuate an arrest so would that
knock with the officer in a horrible
position trying to decide what you know
which way that was going
well first and foremost uh it's not a
continuum anymore
it's more of a cyclical uh type of um
activity
we don't go from one end of a continuum
where there's perhaps nothing more than
verbal commands all the way and then
follow that continuum of that line to
the use of deadly force uh in my
situation for example
um i was trying very simply to affect an
arrest in a domestic and the next thing
i know is uh i had to use lethal force
in order to save my own life
uh that happened with literally within
seconds
um so
i would disagree with that
characterization however if i understand
what you're asking correctly yeah it's a
very difficult decision making process
it's a very complex process and as i
alluded to earlier it happens very very
rapidly in all too many situations so um
if you wish to try to regulate a police
officer's behavior by taking out that
phrase which helps us
um by taking out that phrase it actually
may have just the opposite effect of
putting people in an even more dire
situation
seeing no further questions i want to
thank thank you chief for your testimony
the next witness is joseph ever
you please just like identify yourself
the record state where you were where
you are from and please state whether
you are in support or opposition of h.p
good afternoon everyone
thank you for the opportunity to talk to
you this morning or this afternoon's
case may be my name is joe ebert it's
e-b-e-r-t
i'm a captain with the new hampshire
state police
uh and i'm representing the state police
today uh we are not taking an official
stance on this bill however
um and i'll do my best not to uh rehash
things that have uh already been brought
up but i
i did want to uh at least address that
uh the tennessee verse gardner
decision he
talked about a non-dangerous non-armed
individual and i don't think that that's
what our uh the seizure of that
what our statute uh refers to our
statute uh is talking very very
specifically
to
uh
a very narrow time when you could use
deadly force
to prevent the escape from custody of a
person
so in that tennessee v gardner the
decision specifically talks about uh
this the seizure of this individual and
i think that's that's key for me this
may be a semantics thing
uh but
if you're able to prevent the escape
from custody of an uh
of an individual for specific reasons
within our statute
uh and you're able to do that by using
deadly force
my training has always been that that
then you're affecting an arrest you're
affecting a seizure of that individual
so it it's hard for me to uh reconcile
that
i think that by taking out uh effect and
arrest you're causing um
uh you know disagreement within the the
statute itself uh because by the very
nature of preventing the escape leaving
that portion in by the use of deadly
force you're in effect you're affecting
an arrest so i i hope that
comes across as simple as i
had intended it to be but i am
absolutely willing to take any questions
seeing no hands raised i wanna
thank you for your testimony
i do see the hands raised in the
members of republican representative
abramson we uh
we're not going to allow members of the
public or representatives
to testify more than once on during the
public hearing so we were going to
if there's anyone who hasn't testified
already wishes to testify they may step
forward
seeing no hands raised we will close the
future
a quick reminder we do have people who
signed in uh in support in opposition to
this bill and i will
uh read those totals if you would like
thank you representatives no
representatives for the remainder of the
day i'm going to
delegate that that
assignment to you if you don't mind you
for that oversight again thank you thank
you representatives
uh you're welcome uh so for
for uh for bill hb 66 we had uh 14
individuals who signed in in support
we are now going to open the public
hearing
for
hb 564 which is prohibiting the use of
rubber bullets and tear gas by law
enforcement
it's like we're opening up a public
hearing
at 11 35
am
so
uh
for the purposes of this public hearing
due to time constraints we are going to
limit testimony to two minutes per
witness uh i will sit for the sponsor
sponsor introducing the bill we will
allow a performance
all right no worries i'll be but i
appreciate that mr chair um
colleagues hi my name is representative
manuel specia and i'm here
before you discuss the hp 564. um and
before i have an amendment two mile that
should have been shared with everyone in
this amendment will narrow the scope of
bill to restrict the use of republican
tear gas
rather than prohibiting their use entire
the proposed amendment would prohibit
the use of these weapons in situations
where there is
not an imminent risk of bodily harm to
the officer
the goal is to balance the power and
responsibility of law enforcement
to protest
public safety with you know
to protect sorry public safety with the
threat of these weapons to the physical
well-being of individuals particularly
unarmed individuals
and you know this bill is in response to
the number of injuries and trauma that
have been caused over the last few years
during peaceful demonstrations you know
injuries such as broken bones skin burns
and then
internal injuries have see have been
seen due to tear gas and herbal bullets
we have seen how tear gas has caused
people to be suffocated and tear gas is
intended to be deployed at a distance
and when canisters are launched directly
at crowds they're prone to causing
serious eye head brain or chest injuries
from the force of impact as well as
chemical burns
and i understand that the work that our
law enforcements must do i you know it's
it's it's hard work but we must find
alternatives to chemical irritants and
rubber bullets police know how to
control uh safely control crowds without
resorting to these dangerous and
potentially lethal weapons and while we
have not seen these weapons abused in
new hampshire my constituents have seen
a number of videos in recent years of
unarmed protesters being targeted and
seriously injured by rubber bullets in
tear gas in other states and these
videos are traumatizing and have led to
concerns about the use of these weapons
in new hampshire and you know this is
legislation that is meant uh to ensure
that police violence seen elsewhere
doesn't happen here
um so with that um like i said there is
an amendment um so i hope you all would
take a look at that um and i will open
representative
thank you for allowing me a question uh
so
you want i'm trying to understand this
you're
you're asking them not to use
rubber bullets or any other non-lethal
kind of
it was of a
projectile
so they would be okay to use
real projectiles for a gun i mean is
that what
i guess
you're prohibiting a non-lethal and only
so no um
i'd like to answer um no i think
um i would obviously would not want to
see lethal weapons to be used in an
opposition and like you know as opposed
to rubber bullets or tear gas i think
um you know i have a lot of faith in our
law enforcement to be able to do the
right thing and you know be able to
control crowds without the use of tear
gas but
thank you
thank you for taking my question i'm
just curious uh here in new hampshire
at uh at protests or gatherings uh that
you've either been involved with
directly or that you've heard about
have you actually seen officers uh
equipped with uh with these weapons
thanks for the question um i
i mean i've seen and here's the thing
like i've seen heavy mobilization of
um of law enforcement and i think you
know that in and of itself is a
deterrent um i mean you know i haven't
seen the folks with tear gas or rubber
bullets like in place but
i think you know just because it does
like you know the saying just because it
doesn't happen here doesn't mean we
shouldn't worry about it um i think you
know this is just um i feel like we can
trust our police officers to comply with
with a bill like this so
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative take my question
um
there i think you mentioned the proposed
amendment which i'm not sure we have
access to
and i believe it was to limit it
somewhat by saying if they felt they
were in danger
and physical danger i i guess it would
be
um in in a case like that um would you
consider
like i've seen in some protests people
throwing frozen water bottles that
police would that be
covered by
the that's a good question um
i mean if i would be up to the
discretion of the law enforcement i
would
i mean i i when i talk about this i i
mean like real like you know if people
showed up with with with rifles or or
actual like you know with with pistols
and things like that i think then would
be a different story
um with armed protests um
but when it comes to water bottles i
don't think that's um i think that's
different
representative conley
thank you mr jeremy just a comment uh if
i may
the amendment has been referenced i have
stopped this amendment
and i intended to have it sent to the
committee
several hours ago and
that does not happen likely it's
something that i did not do but i have
sent it to everyone on this committee so
that they can take a look at it in case
the amendment is discussed further
that's not right for the delay and
thank you europe for some calling for
bringing that to my attention just in
case anyone didn't hear
the
there was an amendment that was
referenced in the testimony uh
representative colonies now forwarded
that
amendment to the rest of the committee
i'm sorry i think i took my hand down
thank you though i had to leave the room
seeing no no additional hands raised i
want to thank the representative for his
testimony
edwards
representative edwards the floor is
yours
i'll remind i'll remind the members of
the public wishing to testify that their
testimony
or having difficulty on his side we'll
move on to the next witness i don't i
thank you mr chairman the next in order
would be uh chief david goldstein
i think we made it we did pretty good
maybe this far without technical
difficulties yeah still going better
all right let me meet him again um tim
representative edwards i believe has
solved this technical difficulties with
the strike
good morning uh my name is tim
o'donoghue i think there was a glitch i
was actually in the queue for hb 66
i don't want to speak out of turn but i
was
i've been waiting to speak on hb66
did we already do that
you did sir i had signed up on the thing
and i had registered and i was like i
said i was standing by in the queue when
you guys said ask for any more hands we
we clicked here and i think we might
have missed it
so
to the extent that that was the
oversight of the chair of this committee
it's unfortunately not as simple as uh
just simply opening
reopening a public hearing that has been
closed no i understand that yes sir
i may be somewhat limited on my ability
to do that
so i sincerely apologize for that sounds
like that was hard but i would recommend
if you'd like to email
your written testimony
it's something that it could be
the committee will have it and will make
sure that it's the
it's at least
referenced you know during the executive
session
yes sir uh
yeah i can look into that so would you
would you like to direct that email to
yes sir
uh also with me is lieutenant mark
morrison he's the president of the uh
new hampshire police association
it's sir i was uh also in the queue uh
waiting
for hb66
and i was on the line with the
technical uh help as as that hearing
started to close trying to
bring attention to the fact that we were
not able to be recognized
so i don't know if there are more than
just um the two separate
entries that had registered this morning
but
um
you know so i guess i would ask you know
if we could
offer that testimony on hb66
or reopen the hearing to allow for that
due to the technical uh
you know issues
and sort of just the general situation
where we are forced into the zoom
um
in the unfortunate circumstance we're
not able to be together in person
the best i can
say to to both individuals what i can do
is
i would have to consult with the clerk i
want the process of doing i i simply
just can't reopen the hearing at you
know as my own discretion uh his notice
requirements that i would have to follow
so i i wish it was that easy because
it's we're all talking right now it
sounds like a simple fix but we're we
already opened the public hearing on hb
564. so i
i can't
um
i can't bounce around from each one
unfortunately so
what i'll do is we're not gonna i will
tell you i can say that we're not gonna
have an executive session on hb66 and if
we do end up doing today it won't be the
afternoon i can
recess
for lunch
what i'll do is i'll
ask the clerk the process of
whether it's even impossible for us to
do
today
very good sir well i appreciate your
your time and i apologize for delaying
this hearing um
as it just sort of carried over into the
next hearing we were still logged in
from 66 so
we will
try to look to submit some written
testimony in our opposition to that bill
and uh
i apologize to both members of the
public
yeah
thank you mr chairman the next uh person
to speak is jeannie uh
let me um
before before their witness takes the
testifies
okay
then it would be michael lang
yeah but there is a person well they're
from a group too
um
well there's a couple represent there's
one representative and then jordan
thomas there myself
we just keep this moving if
representative if sergeant mike michael
lang is not testifying on behalf of if
he's specified
okay guys
yeah you want me to click on my
witches
okay i'm here
uh good afternoon representative abbas
and members of the committee my name is
michael lang
and i am a sergeant with the national
police department i'm a lifelong
resident of the state of new hampshire
and i've been a police officer here for
12 years i currently serve as a
first-line supervisor in our
professional standards bureau where we
deal with matters such as recruiting and
hiring training and maintaining
compliance with accreditation standards
i just learned the amendment so my
testimony may not directly address the
amendment as opposed to the original
bill but it may provide some context i'm
here to testify in opposition to hb 564
on behalf of my department and also the
new hampshire association of shrieks of
police
and i'm going to assume that by rubber
bullets and tear gas the bill is
referring to all less lethal impact
munitions and chemical munitions such as
cs gas
rubber bullets as specified are only one
type of munition that fall into the
category of what we call less lethal
impact munitions and by definition these
are rubber foam or similar projectiles
used to temporarily incapacitate or
subdue an armed or otherwise dangerous
person
the devices are called less lethal
because they are designed to create a
temporary pain stimulus
to bring about a change in behavior
tear gas as specified by the bill is a
generic term for
chemical irritant gases and seems to
have become slang for cs gas which is
the most commonly type of most commonly
used type of tear gas by the police and
this is an important distinction because
cs gas has been shown to be much safer
than the other types of quote-unquote
tear gas
cs gas causes a temporary irritation to
the eyes nose mouth throat and lungs and
skin it's used with the hope of creating
a strong desire to move out of the
contaminated area or make it difficult
to mount an offensive attack due to
watering of the eyes and difficulty
breathing
the effects of cs gas on an individual
immediately begin to dissipate once they
are removed from or they remove
themselves from the affected environment
as you heard with both of these tools i
use the word temporary and i want to
emphasize that
both of these tools when used in
accordance with policy and
manufacturer's guidelines create a
strong but temporary discomfort to the
person exposed
the irritation from cs gas begins around
20 to 60 seconds after exposure and the
effects to quote the cdc are short-lived
and commonly resolved 15 to 30 minutes
after the person has been removed from
the source
these are not weapons of war designed to
inflict pain and suffering on innocent
people they are the exact opposite in
that they are designed to provide the
police with an option to respond to
people intent on doing harm that is less
likely to cause death or serious bodily
injury than lethal force options they're
awesome
we do have to limit testimony to two
minutes so i would just ask uh if you
mind
coming to a conclusion
i'll wrap it up with an example uh the
capital rise as we all know that
occurred
and we're all aware of the unarmed
protester that was fatally shot by law
enforcement
i would argue that if that
law enforcement officer or officers at
that scene had
less lethal munitions or tear gas they
could have deployed those instead of
lethal force and we might not have a
fatality at the hands of law enforcement
in that scenario and the tools mentioned
in this bill as with all police use of
force options are critical to
maintaining safety in order and the
answer is not to ban them because this
would have a negative impact on suspect
and officer safety as well as quality of
life in the community especially in
times like these society is demanding
police use less force thank you sergeant
thank you for your testimony
representative harper
uh thank you mr chair thank you uh
for taking my question
um how often are rubber bullets or
tear gas used in new hampshire
i can't speak to how often they're used
in new hampshire
as far as quote unquote rubber bullets
nashua doesn't use rubber bullets but as
far as left less lethal munitions in
nashua it's very seldom
[Music]
in 2019 i'm referencing our
accreditation analysis from that year
uh less lethal impact munitions were
used six times by nashville in 2019.
it's very infrequent and we have never
used less lethal impact munitions in a
see no further questions i want to thank
the sergeant for his testimony
representative
is representative
schmidt
assuming the
representative can hear us we just want
to remind
everyone to limit the testimony to two
minutes once you reach two minutes i
will at least let you know the time has
come up
it's expired now while trying to
um
representative edwards is raising his
hand again
you want to bring edwards and i'll look
for smiths
if it doesn't work we're going to
conclude that the the chair will
conclude that the technical difficulties
disarm representative edwards is it all
right representative this is
representative edwards can you hear me
now
yes loud and clear
okay so i moved to a different computer
so i'm representative jess edwards
representing auburn chester and sandown
i'm opposed to h.b 564.
uh i'm old enough
to remember
um you know the riots of the 60s uh and
civil disturbance uh since then
and i think it's just a mistake with all
the effort that got put into creating
non-lethal force to give our law
enforcement
uh other options to deal with
um
mobs
that
it would be foolish and short-sighted i
think to remove it as an option in
statute
in practice they make make the law
enforcement may make other decisions
but i don't think this is an area we
want to tie their hands
we've seen
what mob behavior has done to destroy
cities like
portland
minneapolis
we've seen
congress people from the boston area
advocate for violence from boston to
portland
and it just is not a time to be tying
the hands of law enforcement so that
thank you
representative edwards for your
testimony
seeing no hands of representative
she is not on he's on the list but she
representative
do you know if representative schmidt is
uh
having technical difficulties or is
there
mr chair i'm happy to contact him and
the next on the list
mr chairman is the genie um persco
because there's no more
uh no there is one i apologize uh tom
uh is it jordan thompson or thompson
jordan
jordan thompson jordan thompson yeah let
me unmute him he's unmuted
hello can everyone hear me okay
yes
thank you my name is jordan thompson and
i'm a racial justice organizer at the
american civil liberties union of new
hampshire and an organizer at black
lives matter nashua
last spring and summer thousands of your
constituents mark marched peacefully for
equity in justice and solidarity with
the movement for black lives in new
hampshire the people demonstrations that
occurred both here at home and across
their branches i may ask you to ask the
way this is spent for a moment are you
testifying on behalf of yourself are you
testifying on behalf of an organization
because the list you have suggested
you're
testifying yeah
we do needed the record spiritually
stated
and also whether you support our host
thank you so i'm testifying on behalf of
black lives matter nashville
but in my personal capacity as an
organizer from that from that
organization
and i am testifying in support of hb
564.
so returning to my testimony the
peaceful demonstrations that occurred
both here at home and across the country
make up what has been called the largest
civil rights movement in modern american
history although these protests were
overwhelmingly peaceful many of them
were met with a highly militarized
police presence and cities like
washington new york and even boston
demonstrators who had committed no crime
and were only exercising their
constitutional rights were met with tear
gas and rubber bullets thousands of
people were injured as a direct result
they were maimed they were brutalized in
some cases they have lasting injuries
that include the loss of an eye leg or
other bodily feature
as the sergeant on here earlier
described rubber bullets are described
as non-lethal but that is not entirely
accurate they can cause extreme harm for
the rest of a person's life and in some
cases they can even cause death if you
oppose the action of firing live
ammunition into a crowd of peaceful
demonstrators because it is a massacre
why would you not hold rubber bullets to
the same standard the use of tear gas is
similarly destructive tear gas is a
chemical agent that can have that can
cause respiratory burns allergic
reactions and respiratory distress
people have died after being tear gassed
the 1925 geneva protocol bans the use of
tear gas and war so how can it be
considered suitable for use on civilians
thankfully our organizers at black lives
matter and new hampshire were not tear
gased or shot with rubber bullets this
summer but we could have been there was
increased police presence at almost all
of our events the national guard had
been calling for vigils in nashua and
manchester this could have been us and
it could have been your constituents
your job as a legislator is to prevent
this legislation is about prevention
it's about public safety it's about not
waiting for someone to lose an eye or
leg before we take action let us act now
before it is too late and let me be very
clear because this is referenced in the
amendment this relates to peaceful
demonstrators for someone to compare us
to the terrorists that marched on the
capitol and stormed that that building
is disgusting and frankly the casual
racism that has gone on in this hearing
is disgusting we are talking about
unarmed peaceful demonstrators that are
your constituents they marched for peace
equity and justice
right excuse me
the witness will suspend
the chair does not receive any testimony
today to be racist towards anybody and
i i don't i hope no one
and i'm from speaking on behalf of the
entire committee i feel that if anyone
said anything that was racist or
inappropriate that all 21 members of
this committee would stand at the same
time
anything of that nature i did not
perceive it and
i welcome anyone on this committee if
they perceived ending as as be racist
please speak up
your silencing of me in this moment is
racist
i i understand what you're saying
but
i'm just you're saying that other
witnesses were so
let me finish your testimony
[Music]
i have nothing further to say other than
the fact that whoever laughed this is
not a funny thing the act of shooting
someone with a rubber bullet or tear
gassing them to death is not funny and
thank you for your testimony
thank you uh
chair for recognizing me to ask a
question and thank you jordan for
your words today um
do you know of other events conducted by
other local groups in new hampshire
that had a similar protest or even they
they had weapons on them were met with
the same amount of police presence
i do not and i really appreciate you
bringing that up because we had armed
militias who were walking around our
state capitol with ak-47s and they
certainly were not met by the national
guard they weren't met with increased
presence by local and state law
enforcement but we teenagers unarmed
with water bottles as you described
earlier were met with that kind of
militarized police presence there's a
see no further
representative testament
thank you for allowing me the question
are you are you saying that
other people who protested in front of
the state capitol
did not have a presence of police
and so on
or just blm had a
i'm saying what i said so i'm a little
confused by your question can you maybe
you're not a customer would you like to
clarify your clarifier
you said
that
you were there or some of your people
were there
armed with nothing but
water bottles and there were a lot of
police
there were other people armed and
they didn't have any police
it that just it funnels me
because
you know i've been there when there are
police and certainly there aren't people
so i just want to make it very clear and
i hope that we're being we're
approaching this conversation in good
faith and being intellectually honest
here because there's a clear difference
between a state police captain showing
up to meet a group of armed protesters
and the national guard being called out
on 22 year olds who are holding a
peaceful vigil i hope we can make that
online
but i hope so
thanks for uh thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
my question is have you found that there
are
a notable number of children or family
pets
that are brought to
these protests that you participate in
and um
[Music]
would you consider it appropriate for
children and families to speak tear gas
or hit with forever bullets if i just
remind the member
ask one it's easier for the witness to
answer the question ask one at a time i
will recognize you for a follow-up
question but it will overlap two
questions isn't necessary
i appreciate the question representative
and it's actually quite easy for me to
answer both i do believe that it is
wildly inappropriate for
when you are at an event what we call
our protest family events because we
have people uh that are
multi-generational multiracial from
every age group we have pets we have
small children that show up to hear us
speak so yes that is something that
occurs and it's very very inappropriate
it is disturbing that like i said these
folks that are coming to these protests
they are unarmed and they are peaceful
and they are met with such
seeing no further questions
mr chairman now the next speaker is
jamie hirschka did we can we find
representative schmidt
gina hersch goes on
good afternoon thank you mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
jeannie herreska i'm the political
director for the american civil
liberties union of new hampshire
and i appreciate the opportunity to
testify in support of hbe 564. i just
want to know to the top that we support
the amendment
that representative conley has proposed
we fully support
not making the bill so it's not so
prohibitive
our goal is to create some guard rails
around the use of these weapons
not necessarily to prohibit them
outright
and i just want to mention i want to go
back to what sergeant lang said because
he said a couple really important things
he said these are not weapons of war
and i'm not sure he knew just how apt
that was these weapons have actually
been banned uh during wartime by
international law the 1925 geneva
protocol prohibits tear gas and the
chemical weapons convention prohibit
tear gas in times of war and yet somehow
this weapon is still allowed to be used
on our neighborhoods and in our
communities and so again our goal is not
to prohibit them um
it's really to just make sure that
they're not being used indiscriminately
or inappropriately
um again sergeant lang mentioned using
these weapons against armed or dangerous
persons and i think that's the
distinction we're trying to make we're
trying to make sure that when these
weapons are used it's because there is
an imminent threat that they're not
being used for crowd control that rubber
bullets are not being indiscriminately
shot into a crowd um because that's when
they're really dangerous when they're in
indiscriminately and disproportionately
used um so i would really encourage the
committee to look at the amendment that
representative conley proposed um and
take this opportunity to create just
some common sense guard rails around the
use of these weapons um and with that
thank you very much for your testimony
representative comey
thank you mr chairman thank you for
are you aware of any cities or towns or
states that have
taken the step that is proposed in the
in the bill
or the amendment that the committee has
before
uh thank you representative for that
question and the answer is yes there
have been a number of towns and cities
particularly in the last year
that have banned or restricted the use
of tear gas and rubber bullets or of of
projectiles as
others have referenced
and colorado actually passed legislation
last year
to prohibit law enforcement from
shooting rubber bullets indiscriminately
into a crowd and targeting rubber
bullets at someone's head torso or back
and that same legislation colorado also
prohibited using tear gas or pepper
spray without first warning the crowd
and giving people time in a route to
disperse
and so i i flagged the colorado example
again as something that doesn't prohibit
these these weapons outright but really
creates some common sense guard rails
thank you mr chair for and thank you to
the witness for taking the question
cite any instances where
the use of tear gas
would be used for crowd control and i'm
thinking maybe of where somebody's
blocking a block or people have been
occupied a space for a month or more and
the only option as i see it from this
bill is that the police would have to
use
shields and batons
to move the people i'm just wondering if
yours your position is to support some
use of tear gas and i don't think the
i appreciate the question um i think the
example that's come up in the past year
is to use tear gas to enforce a curfew
um and given that tear gas
can actually be very very harmful and
i'll note that it's particularly harmful
for people with respiratory illnesses
including covid19
so tear gas is actually particularly
dangerous right now
when people's faces are covered and tear
gas can actually get caught between
their mask and their face and when
people may be suffering from respiratory
illness but again
it was referenced actually earlier i
think in the earlier hearing that law
enforcement have many tools in their
toolbox so i i don't believe that it's
you either you use rubber bullets or you
use lethal force i don't think those are
the two only two options in the toolbox
i think there are a lot of options in
the law enforcement toolbox and all
we're trying to do again is create some
common sense limitations on the use of
representative testerman
thank you thank you for taking my
question
you mentioned colorado uh
do you know what the laws are in
portland or seattle or minneapolis
uh
you know where there have been
large-scale riots for a long time you
know do they have a
prohibition of rubber bullets and gas
and so on i'm not sure i will say
minneapolis is undergoing a pretty
comprehensive review of its police
practices right now
so i would not be at all surprised if
the use of these weapons are part of
that very comprehensive review that
they're undertaking
representative boardney
[Music]
thank you for coming to testify and
taking my question i am trying to
reconcile a couple of statements you
made
first
legal in
war but i thought you
said that you allocated there were times
when tear gas could be used domestically
is that true
i think what we're trying to do is
strike a balance um i think our sense is
it's very difficult to pass a
prohibition outright i think you've
sensed that in this hearing and so again
we're trying to find a balance
um and and we think the amendment
strikes it um i i think there's a good
reason these weapons have been banned in
wartime and i do think that that's
telling it's indicative of how dangerous
these weapons can be
um which again to me underscores the
need for some real safety protocols
around how they're used
and that when they are used that the
leaf the dangerousness of the weapon is
warranted because of the threat being
faced that they're not being used simply
because somebody's violating a curfew
that it's being used because there is
somebody who's armed dangerous and
trying to attack i i really want to make
sure that there's a proportionality to
could there be circumstances where
rubber bullets were used
despite it being a
form of non-lethal force it could still
be considered
excessive force if it was used would you
agree with that statement
i think so yes again it's situation
specific certainly for instance in like
short distance to shoot somebody point
blank with a rubber bullet um or
shooting them in the face for instance
like rubber bullets are highly highly
see no hands hand raise i want to thank
you again for your testimony
representative
all right
good afternoon uh mr chairman uh
representative al baldusow rockingham
county district five while i was sitting
here waiting for the next build to
introduce i listened and listened and i
said my god i can't believe the
testimony that's coming out
to people that are supporting this bill
uh first of all as a retired marine and
somebody just
went to war
uh
tear gas
what does not work against real bullets
when they're shooting at you okay uh we
believe in the one shot one kill
mentality as a marine
okay so naturally we're not going to use
tear gas our job is to protect the
police along with the people that are
out there on these peaceful
demonstrators that kill cops that burn
down buildings that tear up um other
people's property that spray paint all
over those are peaceful demonstrators
okay but most of the media the liberal
media does not show that stuff
um i understand these rubber bullets
they have um they don't want this stuff
but the police have the right to protect
themselves when they're being attacked
uh we do riot control in the military to
back up police that's why you see
national guard there in washington okay
it is our job
otherwise we did do they prefer a
beating with a uh baton if they're gonna
you know keep coming forward
if you look what's been going on around
the company you know uh on the let's
let's use the weapons i'm gonna touch on
that real quick
these weapons that they're talking about
are law-abiding citizens that are there
protecting property okay whether it be
in salem other parts of the state that
is not against the law
it's our duty we have the right per the
constitution article 2a to protect
property others and ourselves
closing
okay um
the criminal threat here
is to protect the police when they're
doing these peaceful rallies which is a
bunch of bs and i'll leave it at that i
was going to be silent mr chairman but
the testimony really got me going just
listen to the false testimony thank you
representative i want to thank your
testimony
even though you did not say anything
that was
you know
the future no abbreviation
mr chairman it's hard to hear you with
that mask
through the computer
you're the only one
everyone else is going to hear me just
fine
no
representative marston
hi chair thank you for
recognizing me for the question uh thank
you representative baldassaro for taking
my question
are you saying because tear gas is too
safe for war that's the reason it was
banned
no uh what i'm saying is uh when people
are shooting at you don't use tear gas
tear gas that they use in the the police
is not like what we use in the military
the tear gas they use is identified for
water eyes uh nose uh to blind people uh
you know temporarily uh with watering
eyes it is not a lethal weapon as you're
saying
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the representative for his testimony
representative abbott
you know everson
is
you want me to recognize him or a member
grace lonnie let me get down on you
representative baldsar well i know you
your intention was to introduce uh hb
81 at 12 15 as you can see we're running
behind schedule
if you are unable to introduce the bill
i sure i assure you that a member of the
committee will introduce and introduce
the bill to make sure that it's heard
today
uh am i can you hear me
am i unmuted
you know i'm just letting you know that
if for some reason your schedule
conflicts with the fact that we're
behind schedule that a member of this
committee one of the 21 of us someone
will introduce hp
81 to make sure the public hearing if
you're unable
how long
mr chairman how long do you think it's
going to be before because what i have
to do and introduce the bill is a quick
three-minute spill since i did
co-sponsored stand your ground in new
hampshire
and uh this is a very simple
housekeeping bill
i'm going to keep i'm going to keep
going forward with the public hearing is
open right now i just if for some reason
your schedule conflicts it will get
introduced
we assure you
if for some reason mr chairman i get
knocked off
then uh please do so have uh mr
representative john burke
introduce the bill if possible
well you would have
uh grace lunny
can everyone hear me
yes grace
hi thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity
um i'm
here to testify my name is grace honey
and i'm a student at newmarket junior
senior high school i'm here testifying
today on behalf of the new hampshire
high school democrats and i'm testifying
in support of house bill
564. as this bill is a necessary step in
ending racial injustice in the police
system as well as preventing the
unnecessary injury of peaceful
protesters
so for many years weapons such as rubber
bullets and tear gas have been deemed
non-lethal despite studies increasingly
showing otherwise a study done by the
british medical journal showed that
people who were injured by a rubber
bullet 3 percent die from their injuries
and 15 suffer a permanent disability as
a result and despite being considered
non-lethal by law enforcement across the
country these weapons are not harmless
by any means injuries from rubber
bullets can range from bruising to bone
fractures
nerve damage and even damage to vital
organs depending on the location of the
body in which the victim is hit
and though tear gas has been most
commonly known to cause watering of the
eyes and irritate the nose and mouth
when deployed in enclosed spaces this
can actually result in chemical burns
and vision loss so along with the issues
that i've previously stated the
difference in police response that has
been observed in the january 6 capital
riot versus 2020 racial justice protest
is brazenly clear and quite
quite frankly hypocritical
as black lives matter protesters
peacefully took to the streets across
america they were met with violent shows
of force by police who used rubber
bullets and tear gas
for instance seacoast black lives matter
organizer julian julian maduro told npr
that she saw violent shows of force
against racial justice advocates at a
protest she attended in late may of 2020
in portland maine however an opposite
reaction by law enforcement can be seen
during the capital riot that took place
earlier this year instead some police
officers were filmed taking selfies with
rioters and even removing barriers
allowing rioters easier access to the
capitol building
in response to these events president
joseph biden tweeted no one can tell me
that if this had been a group of black
lives matter protesters yesterday that
they would have been treated differently
than the mob that stormed the capital we
all know that's true and it's
unacceptable
racial bias has been in our policing
system for centuries and it's long time
past time that action be taken
hb 564 and other legislation like it are
important steps to take thank you so
much for your time i appreciate the time
that you have taken to hear my testimony
and would like to please request that no
we thank you for your testimony we will
respect the request of the witness
testifying
tony narrow yes good afternoon can
everyone hear me
yes we can
thank you
um
my name is anthony nero i'm
an attorney at bernazani law in nashua
i'm speaking in favor of the bill on
behalf of the new hampshire association
of criminal defense lawyers
i would like to say that i
agree with
the testimony of the representative from
black lives matter nashua and the aclu
and
they covered a lot of the points i was
going to make so i will try not to be
repetitive i've submitted written
testimony and i trust the committee will
review that as well
as lawmakers you know quite well that
words matter
and as this bill is discussed i
encourage the body to continue to think
about the words we are all using here um
tear gas and rubber bullets are not less
lethal weapons they are by definition if
we look to rsa 6 25 11 roman numeral 5
tear gas is a chemical weapon that is
banned in the use of war rubber bullets
are not rubber they have some rubber in
them they also have hard plastics and
metals
and they are bullets however they're
fired at high velocities and civilians
they cause death they maim people they
are imprecise weapons and as a result
innocent people suffer great injuries
when they are used um i understand there
were some questions about have we seen
instances or how many uses of these
weapons have we seen in law enforcement
i think this body should think about are
we going to be a reactive or proactive
law making body and i think we should be
proactive
there are other approaches to crowd
control we haven't really gotten into
them today but officers can be trained
to negotiate with protesters explain
police actions third party negotiators
can also be employed to mediate
information exchange between the police
and the public and these community
policing practices which seek to
facilitate peaceful political expression
rather than repress it can avoid the
escalation that often ends in the police
use of tear gas or rubber bullets
this bill does not take away
batons taser hand handheld aerosol
pepper sprays i've noted in my comments
that
i think the language needs to be
tightened up however
because
there really isn't a definition tear gas
is a is a broad term and i do think it
needs to be tightened up a bit to
effectuate the purpose of the statute
which i think is about crowd control and
not taking away um personal
weaponry from the officers when they're
but by removing chemical agents and
projectiles such as rubber bullets
from law enforcement's arsenal in this
state you will not just be protecting
lives but you will also be building
trust with the community
with respect to i just want to touch on
one point that sergeant lang
who i
know and i respect his work he mentioned
the cdc i would refer the committee to
my written testimony the cdc does not
say this is harmless
in fact the cdc
has pointed out that
tear gas has long-term effects not just
short-term and can actually
cause internal damage that will make
people
for the rest of their life susceptible
to
virus disease
such as influenza and coronavirus and
that's something we really need to be
mindful especially nowadays so if
there's any questions i'm happy to
entertain them and again i would refer
to my written testimony
see no hands raised i want to thank the
witness for the testimony
thank you
thank you mr chairman the next speaker
is going to be erica
hi um
thank you um
my name is erica perez i'm
on behalf of new hampshire youth
movement
and i'm in support of hb 564.
um i've heard a lot of talk about
nationally but i would love to talk
about blm locally because we have three
amazing chapters who give back to our
community
um
and regularly have events throughout the
state
um
they can't speak to how often tear gas
and rubber bullets are used because as
of yet me and my friends who organize
these events with new hampshire blm
chapters have had the biggest protest
new hampshire has ever seen and has
never given them the reason to and it's
because they're peaceful and family
friendly and
hundreds of people go
and they have never turned violent and
it's because they're meant to shed light
on situations that are horrible not
become horrible situations themselves
um many times i have marched as police
and civilians pointed guns at me
and i have remained calm how is it that
i and your constituents can handle this
threat without reacting but a march is
seen as a threat
and a peaceful one at that
i want to emphasize the lack of rubber
bullets and tear gas during the capital
rights because i think it's important
and polarizing as we've seen with the
blm marches and protests how is it that
there was no tear gas or rubber bullets
during an act of terrorism but there
were at vigils and peaceful marches i
don't want to destroy new hampshire i
want to be on a path for new hampshire
to be better starting with this bill and
i also just wanted to add because no one
else had mentioned it that rubber
bullets the ones that we've been seeing
use on the news are meant to be shot at
the ground and to hit someone after
they've been hit from the ground
they're not supposed to be directly shot
at people because that is as harmful
almost as harmful as just a regular
bullet
um i'm happy to take questions if you
seeing no hands raised
thank you mr chairman the next
speaker is going to be sergeant nutella
is it
dear representative abbas and members of
the committee my name is gregory
ditullio and i'm a sergeant with the
manchester police department i've been a
resident of the state of new hampshire
and a police officer for the last 15
years i currently serve as a first-line
supervisor for the special enforcement
division special investigations unit
where we deal with the detection of
organized criminal activity intelligence
gathering and narcotics enforcement i am
also a team leader on the department
swat team i'd like to thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today i
concur with sergeant lang's testimony
prior i am also here to testify in
opposition of house bill 564 on behalf
of my department and also the new
hampshire association of chiefs of
police
as i'm going to speak to you about less
lethal impact munition which you are
considering rubber bullets and chemical
munitions cs gas
over the century civilizations have
sought ways to protect society from
violence while minimizing injuries to
the public and its officials police
officers within the state of new
hampshire are required to attend
specialized training which certifies
them in the safe deployment of less
lethal impact munitions and chemical
munitions this training provides
officers with various ways to maintain
order while also earning the public's
trust chemical munitions are chemical
compounds that temporarily disorient and
discomfort individuals by causing
irritation to the eyes mouth throat
lungs and skin most common compound used
by the police in the state of new
hampshire
are cs and oc gas
chemical munitions are most commonly
used in the state of new hampshire to
dislodge
aerial denial of barricaded subjects
within a structure these munitions are
deployed after exhausting all attempts
in establishing communication to attain
a peaceful resolution
chemical munitions are a tool utilized
to de-escalate volatile situations by
safely removing an individual with
minimal injury damage to property and
risk to the public less lethal impact
munitions are rubber or foam projectiles
that are deployed in order to apprehend
dangerous individuals and decrease the
chance of injury or death to suspects
bystanders and officers they provide a
transfer of kinetic energy from the
device to the individual with the
desired effect being a temporary pain
stimulus that interrupts their thought
process in order to bring about a change
in behavior
manufacturers have tested these prod
these products endlessly to ensure that
they're only using enough kinetic energy
to simply gain compliance
is imperative to provide officers with
the viable methods of subdue
sergeant
we do have to limit testimony to members
public to two minutes so i just would
ask if you find uh including the
testimony
yes
sorry about that
um get back to where i was saying if
hospital 564 were to pass officers would
not have these options and would be
forced to decide whether to subject
themselves to potential injury by
physical confrontation or utilize lethal
force as seen in the u.s capitol
building riots that sergeant lang
discussed
by removing these options you are
inherently increasing the risk to the
general public police officers and
suspects
thank you sergeant we do have to limit
testimony to two minutes per per witness
and i believe the art you've exceeded
that time by about 30 seconds we do
um me no disrespect to
um
interrupting but we do have to move on
to the next way this and fairness
representative hopper uh yeah thank you
mr chair thank you uh for uh sergeant
for taking my question
if in some of the cases around the
united states because it seems like
we're really not talking about new
hampshire today
i have seen uh frozen water bottles
thrown at police bricks thrown at police
uh molotov cocktail stronger police
what non-lethal
uh remedy would they have to try to
control those
crowds that are
you know um
attacking them if we if we
can you hear me
yes
no i agree with you 100 on that the
individuals that are in favor of this
house bill
i think they need to educate themselves
a little bit on what less lethal
munitions are
um in the effectiveness it has and what
else what are the tools the police
department have to protect the community
and the officers at these situations
representative
representatives
thank you for taking my question
my question is whether or not officers
carry weapons like tear gas uh and
rubber bullets uh as a matter of course
or if these are weapons
uh that are only
uh
provided or used uh in situations like
um
uh
public protests yeah you mentioned that
there are situations where you may have
some people in a building that you may
want to evacuate
um i'm just curious uh how special
these weapons are in the course of a
that's why i make drama muted can you
hear me
yes yes
the typical officer does not have access
to these uh to these munitions that we
speak of here today
these munitions are usually utilized um
after uh safe considerations and
detailed operation plans have been
deployed um the testimony that you heard
here before us earlier um they indicate
that they're concerned about officers
deploying these rounds blindly into
crowds which is not the case and it's
not near the training that's received
here in the state of new hampshire
uh these uh these these tools that the
officers have um are not utilized on a
day-to-day basis um here in new
hampshire um they are used only for
specific
representative
in terms of the training that you
receive you you said that you received
training in the use of these these
weapons that you actually call editions
which has more of a military context
than a public police uh policing context
uh but i'm curious to what extent uh
if you had to weigh the amount of
training that you received uh in the use
of these weapons
uh in these types of situations versus
the amount of training that you receive
in
where do things lie
yes sir it's about the same
like i said before i would love for uh
any uh individual of the community to
come join us during one of these events
um and see the uh the planning that goes
into these
um
we do not plan or nor do we want to use
any of these munitions or these tools
our ultimate goal is a peaceful is a
peaceful resolution to everything
unfortunately
there are incidents that occur that
result in the use of these tools in
order for the police to properly do
their job
to protect themselves the community and
the people that are present at these
events
or
they're not just used at events i love
everybody keeps on talking about how
these are used at protests um you need
to understand that these in state of new
hampshire um
i can't remember the last time they were
actually used during an event um
or a protest
the majority of these tools that are
used are used for barricaded subjects
here in new hampshire
um
and obviously this bill pertains to new
hampshire
itself we're not looking
across the uh across the nation at this
time
representative newman
thank you mr chairman thank you sergeant
um if this
in your opinion if this bill was somehow
limited
to uh prohibit the use of these
items
at only uh events and things like that
for crowd control
and the restriction not apply to the
other uses that police have for
like getting a suspect out of a house
would that make the mo that make bill
no i still would disagree with the bill
when i would be opposed to it
these tools have been proven to be
effective
and safe to use as liners are used
appropriately
if you take these tools away from the
police here in new hampshire
unfortunately my testimony was cut short
but i was trying to explain during my
testimony what less lethal force is
and what lethal force is and people need
to understand that if you take these
tools away from the police
i know that the earlier testimony people
talked about shields and batons
um and etc but we need to understand
that you take these tools away from the
police with an um we didn't have
different a different outcome um than we
normally would when we were able to
see no further questions i want to thank
the
before we call the the next witness i
just want to address the committee well
we're going to do
a
public hearing on hb 564 is going to be
in recess to
115.
i'm going to open the public hearing on
php 81 just to introduce the bill and
put then that will also be we'll also
recess and we're going to pick up we're
going to be on
[Music]
so at this time
at
12 46 p.m
we are
the public hearing on hb 564 is in
recess
at this time we are opening the public
hearing on hb
81.
i see representative abrams saying
mr chairman can you hear me
yes we can i hope you can hear me
i can hear you thank you i hear you're
much better there your voice come out
louder thank you um for the record i'm
representative albal the sower
rockingham county district five which is
londonderry
i want to thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
and i wanted on hb 81
uh in support of this bill as a
co-sponsor
this is a simple change it's a
housekeeping bill
which means that the rsa will say that
not only can you use deadly force to
defend yourself but that you will also
be able to use deadly force to defend
your family's members
this bill
will ensure that the rsa aligned with
the new hampshire constitution part
first article 2a
apparently when we did the bill of years
ago
it was we forgot to put other to match
it with the um constitution so i'm
asking mr chair members of the committee
uh to support this bill
and thank you very much for your time in
consideration
short and sweet
thank you representative
the witness is excused
thank you thank
you this time
uh
hb 81 will be in recess
the criminal justice public safety
committee will be in recess to 1 15
pm hey john
yes i'm take am i taking the van
yeah
let's mute
you can't find the
person
i am on i had to step away for a moment
um you know how to move us and bring
that picture up that we're out to launch
until 115. and representative there is a
representative
schmidt that's been trying to testify
yeah we can't find well representative
burt and i both can't find it's under
peter smith's i found it
okay that's okay
that's where i've been you know
we're gonna call uh so to the
representative that we've been
struggling with
we're going to call that representative
first we apologize
despite the technical difficulties we
are we gonna recess
you
oh
[Music]
does anyone know where our
is
recess with just to go into recess
i think because we we need to get bills
out of the community i think we can at
least we're not gonna we're probably not
gonna exact 564 today
but i think we can exactly 66. there's
no amendment that's coming
but i want to wait for representative
marston and the purpose to call me to
get here so if they're close
we don't have to wait for them i think
we know
yes
what do you want me to tell them
i think we can at least you got to get
bills out of committee
or we're not going to meet any deadlines
so
his phone's over there he keeps dinging
i keep telling him to
mute his phone
all right let me try it one more time
yeah
i just said move your phone back
all right
casey in casing and dick come back we'll
reset that again
good afternoon uh we are
we are
we're reopening uh the public hearing
and
and i pray we get this right this time
we're going to call representative
schmidt
and i would ask representative please
yes i can hear you mr chairman
is representative
there we go i think i've been unmuted
is this represented is this
representative
it is indeed thank you so much and my
deepest apologies for not uh signing up
ahead of time
our problem was is that on the list that
he'll calling appears as a number so we
did not know who
the number was
by fault my fault entirely and i do
apologize may i begin to save you some
time
yes but you are you when you give your
testimony i would just ask you limit the
testimony
two minutes got it i'll talk quickly uh
thank you mr chairman and honored
members of the committee for the record
my name is jan schmidt and i represent
ward one in nashua um
when the country erupted because of the
murder of black citizens by a few
corrupt police the citizens of nashua
were worried on the news they could see
people like themselves in those who were
being killed they also saw stickers on
telephone poles here in nashua of white
supremacists inviting people to join and
families were rightfully terrified that
was when the nashua conversation on race
and justice was formed and this group
continues to this day offering our
community an opportunity to discuss with
the police chief and his officers issues
that we believe are racially biased
nashua's police are nationally
accredited and um go through a rigorous
uh
test
to be reaccredited each year um and
they're also full members of the nashua
conversation of race and justice and
this bill has nothing to do with those
good people but just like much of what
new hampshire does the country follows
this bill as amended should be part of
any police department's manuals peaceful
protests need to be protected by the
police as they have been in nashua and
when a few people do something that
needs to be stopped the rest of the
people should be kept safe
passing this into law would send a
message to the rest of the country and
all of the good people in new hampshire
the pepper spraying a person kneeling
with their hands behind their head among
other things is wrong
so these are the few things that they
wanted to amend
to
to keep from being used against unarmed
persons
to keep from uh being used
indiscriminately into a crowd and to
prohibit um gas from being used without
first warning a crowd and giving people
time uh and a route to disperse and
that's the end of my testimony i hope i
i'll become glad to answer any questions
thank you representative and again i we
we apologize for uh
our technical difficulties but
totally my fault
our representative testament
thank you thank you for taking my
question
certainly
quickly
an unobserved citizen would be somebody
who's standing there and not holding
oh well
representative
if you just raise your hand you don't
need to say say fall
so
it only
holds true if
they have something that would kill
another person or would just injured
i mean like a bottle of water i honestly
don't know i'm sure the police would see
a bottle of water thrown at them as as
something that is not intentional to
hurt them
that's that's just not something that
can
so i've seen
pictures of people
uh
carrying skateboards that seems to be
the weapon of choice
so would that be an armed person
it depends on the situation are they
holding it up over their head yes they
are armed if they're rolling on it on
the road no
thank you
certainly
seeing no questions i i again thank the
representative for time
thanks for your patience with this this
is a it's going to be a very long day
for you folks i hope it goes quickly
so just to let what we're going to do uh
we're just going to put our hb 564 is
going to go back into recess
temporarily
and what
what the chairs gonna do is we're gonna
and mr chair we do have uh sign ins on
hb
of 564 if you would like me to read them
rick's representative news after after
the
session on hb66 we're going to go reopen
the hearing for 564.
and you can read them
as soon as you go open here let's read
those just to make sure we do that
but
if you want i think we should read it at
the end of the hearing 564.
we're opening the executive session on
house bill
66 on the chair
thank you mr chairman
mr chairman i move house bill 66 itl and
expedia to legislate
representative wallace do you wish to
speak
yes briefly thank you
um
pass with two sides of this
we have to we have to
make sure that our law enforcement have
the tools that they need to be able to
maintain uh order on the streets of our
civil society
uh
it's apparent that repealing
rsa 627 colon 5 part 8
would seriously impact their ability to
do their jobs effectively so
based upon that
more it doesn't really solve the problem
here in new hampshire than
presently or historically according to
the chair will open this uh open the
question for discussion
representative gathered
when i first got this bill when i read
it
my colleague did
however i really
dug into it
the
term
effect
is truly not necessary
because
eliminate
what uh
the sponsors have put in here to
eliminate
you still have the same tone as to what
what the person is trying to say here
so for me i can read this i'll just read
uh the one let's say b
on the on the roman rule 2
to prevent the escape from custody of a
person whom
so for me and i think when this was put
here
it i really struggled with it before
why do you need effect
or any of that
what's the purpose and to and i have not
seen where anyone has
actually
told me that effect is more important
than not having a bear
i don't think that that that verb
generates anything other than even if it
wasn't bigger it would make a difference
so
for me
it's a cleanup deal
and i don't think it's necessary that we
so i do not agree with the bmi ipl as
well
representative muse
hughes
yes thank you um this is a bill that
actually came before us in some form uh
last year and i think last year a lot of
us were confused by it i think there was
a lot of confusion around exactly what
an effect what affecting an arrest is
and
one of the things that i think was a
good outcome of the hearing today is
that we really had a chance to sort of
drill into that
and to understand uh understand that a
little bit better
but the thing that that really stuck
with me in the end is
you know the whole question of whether
or not we
we can value an arrest over over a human
life
so
is it is it ever worth taking a human
life in the in the course of of an
arrest
and
um
especially when you have a choice to
uh to
uh
to let the person go or perhaps to use
some sort of a um of a
more reasonable measure
um
i think one of the things that
that a lot of
a lot of people have been very disturbed
by over the last few years is that with
the increasing use of police body cams
we we actually have seen
quite a few incidents of where people uh
where our officers in particular
will shoot somebody fleeing in a rest
and
and that person
that person
that person dies
so
[Music]
the bottom line is uh we don't have a
death penalty in new hampshire
anymore
and when someone is fleeing in a way
that um
that isn't creating a specific threat
for the officer involved
it it does seem reasonable to me uh you
know to uh
to eliminate this this does not take
away eliminating it would not take away
the ability of an officer uh to defend
himself or herself um if she was under
you know he or she was under uh attacked
by somebody who was threatening their
life um but what it what it does seem to
do
is to
lower the possibility that we're going
to have one of those incidents in new
hampshire um that we're all going to
regret and that we all
should have or
would be thinking later it would have
been nice to have done something about
that so to me this is an opportunity to
maybe be
a little more uh proactive and and i've
actually
changed positions on this i think i
think last year i i didn't see the the
need for it or the use for it but the
hearing today
helped me understand uh why something
thank you mr chairman
i too am confused about the uh
the effect of an arrest
but and i hear all this most of the
commentary being about the
the person trying to escape or trying to
flee
and
i think i just can't find the line that
delineates between affecting an arrest
and and trying to flee
and so i'm still pretty mu i haven't
made up a decision my decision what i'm
going to do but
i am really confused by that
so just to help help
and understanding this is the way i
interpret it and not always right but
so
there is a
if you're in custody you don't have to
necessarily be arrested to be in custody
but generally you can't you're not free
to leave
when you're in custody you can be in
custody for more than one reason but if
you are arrested
you are most certainly in custody in
that scenario
what this says affecting the arrest is i
always i interpret that as the officer
is trying to arrest the person to bring
them into custody
so when it comes to the
trying to escape language i'm reading
that as
they can be trying to escape whether
they're in custody or they could be
trying to escape to a you know evade
being arrested
i think if you can have hope the
difference is
this will allow
still allow won't have any effect on a
person already in custody who's
attempting
to escape
but this will prevent someone who's
trying to escape
that's not in custody
and
that and that's near and i'm just
reading right off it is
using a deadly weapon and attempting to
escape so
in that scenario i would assume
the person has in their possession
some sort of deadly weapon and they're
using the deadly weapon
to help
further their escape and that's an
escape to evade being arrested not to
just get a baby
escape custody does that make it does
that help clarify it that's just the way
i recovered
yes
thank you mr chairman and my only
and i pose it as a question
when was the last time in the state of
new hampshire i don't care about north
carolina or florida
california
when in new hampshire was somebody shot
just which it's trying to still be
representative martin do you mind just
speaking louder some of the members who
are participating remotely i could not
just
trying to not play with the microphones
i've never been accused of not speaking
loud enough
but i'll go again in that and just make
this a rhetorical question because i
don't believe
it's ever happened in new hampshire now
i could be wrong
but i don't think anybody has been shot
fleeing the police
that is to say like you see in some of
these other states they're shut in the
back that don't happen in new hampshire
[Music]
was playing in a vehicle
a few years ago and you're not able to
determine representative i don't believe
representative knight can uh hear you uh
if you don't mind speaking
speaking louder i'm not sure if there's
even a microphone near me so i'm not
sure how loudly to speak but i was only
saying that i believe a few years ago in
where there was a shooting involving
police and a man who was fleeing
representative hopper
uh thank you mr chairman
in response to uh representatives
comment about where
um
i thought of that exact case we were
when we were hearing the bill
and the issue with that is the police
and where believed that their lives were
in danger
because they were being attacked by the
man's vehicle
i believe the attorney general
investigated that
and
i see the problem there not necessarily
with the police but if the attorney
general investigated that
and the man was unarmed
i i think
the
issue might be with the attorney general
um
i want to say that
in my opinion
this bill
is
a start in trying to
um
i'm not saying limit the powers of the
police department but put some guidance
around what they do
it's not saying that they can't
arrest or any of those things okay
what it's you know like i said removing
the effect
from the from the bill
um does not change anything there and
when you look at the section that you
talked about in terms of um
attempting to escape there's no change
to that section so we're not even
speaking on that we're speaking on the
sections where
effect and arrest
is being requested to be removed
so i will say again
new hampshire has their problems
always have
and hopefully
with the changing times things will
change for the better
but i've been here since 79 and i know
for a fact and yes people have been shot
and um so
i'm just saying that for me
this is
um
it's
it's like
a guidance for a police department okay
um so that
if they're doing their duty right
the verge means nothing
it really doesn't if they're doing what
they're supposed to do
then change removing effect
representative ordnay
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um i think that this bill has some merit
i think uh we should
make it off a path um
i'll look at two things two questions
a is
uh under um a
the officer still has the right to
defend herself with basic force their
life
is
threatened
however in b we look at
the words are the officer reasonably
believe
a person has committed or is committing
a felony involving the use of foreign
so if
the officer is allowed to use every
force in this case
they are basically
the
judge
in the jury
and uh
condemning someone who has not been
convicted from you so i have to say that
this
bill
representative testerman
what worries me here
is that
this is sort of a
me too kind of a thing it's like my kid
coming to me and saying i want to go
wherever
because johnny is going there
we're trying to appropriate
into new hampshire
portland of minneapolis
of california is
of seattle
and and we assume that they can happen
here
well maybe they could happen here but
they haven't and i don't think it's you
know here we are trying to second-guess
the police
and their training and and i just really
take offense at the fact that
something happened in minneapolis oh my
goodness we have to do something about
it or something happened in portland i
know we have to do something about it i
i just see
a complete a me too kind of a
system thank you
just in fairness that point we did have
this
virtually identical bill filed last term
in the first term before all those
events occurred so
i wouldn't
i understand what what you mean by some
legislation being reactive to odd state
events i don't feel that out of i don't
feel this one needs that because we did
have it
last year it was i believe had similar
sponsors last year and uh
but i do i do understand what you're
saying i just want to clarify that
the people who weren't on the committee
last year the last term we heard of
thank you mr chairman i'm really
association with this with the metoo
movement
i'm if he could elaborate on that
because i don't understand if he
understands what the metoo movement was
do you want to address it thank you
point of order mr chairman
uh thank you mr chairman is this
appropriate during an exec session that
well i i i think during the purpose of
the discussions that we have during the
executive session is if a member wants a
ask of another member to clarify their
comments
i think that's a fair question
i'm not sure that the
me too
has much to do with the use of force of
all the police officers so i
i would kind of get into whether this
whether this is necessary purpose of
this bill we are on when i say an
incredibly tight schedule i don't know
if getting off topic into another
i would say
we can talk about that topic that can
take a full day so i'm not sure it would
be helpful to this
this discussion
to discuss
unrelated discussion of that nature i
will
allow you to clarify but i just don't i
don't understand how
you did say it which is the only just
the mere fact you said is what made it
relevant
i believe i know what they're referring
to as me too
they've appropriated that and that's
fine for certain people
i was using it in a general context
i i don't have a question no throw out
representative roy
thank you um i just
i agree with the premise that a police
officer should almost never shoot
someone in the back who is fleeing a
scene
um it should be so rare that it's almost
non-existent however there are times
when it could be necessary uh if a woman
comes into the police department she
severely beats me and nick takes out a
complaint and he also goes to arrest the
guy and he runs and says i'm going to
kill her
what does he just let him go because
he's an arm but there's certain
situations where we can't dictate that
could happen on the fly
the part of this law that bothers me is
the part that says that an officer
can respond to deadly force with deadly
force
it doesn't necessarily if you are shot
with a taser you're incapacitated
so you can't you can't that's not dead
before as a matter of fact they say it's
not
but you'll be able to have them to
defend yourself once you've been
incapacitated by them so to put an
officer in a position where someone
picks up their taser
that it could have fallen out or they
could have pulled it off their belt and
say well you can't use deadly force
because that is a deadly force well
you're going to be incapacitated so what
happens after that you just got to
hopefully they're nice i mean we're
getting into so much minutia here that
you're trying to anticipate every
situation and you can
so i feel like putting blanket
statements out that you can only use
deadly force in response to deadly force
it's going to put police officers an
untenable position but i i agree with
cleaning up approaching the law that
says you can't shoot affiliate
just by the mere fact that they're
felonies should never be shooting anyone
back in extremely unknown circumstances
representative welch
i wonder if everybody in this
community will remember ed brown
ed brown
had 35 corporations at home
they surrounded the home and was
it doesn't happen that often when it
does happen there's probably a good
representative bolden
i'll try to speak loudly i hope that the
folks can hear me thank you mr parent
um i just wanted to clarify something
that was brought up earlier it has
happened in new hampshire
specifically the incident and where
we pretty much could take a position on
whether it was justified
they they didn't find that it was
justified they didn't find that it was
not justified they they took no position
um and the
man who was shot he died and
he was waiting arrest at the time
and was bullying and his family won a
suit against the police department for
three hundred thousand dollars after his
death
uh
seeing no no further hands race for
discussion
uh the clerk will uh call the role if
you're in support of the motion to itl
in expedia
please say yay
if
you are opposed please say nay
vice chairman
yeah
representative burke
yes
representative copper yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative roy
i'm sorry representative testerman yes
yes
pratt
representative morrison yes
the clerk's votes yes
representative kerry
no
representative
hurry
yes
representative ordnae
no
nope
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
now
representative bradley
no
chairman
abbas the chair votes yes
mr chairman 14 years seven days
by a vote of 14 days uh it's
seven days the
representative wallace will you be doing
the
majority report
yes sir will someone be
okay
representative walls
thank you mr chairman just for
clarification you need that majority
report by 10 o'clock tonight correct
that's correct please please
prepare
your reports by send them to the
that will
now close the executive session on
housekill 66.
uh representative muse
oh yes mr chair just wanted to uh to
read the uh the folks signing in uh
on
hb66 we had 14 people sign in support
and we had uh three people uh who were
opposed and i did not hear who
volunteered to do the minority report
representative gathering is going to do
the minority point and representative
thank you again for that
healthy reminder
at this time we'll close the executive
session on hb 66
at this time we are going to reopen the
um
is
sheila available uh
in the audience
signed up in support uh speaking support
of
hp 556
mr chairman before lunch um the
individual was online uh but
i do not see their name at this point mr
chairman i was just asking if
we're going to move on with the next we
have a few hands raised but if anyone
sees that that member of the public
rejoins the list please bring it to the
and if i just may identify yourself uh
for the record which organization you're
speaking on behalf and whether you are
testifying
uh in support or in opposition of house
bill 564.
uh uh yes mr chairman can you hear me
yes i can yes uh i apologize for that my
name is doug marino um
i uh i work for an organization called
6034 but i am testifying on behalf of
myself uh today uh in support of house
bill 564.
um i won't reiterate testimony that's
already been said but i just want to
offer my voice and support
um systemic racism is a huge problem in
new hampshire um and house bill 564. is
an important represents an important
step in the right direction
uh to make sure that um
um
that we that law enforcement um you know
does not use excessive force um and we
know that these issues
disproportionately impact people of
color
new hampshire is not innocent um and
frankly i've been a little bit disturbed
by the behavior of some committee
members uh during some of the previous
testimony on this bill and just i hope
that committee members will take this
seriously and and vote ought to pass
seeing no questions i want to thank
hello can you hear me
yes we can hear you and just a reminder
your testimony needs to be limited to
two minutes
okay awesome
good afternoon my name is renelle chella
co-founder of black lives matter
manchester i'm here today to testify in
support of hp 564
on behalf of the organization in june of
last year we held a peaceful candlelight
vigil at manchester and stark park in
the days that preceded many advised us
to cancel that event and i was told by
mpd so this is the manchester police
department that unfortunately things
were going to get ugly we had seen the
aftermath of police presence at similar
events all across the country the use
and misuse of tear gas and rubber
bullets caused permanent physical and
emotional damage to undeserving targets
going into sark park that night that was
the number one fear on our list i
thought of the possibility of spending
the week of my 21st birthday in a
hospital bed recovering from injuries
given to me by the one sworn to serve
and protect it could have been me let me
be clear new hampshire is not immune to
having similar events occur here so the
fact that these things are not used here
that often is irrelevant new hampshire
says new hampshire is by no means
innocent at any moment this past summer
our cities and towns could have made
national news as a result of peaceful
protest gone wrong and that's when many
of these events turn violent by the way
it doesn't matter how
it doesn't matter that um
we haven't seen these things happen in
new hampshire because
it could very well turn violent not at
the hands of us the organizers but at
the hands of the ones who arrived under
the guise of maintaining order with that
black lives matter manchester
enthusiastically enthusiastically
supports this bill and we're asking that
you do do the same and i just would also
like to say that i would ask the chair
to reconsider his decision to not
reprimand the representative that
laughed during jordan's testimony
[Music]
thank you for your testimony
seeing no hands raised
the next witness is
jr
fuel
hello chairman abbas members of the
committee can you hear me
yes we can okay thank you i i speak on
myself
this is for the record this is j.r holt
dunbarton new hampshire former state rep
i'm currently on the board of the new
hampshire firearms coalition
i did not sign in favor or in opposition
to this bill i wanted to point out
something that's important which is
has to do with the lethal use of lethal
force
there is a policy known as escalation of
force from not response on the on the
benign end all the way over to lethal
force
on the extreme end
and i want the committee to understand
that if they pass this bill
they're going to limit the options and i
don't want to see a situation where a
police officer is ever forced to make a
tough decision between not responding at
all and having to use lethal force
i do think
that appropriate statutes should be in
place
that if a person an officer misuses
non-lethal force
and it results in unintended
consequences
for instance firing a rubber bullet into
a crowd and hitting an innocent
bystander that appropriate
discipline is in place and i think
that's the the message coming from um
those who are expressing a desire to
pass this bill and i'm not sure our
statutes do a good job about assigning
responsibility to the officer for
misusing
a less than lethal force tool
um the bill has filed i have concerns
with but the bill
um
the idea of making sure that police
officers are held accountable for misuse
of force is an appropriate thing to do
in statute
and that concludes my testimony
see no
seeing no hands raised the witness is
excused
thank you mr chair uh representative max
abramson representing hampton hampton
falls and seabrook
i disagree with the bill um i haven't
seen the amendment but i
agree with what the bill is trying to do
except that i would say that i i think
it's much preferable and even laudable
that police use uh non-lethal force and
non-deadly force whenever it's possible
i've started putting together an
amendment on this bill also
and it would simply take
the use of rubber bullets and tear gas
and instead of it being prohibited
i would put that in the definition of
non-deadly force which is in rsa 627
section 9 part 4.
and that's being drafted right now
the deadly force
during the
blm riots all summer
over 40 people were killed police would
be allowed to use deadly force for that
um
many buildings were burned down some
occupied hundreds of vehicles were were
destroyed vehicles drivers were attacked
some of them with family and animals in
the vehicle
it's a question about whether or not
you'd be allowed to use an officer would
be allowed to use deadly or non-deadly
force in that situation so that's
another a great area we have to deal
with
another one is
you had people screaming racial slurs at
black and latino officers during those
protests
and that's also another question because
that type of
screaming sometimes does lead to an
escalation of violence so i think to to
be absolutely clear
this committee has done it before
with both deadly force and non-deadly
force is to add in
the use of tear gas or rubber bullets as
putting it under the definition of
someone's on mute
thank you
um yes am i being called on to speak
yes sorry
just please i gotta please identify
yourself state whether where you're from
whether you are testifying in
uh support or in opposition to a house
bill fire system
thank you so much yes my name is asana
elgini and i'm here in strong support of
hb564
thank you for taking my testimony um
just hearing from what happened today
just kind of want to express some things
i think it's very important that we're
listening to vulnerable communities that
took time out of their day today to let
you know how they're feeling and how
scared they are when they go out to
express their constitutional right
to express themselves and we heard
particularly from the black community
that this is needed and i think we need
to
listen to our community members that are
vulnerable i also want to express my
extreme disappointment that somebody was
cut off earlier a black gentleman who
expressed um racism or expressed the the
fact that there is racism in our state
and there was laughing from our
representatives i think that is very
inappropriate and something should be
done about that that sends a a wrong
message to our community members that
their experiences are invalid just
because others don't face them
themselves um so it's uh i think it's
very important that we're passing
something like this to protect
vulnerable communities and to send them
a message that we are there for them
when they're coming to us and they're
saying they need to be protected and so
when people say this doesn't happen in
new hampshire they're basically saying
we're not going to protect you from
making sure it doesn't happen in new
thank you for your testimony
seeing no
no hands raised
the public hearing
we will
now reopen the public hearing on house
so
that was the c or k
with the k
can you hear me now
yes
i'm reverend kendra ford and i'm an
ordained minister in the unitarian
universalist tradition and i have served
a congregation in exeter new hampshire
for 19 years
i'm here to testify against hb 81
and i will submit some written testimony
for
hb 145 and 197 as well i can't stay for
many of the situations in which lethal
force would be allowed are situations in
which people make choices based on how
they feel
in a given moment
and most of us do not make our best
choices in unpredictable situations
because
our limbic brain is activated
which is to say we're not thinking we're
just feeling
hb 81 as well as 145 and 197
allow people to shoot others because
they feel
threatened
when there is not necessarily actually a
threat
we have seen this occur over and over
around our country
african-american people in particular
have been shot because
white people feel uneasy in their
presence
multiple studies have shown that white
people are irrationally uneasy in the
presence of people of color
even in objectively neutral situations
so these bills
that allow the expanded use of weapons
when people feel threatened
are likely to be life-threatening for
expanding when people can use deadly
force means that we are deciding to
privilege the use of guns
over the well-being of humans
and saying that we think it is more
important to protect things
than the sanctity of human life
giving people wider authorization to
solve problems by shooting
doesn't solve any problems in our
society if there are problems that
need to be solved that are conflicts
between people
conflicts over the taking of things
i want us to look
back upstream
and figure out the sources of the fear
and the anger and apply our work and our
resources there
i would ask that instead of legislating
to expand gun use
that we put our state and community
resources into training the public and
the police in methods of de-escalation
and that we address our society
conflicts and unease
in ways that build connection and value
human living
over material things
thank you for your time and for all the
thank you for your thank you for your
testimony
representative testament
thank you
thank you for taking my question
i have a simple one
do you believe that it's all right
to take a life of an
unborn infant
i asked the witness to
not answer that question
this is this is not i don't see how it's
but
i respectfully to the representative
i don't believe the issue of
abortion or pro-life whatever everyone
call it is relevant to this bill that's
my this decision there's also a point of
order raised i don't know what that
point of order is
does the representative still have a
point of order
respectfully mr chairman you're
i i would like to say
that we were talking about
the feelings
of somebody who was who was going to
kill somebody else
i just wanted to want to find out
you know what the feelings were
of the
the person offering testimony when it
came to taking the life of the unborn
engine
representative i i understood the
question that yes i just i don't feel
like that
that topic
and i understand the
analogy i just i don't think the purpose
of this build
you talk about
get into that subject okay
thank you mr chairman i have a quick
question do you feel that
for the witness and thank you
for your testimony
do you feel that
a person who is observing a crime
that they think they have the right now
deadly force
can tell the difference
between if that crime is a misdemeanor
or felony
um i think that
most people
in the general public would not have any
such categories in their mind
about what's a felony and what's a
misdemeanor
representative marston
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking out my question
i'd like to point out that the final
part of this
bill is talking about
somebody acting in somebody else's
dwelling
or cartilage
and kind of get a kick out of that word
but matter when somebody's trying to get
into your house
and your
life is possibly threatened and you're
saying you don't want to be able to use
force to stop them
you're you're asking me if i if i want
to be able to shoot someone if someone's
breaking into my house is that what
you're asking me
correct
i do not want to shoot someone if
seeing no further questions questions i
can you hear me
yes
okay i'm bill kingston from newcastle
and i'm speaking for myself in
opposition to this bill
i'm a gun owner and a marine corps
veteran with combat experience and i've
been in deadly situations
and you will also recall that i sent all
of you the report from the american bar
association on stand your ground laws
in the opening sentence of this proposal
the author wishes to insert the word
duty into the right of self-defense
now this is a radical departure from all
previous statutes and court decisions
and it is not the new hampshire way the
right of self-defense is one of the
basic principles of every civilized
society this one word strives to change
that and will have enormous impact on
the people of new hampshire
article two of the new hampshire
constitution guarantees our natural
rights
it specifically mentions the right to
defend oneself and then immediately
spells out the right to seeking and
obtaining happiness it further goes on
to say equality of rights under the law
shall not be decided denied or abridged
by this state on account of race creed
color sex or national origin
what i'm getting at here
is we should not make the same mistake
as florida when they adopted stand your
ground legislation
a person of color has the right to walk
through my white neighborhood
his presence should not be a point of
contention or fear
we do not need a trayvon martin case in
new hampshire please do not tell me it
cannot happen
i hear it from a few of my own neighbors
whenever a black person is in the
neighborhood what is that black kid
doing in this neighborhood
do we really want to invite this excuse
i'm sorry officer i thought he had a gun
i was only doing my duty
we should never insert duty into the
definition of self-defense this is only
an invitation for the bad actors to use
deadly force
this duty thing flies in the face of
every legal precedent that requires us
to act responsibly and use good judgment
with proportionate restraint
since it is contrary to article 2 i
believe it is also unconstitutional
therefore ladies and gentlemen i urge
you to reject reject this fundamental
and radical change to our laws here in
thank you for your testimony
representative
bradley
i thank you chairman um bill thank you
so much for coming to testify today so
um it just sounds like you're opposing
all the stand your ground bills being
introduced today is that is that so
uh yes ma'am i will be uh testifying on
representative testament
thank you
thank you for taking my question um
you testified on the whole
all the verbage that was in the bill
that much of it was is is there today in
the statute the only change that we're
making
is what you will see
in italics down in
line 10
section 2d
and we're adding the fact that they
the situation
let's say could arise where
you were defending yourself
but you couldn't defend
somebody else that was there like your
wife
all this had is
two words or another because we forgot
it when we did it last time so this
isn't
the whole bill isn't an issue it's just
two words
oh yes sir
i'm aware of that
uh however i'm objecting to the
insertion of
changing uh
the tone of uh self-defense and and
making self-defense a duty rather than a
a necessity
representative marston thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking our
questions
i'm confused by your statements that you
ran through
and i'm just wondering generally you are
against self-defending yourself
self-defense
oh no that's the that's an absurd uh
that's an absurd
interpretation of what of what i'm
trying to say here
uh everyone has a right of self defense
i'm just saying that self defense should
not be made duty
because that
leads to vigilantism which is not the
new hampshire way and it is never
just
before i go with
representative martin for a follow-up i
just want to
address when
the members of the the committee ask a
question of any member of the public
testifying
it's supposed to be done with the intent
to gather information
either about about their testimony they
provided or about the bill itself but we
don't really
we're not supposed to really engage in
debate style questions i'm just saying
we're getting a little close to that
with some of the questions so let's just
be mindful of that just to remind them
representative mark martin follow the
questions
thank you
see seeing seeing no hands raised okay
representative gathered um
i looked at 6 27 4 my room number 3
a um it says here
repeat from the encounter except that he
or she is not required to retreat
if he or she is within his or her
dualities
well anywhere he or she has the right to
be and was not the initial aggressor so
for me
why am i saying this when it's already
covered in
yes you ask me well no
comment
that's just my comment oh i didn't have
a question of them i just want to share
what i found
sorry
i know i'm sorry
to the member representative i didn't
seeing no hands raised
uh
mr kingston thank you again for your
testimony
i've asked him twice to oh nope john mu
please now
i don't know if he's there or if there's
will maybe mr mr point
please if the committee wouldn't mind
reminding me to recall
this morning at a later time
she signed up this
i've asked her to yep there she is
thank you very much minister chairman
and member of the committee and mr
chairman i'm so happy to see somebody
from my um favorite law school is
chairman of the committee this year
congratulations
um i come before you today in opposition
to house bill 81 a bill that permits the
use of deadly force in defense of
another person
the bill is better known in popular
nomenclature as a stand your ground law
otherwise known by some as kill at will
and it does nothing more than to justify
murder in the defense of another
new hampshire already has a so-called
stand your ground law
giving people a license to kill when
confronted with a perceived threat
without even considering walking away or
de-escalating the situation
and today the committee is faced with a
series of proposed bills that attempt to
make this dangerous law even more deadly
house bill 81 would expand the use of
deadly force in defense of another it
would embolden reckless gun unioners to
shoot first and ask questions later and
claim defense of another to avoid
culpability for murder
time murder legal principles and
codified self-defense laws across the
united states have long affirmed
people's right to use proportionate
physical force to defend themselves and
others against imminent violence
self-defense laws in the united states
also typically justify a person's use of
lethal force in situations where it's
reasonable for a person to believe that
lethal force was necessary to prevent
imminent death or serious bodily imagery
to themselves or another person
traditionally these laws have been clear
that taping human life is not necessary
and is therefore not justified if the
person could have avoided using that
lethal violence by retreating or simply
stepping away from a confrontation
in most u.s jurisdictions court
precedents and or state laws have carved
out an exception to this duty to
de-escalate or retreat called castle
doctrine
on the theory that a person's home is
their castle this legal principle has
traditionally created a rebuttable legal
presumption that individuals are
justified in using force against some
fun unlawfully breaking into their
occupied home
without having to consider options such
as leaving the home to avoid a threat or
confrontation
stand your ground laws abandon centuries
of legal
representative rogers i i i
i have to interrupt i do need to limit
testimony to two minutes per witness so
if you don't mind bringing your
one file
other than just the legal principles
if you don't believe that the unknowing
public could be inadvertently affected
by the the violence
and the classical death on house bill 21
i would ask you to look to the cost of
property taxpayers to this piece of
legislation
the police now always have to be suspect
if this passes to every citizen if
they're armed and if they need more
security to understand the ground laws
do a police have to be have more police
on the beat do we have to worry that if
representative we uh we have we're on
where i say our committee is on a time
crunch
that's an understatement i i don't need
to interrupt i get but i do have to uh
anyone has any questions
and i'd ask you to vote in expedience
legislate my testimony has been emailed
to you i hope you would read it instead
thank you representatives
see seeing no hands raised the
romero
i'm not seeing that name romero with an
oh all right
i'm sorry thank you
uh not still c
are you
next
allison
now
is that with an s
s-n-e-l-l
well don't see the name let me double
check up top make sure they're not up on
top
uh
oh romero is up on top i apologize dina
yes
yes we can
yes thank you
i i hope wait a few minutes
i'll be as brief as i can because i'm
actually going to
save my testimony for the other two
bills that follow
what i do want to say though is that i
oppose any
wording that expands stand your ground
in new hampshire
i want to i should start by saying i've
been i was born and raised in new
hampshire
and i don't remember in new hampshire
when i grew up here about a lot of
people owning
guns so i am definitely against
uh this bill hb81
my i want to add one more thing
um at the
the unitarian minister
expressed very beautifully what my
sentiments are
and i wish we didn't have to have this
kind of a
adversarial process i think what we're
missing
is an opportunity for people to sit down
with each other and really try to listen
i would like to understand where
representative al baldassaro is coming
from
and why he has such strong feelings
about his right to carry arms
and i would like to have an opportunity
not just to be speaking for a bill but
to
to promote and to try to get um
better understanding as opposed to
throwing out uh names like liberals and
um antifa and things like that so i will
i will stop i hope you will vote in
expedient to legislate and i'll save my
testimony for the other two bills thank
thank you for your testimony
see no no hands raised
mr chairman uh members of the committee
can you hear me
yes we can
thank you for the record my name is alan
rice and i am a resident of bedford new
hampshire
and i am here today as the new hampshire
state director for gun owners of america
we are a national second amendment
advocacy organization
with close to 200 2 million members
coast to coast
we um we support house bill 81.
um it's a very simple bill um i've
listened to some of the previous
speakers
and you know they're they're adding
levels of complexity that are really not
needed um they're talking about feelings
and emotions
um humans have an inalienable right to
self-defense
and if a person
is in your home or my home or even an
opponent's to this bill's home
and another person comes into that home
to do criminal
mischief criminal actions who is
uninvited the homeowner has a right to
defend himself
all this bill does is say the homeowner
can defend the other person who he
invited into his home to be a guest
it's adding one other word you can
defend another as well as yourself in
your home um it's not a
shoot em up bill it's not a
stand your ground it's it's in your home
you can defend somebody else who's
lawfully there
um one of the other speakers talked
about value human life those who own and
use firearms
value human life and that's why we have
self-defense guns
we don't shoot to kill
we really don't want to shoot anybody
but we do want to retain the ability to
stop a violent criminal assault and a
home invasion is about as violent as
you're going to get
and therefore
we're asking the committee to vote house
bill 81 ought to pass without any
amendments or changes
i think i'm well under two minutes and
thank you for your testimony
representative bradley
hey thank you mr chairman
um my question is what types of felonies
does this allow deadly force for that
were not previously allowed
it doesn't it allows the same level of
force
that's currently allowed in the statute
defending yourself in your home
but now you can defend another person
who you have invited into your home who
might be subject to criminal attack it
does not add any more
felonies or defenses it only says
you can defend another person who's
representative
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
mr rice for your testimony
uh basically what this bill is going to
allow is
if somebody breaks into my home
and they're going to steal my tv and i'm
upstairs with my wife i'm not going to
be happy but they're going to walk out
the door with my tv
but if they start up the stairs and say
we're here to kill your wife
would this bill allow me to defend my
wife
representative thank you for the
question um you could defend your wife
today
without this bill because she's a
cohabitant of the house
but if your cousin or your brother who
lives in vermont is sleeping over this
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the witness for the testimony
hello um am i allowed to speak
welcome back
thank you
uh again my name is asana alhini and
this time i'm speaking as the movement
politics director for rights and
democracy new hampshire and i am
speaking in strong opposition to hb 81
but also the other horrible bills hb 197
and hb 145 that will be coming up
towards the end of this committee
um people all across the country are
saying stand your ground laws and this
is exactly what these are stand your
ground laws seem innocent upon face
value but are incredibly dangerous to
innocent populations that already get
targeted because of racism and this will
allow people to harm these already
vulnerable community members and plead
self-defense this is not about gun laws
so let's make that clear today is travon
martin's birthday he would have been 26
today
in honor of his memory i want to say i
am not only appalled but i am disgusted
that bills like this are allowed to
that allowed him to be murdered are
being considered in our state
travon martin was born in florida on
february 5th 1995.
his parents sabrina fulton and tracy
martin loved him his parents wanted to
expose him to the world martin
experienced that included skiing
horseback riding a trip to new york city
to take in the sights
one of his favorite subjects was said to
be math he was tall and athletic and
inclined um with tattoos with tattoos on
his body with family members of names of
family members expressing his love for
them as they loved him on february 26 we
all know the story travon was walking
home from a convenience store he wore a
hoodie and was talking with his
girlfriend when george zimmerman felt
threatened by this 17 year old black boy
with a hoodie in his neighborhood
he followed this boy travon realized
someone was following him and started
running
george zimmerman shot and killed this
boy because in his mind he truly felt
threatened by the presence of this boy
in his community this is the law work we
currently have in place in new hampshire
and today while travon lays in his grave
we have to limit testimony for two
minutes per person
i will just let the members of the
public know
it's two minutes per bill so if at a
public hearing later on today you that
member would be able to also testify
that during the week i do have to ask
you if you can test when the time has
expired
yes
i speak in honor of treven travon martin
and also the many other black lives and
many other people that are affected by
laws like this that allow people to
shoot people and claim self-defense and
so we we need to oppose any kind of
expansion of stand your ground law
thank you for your testimony
representative bradley
thank you chairman um i really don't
have a question i just wanted to um
asthma thank you for um that powerful
testimony thank you for sharing
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
can you all hear me
yes yes okay sorry about that earlier it
was a technical glitch on my end
um dear chairman abbas and distinguished
members of the committee my name is
lauren lepage i'm here on behalf of the
national rifle association
in strong support of house bill 81.
in the face of unlawful attack
law-abiding citizens should not be
forced to retreat or run from run from a
place they have a legal right to be
it is unreasonable that victims of crime
should have to worry about being
arrested or prosecute prosecuted if they
are required to use force to defend
themselves or their loved ones any
victim should be able to presume that an
unlawful attacker especially in their
home or forcible intruder
is there for the purpose of doing harm
both of these two of the bills today
clarify and strengthen new hampshire's
self-defense law house bill 81 is a
common sense clarification in the law
all it's doing is making sure that
people know if someone is unlawfully
intruding into their dwelling or
curtilage that they both have a right to
defend themselves as well as a minor
child a wife a guest in their home
against someone who
um poses the threat
courts have consistently ruled that one
might not attack and are not required to
protect every individual in warren
versus columbia the court the courts
have exception concluded that when a
municipality or other governmental
entity undertakes to provide police
services it assumes a duty only to the
flip at large and not to individual
members of the community
for these reasons we are wrong
supportive 81 and respectfully request
the committee to support the bill
um i have emailed you testimony as well
can uh
can the members participate remotely
ms lepage you appear to be having some
technical difficulties but i don't
believe that it is on our end
if um
you heard some of it
i i'm sorry about that i have emailed
the testimony as well so i'll spare the
committee and try to figure it out on my
end but you do have a written copy of my
testimony
thank you
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
hello uh thank you members of the
committee my name is joe hannon i'm the
vice president for governors of new
hampshire
uh i'm testifying in support of hb 81
i wanted to kind of reiterate what the
previous
testifier said and uh to clear up some
confusion about uh what this bill really
does this is mostly a clerical and
bookkeeping bill this does not expand
stand your ground in any ways it doesn't
change the standard ground statute which
is 627 for
roman numeral 3
section a this has to do with
section roman numeral 2 section d
and all it does is change add the word
another
after the word actor
in section a we have the actor or a
third person in section b we have
uh against a person present
in section c
um it says about to commit kidnapping or
forcible sex offense and then finally
when it gets to d it says the actor in
their to and within such actors dwelling
or curtilage this is not something that
applies to someone who is outside in the
general public this is someone within
their own home having the ability to
protect not just themselves but it's
adding another person in that section
so it's a very clear uh very narrow
change to the law and i think it is uh
it was overlooked probably in the
initial drafting of this legislation and
it just needs to be fixed
thank you for your testimony
see
representative hoffer uh thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
when uh new hampshire uh first
passed stand your ground legislation we
were told at the time that there would
be
mass carnage in the uh streets or in the
homes in the winter
of people uh using deadly force to stop
people from uh um attacking them
representative hopper is there a
question
there is
so
since we passed a stand your ground do
you know of any uh mass carnage or
instances where that's been abused
did you hear me this one yeah okay great
you didn't seem excited about my answer
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
again thank the witness for their
testimony
representative max abramson
and can i just before the representative
testifies
uh we've been trying to keep track of of
how long the two minutes and
collectively we're struggling with
managing everything else is there a
member president today that wouldn't
mind being the
i don't know what you want to call that
position
wallace is doing that
representative
so representative please just let me
know when the two minutes is up thank
you
all right am i ready yes
okay under the gun
uh i introduced this bill last session
as house bill 208 the the same wording
it just adds the words or another this
is not a stand your ground law it's a
typo correction
and i have to admit i'm not the one who
found it it was actually while doing the
research in my self-defense case it was
uh judge delker so if anyone gets credit
for finding the typo it should go to him
in response to representative bradley's
question there are many felonies in rsa
631 and 633
that are not
necessarily defined as deadly force
deadly force is a real gray area in the
law and that's something i've asked this
committee to address in the past
but
it simply says
so stand your ground would be you have
to stand there
for sorry before standing around there
are 30 states that are standing around
states you had what was almost
considered a duty to retreat to the wall
because the life of your attacker was
considered so important this is almost
the opposite of that there's no way that
you can retreat to the wall to defend
another person who's under
attack the gang leader
who was involved in that violent brawl
in my home from my self-defense case um
later on a few weeks after the police
let him go he cut up a woman's face with
some type of glass
um
candle holder or some such thing
and uh that could be considered felony
assault it uh she could use deadly force
to defend herself but if he had attacked
her five-year-old daughter
uh she would not be allowed to use
deadly force uh last year last session
every republican and 11 democrats on the
floor voted for this every republican on
this committee voted for this bill
the term duty comes from declaration of
independence it wouldn't be added to the
statute it's just part of the findings
um i'm one of the state's foremost
experts in self-defense law um
and i can tell you that salt the rsa 627
the justifications are absolutely full
of inconsistencies
um and i'm willing to take questions
perfect timing representative abramson
all right
i saw the fingers
in two alarms went off i appreciate that
representative calmly
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question representative
davidson
is i've been wondering who to ask this
too
but is it your sincere belief
that if somebody had broken into my home
in a home invasion
and attacked my child
a visitor in my home
whenever it would be that i would be
charged with a crime for using deadly
force against that person is that your
that's that you're saying here
yes i was charged with eight felonies
eight felonies with a maximum sentence
at the time of 56 years in prison for
acting in defense of the other people in
my home that's exactly what happened in
my self-defense case i admitted uh
during closing and i probably shouldn't
but in closing arguments during the
trial that this was a defense of others
case that i was obviously acting in
defense of the other people in my home
and uh despite all of the witnesses
saying that to the police
the prosecutor patricia conway
went to a grand jury and got eight
felony indictments
and it was just by sheer luck that i
didn't end up with life in prison for
no hand hands raised i want to thank the
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak um i'll
i will say i'm opposed to this bill
as a
latina woman
i don't feel comfortable because if i
shoot someone in my property
because of my skin color the lot will
not protect me and a lot probably say
that
um
i killed someone and not because i was
trying to protect myself and then the
other thing that i will say is
i
as a new state representative i see all
of you as an example of respect
it's an example of
listen and then have a compassion to
everyone in the community no matter
where you're from no matter what
language you speak
no matter what skin color you have and
what i see today
is some of the stay
uh represented
not part of it testimony and they're not
mute and they're laughing they talking
when someone is talking and giving um
they speak
and i would like to ask with all the
respect if you're not giving your
testimony please please mute yourself
because i see all use
an example of respect and i don't see
that today and i will not take any
thank you representative perez for your
testimony
and we will we will honor the
press of the witness to not
j.r
good afternoon chairman can you hear me
yes we can okay for the record j.r hall
former state rep um currently live in
the town of dunbarton here speaking on
behalf of myself as well as the new
hampshire firearms coalition
the bill before you
house bill 81 is a simple clerical
change to the law
we've heard from numerous people today
who have expressed concerns about
firearms and stand your ground laws and
brought up all sorts of hyperbole
but the reality is
if someone is about to commit a felony
against another person in your home
whether that's a resident of your home
meaning sorry a visitor to your home or
a family member who just happens to be
there but live somewhere else
the ability to protect that person is
important and
this was clearly just a minor clerical
correction anything above and beyond
that is hyperbole from the other side
i would like to comment on the person
who asked that we should have debates
and discussions i absolutely agree with
their comment from earlier today and the
sooner that we can return to the state
house to start having these discussions
in person the better off we will be
so with that i'll close my testimony and
ask that you pass this bill as filed
did i make my time limit representative
wallace
seeing no hands raised
i want to thank the witness for the
testimony
i thank you mr chairman can you hear me
yes
terrific thank you so much mr chairman
and honorable members of the committee
um my name is doug marino um
um and i'm uh testifying in opposition
um to house bill 81 as well as the other
um
stand your ground bills coming up uh
later in this hearing um i think it's
really important for us to remember that
any bill like this is going to
disproportionately impact people of
color in new hampshire because of of
racism implicit bias
and so i urge committee members to
consider that as you're considering this
bill especially on today which is
trayvon martin's 26th birthday um
trayvon martin should be alive today but
he's not because of a vigilante who
decided to take his life
um so i would strongly strongly urge you
to take these things into consideration
and recommend that the spell is
inexpedient to legislate
mr mr mourinho thank you for your
testimony
seeing no hands raised
the
leonard corn i'm gonna figure out that
yep
can you hear me now
yes we can oh good uh
uh hello my name is leonard corn i'm a
psychiatrist from portsmouth new
hampshire i've practiced in new
hampshire since 1974.
i also represent the new hampshire
medical society and the new hampshire
psychiatric society
and i've uh submitted my testimony i'm
i'm speaking
um i throughout my career i've been
involved in issues of violence and uh
since 2013 i have been chair of the new
hampshire medical society subcommittee
on violence
psychiatrists and physicians in general
are intimately involved in issues of
inviola of violence
and as psychiatrists we treat patients
who are potentially are act actually
violent
and as general physicians of course we
treat them in our emergency rooms our
hospitals and our offices
many of us study the precursors of
violence
so i've been quite concerned with the
advent of stand your ground laws like
the one currently in effect since
2011 in new hampshire
uh
stand underground laws are relatively
new
controversial laws and they uh
introduced defenses that were never
stand your ground laws change the
dynamic fundamentally so that killing
another person becomes justifiable or
defensible in circumstances of a
subjective nature
where being threatened or feeling
threatened is enough reason to kill
where
other non-violent methods such as escape
mr corny
the two minutes has expired you need to
conclude the test of your testimony
[Music]
in my testimony that i've submitted i've
introduced a number of statistics that
have shown that stand your ground laws
increase
homicide and
i'll be glad to take your
questions
for his testimony
see no members of the public with their
hand raised
that will conclude the public hearing
this time the chair is going to open the
executive session on hb
sorry
music did i do it again
um
yes
but but
it's okay
um
on uh in terms of the sign-ons for hb
[Music]
uh uh hb 81 we had uh 78 people uh sign
in in support of the bill and we had 862
thank you and representatives i do
appreciate it for someone who's helping
remotely doing an excellent job and
assisting
uh
yeah we can hear you now
what did we miss
we'll
start over just look for the there was a
representative burt was recognized for a
motion
about the past that motion was then
seconded by representative roy
i then asked representative burke if you
would like to speak
uh to his motion
thank you again mr chairman and
the reason i support this bill is
like mr rice said and several others
i have a right to protect myself and my
wife in my home
but if my brother comes over from
vermont and visits me
apparently in new hampshire i don't have
that right and
i feel i should and again
it would be the last resort that i would
ever ever you know
reach to
um
you know and again if somebody wanted to
steal my tv i you know i don't want to
put that out on the internet but
um
you know
you know sadly i'm gonna go and buy a
new tv but you know if they come into
the house and they want to hurt one of
us
you know i want that option
not to be charged with defending their
lives
so this is a good bill i think you know
new hampshire needs it and
you know we have not seen mass carnage
since i voted for the first time in 2011
to pass
you know the original stand your ground
and this just changes a few words to add
anybody in the house thank you mr
chairman
[Music]
thank you mr chairman i i
i'm not sure the committee has read
all the section uh two
but i'll start with uh
a person is justifying the deadly force
upon another person when he is
reasonably believed that such other
person a
is about to use unlawful deadly force
against the actor or a third person
which is what i've really been hearing
the
purpose of this bill was
uh b is likely to use any unlawful force
against a person present while
committing or attempting to commit a
burglary
c
is committing or about to commit
kidnapping
or forcible sex offense
indeed
is likely to use any unlawful force in
the commission of a felony
now
unlawful force
could be only by shoving someone against
the wall
now if i were someone and if you're
making a commitment you're doing a
felony of sending selling an illegal
drug to that person
then you would then have the right based
on this law to uh
so i would say that this bill is
completely unnecessary based on a
testimony we've heard because third
person is
uh
taken care of in paragraph a
so i'm gonna oppose the motion to
autopass
and just a
for point of discussion
i think paragraph a and representative
board that
it says is about to use unlawful deadly
force against the actor or third person
when my interpretation of paragraph d
is it's is likely to use unlawful force
and the commission of a felony which
doesn't necessarily have to amount to
the involving
deadly force
against the actor and then but you could
not use you could only against
the act not against
another a third person so i think that a
indeed where they did separate
is that a is strictly involving
unlawful deadly force where i think uh d
could
would not necessarily have to rise that
well
oh not bad again
thinking
um
the problem
i have with this bill is this same
problem i had with at last
and that is
it talks about
any felony and we know that felonies
have a whole range of uh
our whole range of offenses from
drugging selling drugs
to uh
murder and robbery
now even robbery
uh
is
with a deadly weapon
is a
felony
but
i'm not sure selling drugs isn't
necessarily something that requires the
use of deadly force on
and
just declare so i read paragraph that if
if the
person was selling drugs they would also
have to if that is the felony they would
also have been using unlawful force
against the actor at the same time
that's just the way i'm reading and i
just want to clarify that i mean if i'm
representative gordon
thank you
it doesn't say indeed that it's on your
they are using deadly force they say
on
unlawful force and it was we know
that
unlawful force could be as simple as uh
punching someone in the arm or shoving
someone against the wall
anytime that you are basically uh
touching someone in a forceful way that
uh
you want them to do something for you
so
it would allow you basically
to use a deadly force for
small
infractions of
unlawful
representative holding do you wish to
speak on the
on the motion
i was listening to the testimony today i
heard a lot of testimony saying that
this is a clear king
and it appears that the um
i did the impression i hear the phrase
terrible change that means
that the sponsor who fought the
legislation that resulted in this law
had originally intended for the law to
have a broader scope than it was written
to have
that's what i hear when i hear clinical
change
um
so i have some some concerns about
um the level of understanding
uh
by many of the people getting customers
saying the impact
thank you chairman um so hb 81 proposes
um an addition to allowing deadly force
to be used when someone is using any
unlawful force in the commission of a
felony against another person within the
actor's dwelling or cartilage
hb 81 section d
is likely to use any unlawful force in
the commission of a felony against the
actor
or another within such actors dwelling
or its cartilage and at first glance
this seems like a plausible addition
however when you look closer you'll
realize that the current rsa is already
authorizing deadly force in response to
non-deadly force and that this bill
seeks to expand the use of deadly force
even further um
um i kind of spoke to this earlier today
probably should have saved it for now
but again um
in section 627.4
um
it starts at roman numeral three
and if you read down through at least
through a
um i think it already covers that
situation
so again i don't know why we have this
build when it is it does cover the third
the first uh a tells you
the first one
tells you um what's not justified but
my understanding is
we're going to actually get that portion
and that's exactly what this is from
so maybe this part of another bill i
don't know i'm just trying to say that
this bill
should be ikl
because it is already covered what
my understanding is that there's a bill
that it would actually file that would
repeal that section it's not i'd
probably
issue
mr chairman
yes
can you hear me mr chairman
yeah okay i believe that the current law
that we
i believe that the current law
covers this efficiently so i'll be
opposing this bill
and i'm not i i don't know how to make
the relationship with another bill might
be coming up
but i think that what this bill is
trying to do is already covered by
seeing no
no hands raised
at this point in time the clerk will
call the roll if you were in support of
the motion of hard to pass
please say yay
representative
yes
representative popper yes
representative green
yes
representative wallace
representative testerman yes
representative roy yes
representative marston
yes clerk votes yes
representative harry gathering yeah
representative pandolakis no
where
no
representative boarding a
representative
no
representative newman
representative bowden how
representative conley no
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley
go on consent
uh
by a vote of 11 to
years and 10 days the most
uh
will you be preparing the majority
will someone
representative colony
at this time we will close the executive
session on hp 81
this time we'll
open the public sec public hearing
mr chairman
the
last hearing was closed and at that
point um
xander rice hopkins and penny dean did
and their hands are still raised so i
don't know if they want to speak on this
come and know or not
we'll we'll address that once we once
you remove the testimony the difficult
problem is when once we close a hearing
uh
it's not as simple as reopening it i'm
not that's a
rule that's already in place that i
can't change
i just to the members of the committee
before we start i will say with
confidence that a public hearing may go
late i i will not be i don't believe
we're gonna be doing any executive
sessions on any other bills
so just
keep just to get let everyone know that
because people as people are gonna have
to leave and it's snowing
it's still snowing
and
i know some some members have difficulty
driving at night but we can still
continue to public hearings
i'll just leave it to the discretion of
the members who um
they wish to stay or not but if you want
to participate
to ask questions you still need to be
is there someone signed up to introduce
yes
thank you again mr chair
my name is michael ikobovich from
hooksett
representing their map 24
um
i'm here to
work with you on this bill bill 198
house bill 198.
i'm happy to work here to ensure that
the citizens of new hampshire
are getting
served and defended by our justice
system that's what the bill is doing
there was a need to clarify a few points
in the rsas
this is my bill
as we've heard today self-preservation
is one of the
most fundamental rights of any human
being
of any living creature actually
so this is what i felt was needed
um
this is what the bill is doing
it's enshrining the need for
self-preservation and
if a person is feeling threatened in
face of violent attackers
he may resolve to
self-defense
so it's up to the state
it's up to the justice system to be
aligned with citizens in preserving
uh and defending the right of
self-defense
and this is what this bill is doing
because you you need to defend yourself
you need to be able to defend your loved
ones
and especially your little ones when
you're faced with violent marks
so
my testimony is going to be brief i'm
i'm done
and i
i invite you to vote to pass in this
bill that clarifies
the
need and the right of self-preservation
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the representative for his testimony and
thank you very much for your patience as
well
thank you oh excuse me uh
thank you very much for taking my
question um
i'm curious when i saw this bill um it
really seems to dramatically expand the
uh
the area where a person can claim
self-defense and it seems to me as if i
read the bill uh anybody who wants to
climb into their car
um and drive towards a protest and drive
slowly towards the protest can actually
start shooting at people if they bang on
the windows
so one of my my concerns about the way
that this bill um
is framed uh and and frankly that the
way that the
the wording is uh is is extremely easy
to take this wording uh and turn it
around
and to convey a right
uh to people that they simply shouldn't
have
i'm not sure whether there's a question
but the self-reservation again i'm sorry
i'm sorry you can't hear him
uh i i apologize i should have asked you
that in the form of a question i guess
do you share do you share any of those
concerns i mean we i think we all saw
what took place uh in charlotte
i think we've seen that there are people
who can provoke these situations
are you concerned about that at all as a
as an unintended unintended consequence
you're going to be facing a violent
attacker
this is what the bill the bill is saying
and that's where you're going to resolve
this is not talking about anything else
representative
thank you corholm i hope it can be heard
online
um
i've heard that new hampshire is one of
the safest states in the country
has there been a change
uh such as a rise in the number of
i believe this is by admission that the
law already should have given the rights
to people to be able to defend against
representative bradley
thank you chairman
um so under um section one
d
it says it states is likely to use any
unlawful force so isn't that basically
uh based on an assumption
uh thank you again we're looking at
violent attacks
commission over felony
this is this is no assumption
representative welch
yes my video is simply though
if you were a victim of a carjacking
you'd be justified in using every boss
that's right
uh yes yes representative yes i agree
with you
representative coordinate
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you for uh
allowing me to answer q i asked a
question
i really don't understand this uh
paragraph e in your bill
lines six and seven can you explain to
i'm sorry i couldn't hear you you're
uh i don't understand your paragraph e
uh
yes
if attackers
in a group
which is definition of a riot elsewhere
in the rsas
are trying to attack you
you're justified just like in
in any other
paragraph
if when it is just a witness if we give
uh provide your copy before
art
we just got the books today by the way
that are enrolling
uh you intend on bringing these to the
uh house session so
if if you're there please let me know
and i'll make sure to bring them up for
you
uh the printout is
just one section
i'm just asking where does
like look
can i have a follow-up question
yes ma'am
um
previously you
looked at that
this has to do with
people using uh
i don't see the language in
the bill that
said that people perpetrating
[Music]
um
i'm not sorry there was a question but
and i know yeah deadly forces are lawful
follow representative board name
yes mr thank you um
your the bill says unlawful force that
is not deadly is that true you
um
i'm gonna have to yeah i don't have the
book with me
so i'm gonna have to if you have if
you're able to look it up please do so
otherwise i'll have to get back to you
um
i walked up to you and said give me your
car are you then justified to shoot me
i mean i guess
no i would probably laugh i don't know
representative
representative bolden
thank you mr parent
i was just wondering is there an
incident that occurred that inspired
thank you for the question it's not one
incident this whole year i'm sorry 2020
has been
crazy crazy with everything that's going
on everywhere
um
so i feel that the citizens need to feel
safer
rather than less safe because
yeah
the whole year has been quite upsetting
for many people
thank you chair for taking my question
uh thank you representative for taking
my question
if your goal is to make people feel safe
which we just heard
how would you feel if you knew most of
the population new hampshire would feel
were the women's mind repeating his
answer
i would question the statistics brought
forward that most of the population was
still unsafe i i don't understand where
representative now you have a follow-up
question
yes chair thank you for recognizing me
uh follow-up is what's what statistics
you said most popular most of the
population would feel unsafe so that's
well i'm sorry can i clarify chair
tonight just let the witness answer
answer the finish answering the question
if you have a further follow-up question
i will i will most certainly recognize
you to ask a follow-up question as
you've seen i've been
recognizing virtually every question
apologies
um
you said that population would feel
unsafe
um i don't know where you get that
statistics from and i would question the
that kind of study
that's yeah that's my answer
representative question
yes thank you i just wanted to know
because you're talking about how many
people feel unsafe that need this so you
must i just thought you would have some
i'm sorry
i don't see a question in that
do you have the statistics
for how many people currently feel
unsafe and need this
law to pass that will give us a clue on
how many people would feel unsafe if it
to me this law is in the mission in
statute that needed clarification
so
it
if it passes that means it's needed
that's
that's what i'm gonna go by those are
the
thank you
um
it says here commission of riot um
can you tell me
um
or describe to me what you're
considering my right to be
and
the definition is that you are saying
the book the german hand
i'm sorry you don't want to be with me
but to me any
um attack a violent attacker
i'm sorry
say it one more
time i'm saying the definition is any
recipe we're gonna go by the definition
when the wall was drafted that's what i
was looking at
so
if you have access to it you can take a
well there is a legal definition on the
books
[Music]
i believe our representative gaffit does
that's the black swat dictionary i think
it might be an rsa
hopefully they're similar but they may
my follow-up this um
okay um
have you
been a part of
or seen a right here that kind of fits
in new hampshire
i have not been a part of any violent
and so
yeah in the right the definition of
writers in the rsa it's not my
definition
representative
question okay my question is have you
been apart or
seen
a riot here i just read the definition
oh
and
particularly in terms of
that's the question right right i i got
no i have not participated in anything
there and i haven't seen it up close no
not available
seeing no hands raised i want to thank
the representative first time you
all timekeeper
[Music]
i'm not sure i believe that
so at two minutes just give me a thumbs
up
maybe go like this you know five seconds
more ten seconds
so is it thank you
right now
is that with a c
i am not seeing kayla
turner
leonard
that was with a k i'm not seeing his
name either
he did testify during the last hearing
um if he does return just please bring
can you hear me
hello
yes we can here okay thank you
uh chairman abbas and committee members
thank you for this opportunity to
testify my name is lois cody i'm a
resident of manchester to volunteer with
mom's demand action speaking today to
urge you to oppose house bill 197
in changing new hampshire rsa 627 colon
4 section c and d and adding section e
house bill 197 extends the potential
area where a person can shoot to kill in
public to the entire community
additionally under the new section e for
example three people rushing to aid a
person or persons screaming in distress
in any given setting
could be mistaken for committing riot
and shot or killed these changes would
open the door to unnecessarily and
recklessly using deadly force in
circumstances where there are clear
alternatives to violent response
under this stand your ground statute the
already narrowly drawn prohibitions
against use of deadly force are
seriously undermined additionally by the
phrase in 627 colon 4 part 3 section 8
quote or anywhere he or she has a right
to be
hb 197 greatly expands this anywhere
seriously undermining people's sense of
individual and public safety especially
in times of severe stress and high
anxiety as we are living currently
as a retired child and family mental
health counselor i am paying close
attention with great concern to the
escalating levels of depression anxiety
suicidal ideation and suicide
particularly among those 18 to 24.
passage of house bill 197 would lead to
increases in public shootings and
killings creating ever greater stress
anxiety and depression among the young
people who grew up having to experience
routine lockdown drills at school to add
fear of possibly
we do have to limit testimony to two
minutes
so i'll just ask you conclude the
representation
did you want me to say more
you've exceeded the time limit but i do
offer the members the public the
well okay i ask you to please uh vote no
thank you for your testimony uh
representative knight you've
been recognized for a question
thank you chairman and thank you
for taking my question
um
my question is in terms of data that the
representative mentioned since we don't
have a lot to go off of
of people who feel safe or unsafe if
this were to pass do you believe that
the sign in sheet after this bill will
it would be a good reflection of the
i i can't uh judge that and i i don't
have a way to collect data but i would
say that those numbers do mean that
people are very concerned
that this
bill will lead to
people feeling very much less safe and
thank you
seeing no questions i want to thank the
yes hello thank you chair thank you for
uh taking my question or thank you for
uh listening to me
uh for the record my name is
representative tony kaplan from
merrimack six which is the towns of
henneker and bradford
we heard today earlier in testimony that
skateboards could constitute a deadly
weapon
so my fear is that
legal definition of a riot is so
subjective a notion
that it will inevitably lead to attacks
on our rights of assembly and free
speech the rights of community groups
and citizen groups to lawfully protest
and assemble without fear in effect it's
a declaration of war on our
constitutional rights and traditions of
tolerance and respect for the
as other people i'm wondering what
problem is this bill attempting to solve
are our streets and highways so lawless
that we need to enable private
vigilantes in new hampshire
i don't think so
this proposed law would make us less
safe uh stand your ground laws lead to
greater homo homosize greater gun deaths
and greater tragedies and traumas
inflicted on the citizenry so i would
urge you to oppose this law and vote in
expedient to legislate
thank you representative for your
testimony
hi hello um again
um
so my name is eric perez i'm with new
hampshire youth movement and i'm here to
oppose
hb197 and hb145
respectfully we have spent all day
talking about how things don't happen in
new hampshire like they do in other
cities and now that we're talking about
gun rights here come all the fantastical
stories of home invasions and danger
when we are the third lowest state in
violent crime in the country these bills
are less often used as a defense of
self-defense on someone's property and
more often used as a protection to
people who murder people in a way that
they find justified like george
zimmerman and i think we can all agree
that you should be able to defend
yourself on your property and i believe
in self-defense and gun rights because i
believe that's something that people of
color should have
the right to defend themselves but sadly
these laws tend to not protect us from
incarceration like centolia brown who
served 15 years after killing a man who
human trafficked her when she was 16.
that being said
um don't act like the point of bias and
feelings people are making are relevant
when in may after the first plm march in
manchester two men pointed and attempted
to shoot a gun at a group of protesters
out of sheer anger in front of the
police this law would defend them
there's so much that's already covered
in the current stand your ground laws
that we already have and we do not need
to extend that right to shoot someone
there is plenty of protection already in
our laws and new hampshire is not the
wild west you should not be allowed to
kill someone just because you're scared
this is how innocent people get killed
do the right thing retain these bills
thank you for your testimony and your
patience
see
seeing no hands raised excuse me
representative knight
thank you chairman and thank you erica
for taking my testimony um i just have a
question based off of your testimony and
other bills we've heard too do you know
what happened or how the conviction of
those two men if that's out of order i
apologize but we've heard other uh
testimony on on sentencing
reform and i i just wanted to know i was
curious were they punished
your question is not out of work
thank you
okay awesome i'm glad it's not out of
order because i do want to answer it
currently they aren't protected by any
laws so they were in fact endangering
people and are currently in the process
of being charged i don't know for what
and they haven't been yet incarcerated
but they are facing a few years for what
they did because it was an attempt of
murder they were trying to hurt people
uh seeing no further questions i want to
thank the witness again for their
testimony and
innovations they've been with us all day
jonah wheeler and just for the members
participating remotely
if you have a if you have a question try
to put your hand up as soon as possible
because
you know you have to scan the room nice
and computer
and you know if you put up later that's
you said jonah wheeler yes i do not see
no
penny
yes sir i'm here can you hear me
yes
okay thank you um members of the
committee my name is penny dean i'm a
licensed attorney i'm licensed in maine
new hampshire massachusetts i'm admitted
to practice before the united states
district court of the district of new
hampshire the district court of maine
the district court of massachusetts the
first circuit court of appeals the new
hampshire supreme court in the d.c
circuit and i'm an active litigator and
i'm neutral on the bill's language
because i think it should be stronger
but this is an excellent bill that's
absolutely needed
and when i hear people talk about we're
the third lowest in violent crime
you might want to tell that to the x
number of rapes assaults and murders
that we've had here and you tell the
person that's been raped oh don't worry
new hampshire safest in the state nation
that might be true but that gives them
no comfort
and so we need this bill to protect
people and to allow people to defend
themselves my only concern is i don't
think the language goes far enough
because the language the statutory
language of riot
which is 644
colon one
roman
one
c
sub c says he assembles with two or more
persons with the purpose of committing
offense against the person or property
of another whom he supposes to be guilty
and it goes on and on so i think
that a lawyer i hate to say it is going
to find a lot of wiggle room to defend
defendants in cases like this so in the
sense of supporting the concept of the
bill absolutely and i think
c or i'm sorry d rather of the proposed
bill is good because it allows a person
to defend others because right now the
way it is worded it arguably only allows
you to defend yourself it doesn't allow
you
to defend your children your wife your
yes sir i apologize um lawyer and a
woman is double talking long so the gist
of it is if you are ever in the
defendant's seat having to defend your
life you would like this bill or a
version stronger trust me
thank you and i'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much for your testimony
uh
representative bradley
thank you chairman
um thank you penny for coming to testify
um
you mentioned section d
does it concern you that it states is
likely to use an unlawful force so
instead of being able to confirm
um unlawful force you're using an
assumption and that assumption can be
based on anything
well no it doesn't concern me at all
because let me tell you an another thing
that a lot of people do not understand
new hampshire does not have a stand your
ground law i wish it did it does not we
have what's called an affirmative
defense and here's what it means if you
are charged with a crime and you raise
enough facts before a judge because a
judge makes this determination a judge
will allow you to raise what's called an
affirmative defense which is what's
found in this bill and so you're going
to have to give the judge facts
that the person what likely meant in
other words if someone's walking
peacefully by you and whistling you're
not going to convince any judge that i
know that the person was going to
commit an unlawful act against you
you're going to have to put forth facts
that say the man had a bad over his head
and was calling me bad names and said
i'm going gonna punch you in the head
with my bat
so likely is actually a word that i wish
was even weaker because you have to be
able to articulate in the spur of the
moment bad facts and we have a saying
for the supreme court that says detached
reflection is not required
you know in the face of an upraised
knife and i'm um paraphrasing the
statute or i'm sorry paraphrasing the
phrase from a supreme court justice and
what he's basically saying is when
someone attacks you you don't or is
going to attack you eminently you don't
have time to debate oh is he strong
enough to hurt me all this or that
you're afraid for your life and you have
to defend yourself so with all due
respect um representative
i think that they're going to go back to
the reasonable person standard and we're
going to look at
is that person reasonable in other words
if you have a two-year-old saying i'm
going to hit you with my balloon
no judge on planet earth it's going to
allow you to raise an affirmative
defense here you're going to be charged
under the criminal code unfortunately
this is still this defense which is not
a stand your ground it's an affirmative
defense after you've been charged it
doesn't prevent you from being charged
which is what true stand your ground law
does
this still is up to the given judge and
remember we do not elect judges in this
state we appoint them
and so therefore a given judge says you
can't raise this the only thing you can
do is appeal it but it makes a huge
difference in your trial and i hope i've
yes thank you um
representative you have a follow-up
question i do thank you
so
based on any assumption if i'm walking
down the street and i'm assuming right i
i believe they're likely to commit an
act of violence
and i
do something and i kill them and i shoot
them
there's nobody else but me right to
the state what happened because the
other person's dead
so
based on that assumption
i have now killed somebody and there's
nobody else to prove what happened
except for me
is there something do you feel that's
off is there something
that's no
that's
ma'am that's no different or
representative that's no different
than any other thing if if i if a
person's driving their car down the
street and they run you over run a
person over
and they say that you walked out in the
road in front of them or that all sorts
of things there's only one person
telling the story there's a guy in the
car
so there's a million other ways that
there's only going to be one voice being
heard
and so i don't think it's off with all
due respect because
i have to tell you the majority of gun
owners
do not want to be forced to have to
defend themselves that's the most
horrible horrible thing afterwards
you have what's called the mark of cane
people look at you like oh you've killed
someone
it's a horrible horrible thing it's a
horrible burden
to have to defend yourself like that
people that have to defend themselves a
lot of times have nightmares
they have sleep disturbance
there are all sorts of physiological and
psychological things going on that go
along with having to defend yourself
but you have to ask yourself
it's no different than if someone pushes
someone off a cliff or there's just a
million ways if a person is inclined to
kill people that they can do it so to
say that they're going to use this i
respectfully would say they don't and
and i just don't think that's a
um fear can i say that no one's ever
going to do this i can't say that ma'am
you know i mean a representative i can't
make that statement i don't think
anybody can um
if i take medication could i give too
much to someone i wanted to get rid of
if i didn't think it'd show up in their
system yeah there's a million things but
i don't think
that you're going to have that happening
here and especially in new hampshire we
have people who defend themselves get
charged all the time sadly people that
should not be charged because again the
county attorney has or in the case of a
homicide the attorney general has
exclusive and discretionary law making
authority as to whether or not to charge
someone so they can still charge you
because again remember this is an
affirmative defense that a judge has to
and so i i hope that answers your
question i can i don't think with any of
this that i can make any
promises or assurances no one can
but i can tell you that usually law
enforcement does pretty darn thorough
um
research and investigation
in cases like this or one would hope
and if there's any evidence they tend to
i'm not sure if i put your i might have
you may ask are you recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman i hope
you can hear me um
we've seen it for the past year and uh
briefly it's january a voice for
disagreement
over the
our
[Music]
i'm very sorry
i thought i heard can people identify a
riot for some reason i'm having trouble
hearing you and i apologize it may be my
equipment but i think i said i think you
asked me representative
could people identify a riot could you
possibly maybe repeat part of the
question so i can hear it
i think
representative please correct any part
of me asking the question that's
incorrectly i'm asking this on behalf of
representative holden are you asking the
witness that do you think an ordinary
individual would understand the
difference between a peaceful protest
and a right and i think the legal
definition of a rise is that the
question
that's the question that uh
yes representative i think they can um
because the riot definition
is based on what's called common sense
and it's a part of it which is 644 colon
one roman one
sub a
is the person that's guilty of riot if
simultaneously with two or more other
person he engages in tumultuous or
violent conduct and thereby purposely or
recklessly creates a substantial risk of
causing public alarm
and it goes on and on but basically
i think an average intelligent person
can tell the difference between
horseplay and violent attack towards you
or behavior that is going to become
violent towards you so a couple of young
men or young people having horseplay and
wrestling is not going to come up to the
level of riot but people that are making
threatening gestures or statements or
making physical movements towards you or
displaying a weapon or making threats
for example men zipping unzipping their
pants and saying we're going to have a
good time
i think
that's going to be the type of behavior
that factual scenario and this is no
different than when police officers say
they arrest someone for certain behavior
they have to enunciate facts
that rise to the level of the alleged
crime and so in this particular case
even though the average person may not
be able to quote the elements of the
statute
here's what i think they will be able to
do they will be able to identify a
threat
every i think everyone knows the
difference again between the kid in the
balloon or a 12 year old saying i'm
gonna punch you in the nose
and a larger
um and stronger person or a group of
people coming towards you and making
threatening gestures or saying things of
a threatening nature
and i think that's going to make a huge
difference
in how this is interpreted so no i don't
see a problem this statute has been on
the books the riot statute for quite
some years
and i have not heard of there being a
huge problem with defining it
it was enacted first in 1971 it's been
amended in 1990 2004
and in 2005.
and this legislature legislatures in new
hampshire are typically very
fairly proactive and no one's attempted
that i'm aware
to amend it since 2005 or if there is it
never caught my eye and i don't believe
there's any bills before the general
court right now so
my thought is that the general court
i'm asking may ask a question and this
this is perhaps a concern that may
pre-exist this particular film
how does when it comes to writing how
exactly in the world do we distinguish
between
100 people who are peacefully protesting
then
five of those people deviate from the
peaceful protest into what is now a
violent protest so really you have five
bad actors
mixed in with 95 good actors
and i'm just wondering for the sake of
that scenario how exactly does the law
separate that because i i understand in
maybe the public opinion
all hundred are gonna be considered bad
but from the legal sense
it seems that they're kind of all lumped
together but how do you i'm wondering on
the other 95 in the face charge
detention
i don't think they're going to um not
successful charges and here's why
they're going to look at the behavior of
individuals nowadays businesses have
cameras
there's rarely an event that there isn't
everyone with their cell phone out
taking video of it or taking snapshots
of it and so you're going to look at the
behavior of each person the person who's
standing there yelling rah-rah for this
or no no for that and holding a sign and
and kind of lifting it up and down and
yelling that person is no threat to
anyone um the most
you know is if someone doesn't like them
yelling around well tough luck you know
what i'm saying they're just peacefully
protesting what they're gonna look at is
the person who's maybe
smashing furniture or smashing things
and picking them up in their hand and
coming towards you
and making threatening
movements but the person who's just
marching along and yelling and holding a
sign or maybe waving a banner
those people are not going to be if you
will piled in with the bad actors
because you if you use this are going to
have to again describe in order to be
allowed by a judge
to raise this affirmative defense when
you've been charged you're going to have
to describe to a judge specifically what
that person was doing to be a threat to
you and in your scenario you got a
hundred other witnesses
you know and and if if a person to
address the former representative they
asked me a question i apologize i've
forgotten her name
you're gonna have witnesses if that
person tries to lie and say this person
did this you're gonna have a hundred
witnesses that say no we saw him or her
do or not do x y
representative
you have an additional question
thank you mr pierre
i hope that
you can hear me
i'll read i'll make sure to repeat it
the yes
between running gestures and vehicles
and i'm reminded of road rage and in
particular the incident a couple of
years ago in the north country where
someone was having a road rage thing
with another person on the road and then
they got out of their car and
shot the other person and they're
claiming
self-defense but they're in prison
certainly i believe
um so i was wondering if passing this
would give someone the impression
that um
a gun would be an acceptable way to
i can answer that question and there's
kind of a very famous or infamous case
on road rage in and it happened at the
nashua mall and ironically because
the elements ended up happening over the
line a lot of people don't know that one
end of the nashua mall is actually
located in kingsborough mass
so the case even though it started in
national new hampshire ended up being
tried in kingsborough mass and it's um
commonwealth for david bushong and i
tried that case
and the answer is in that case david
bouchong did not have a gun on him
and he was accused of having a gun what
he had was a cell phone in his hand a
black cell phone in his hand and a shiny
silver watch
and it was conclusively proven at trial
he was accused but
a automobile depending on the automobile
is a three to five or six thousand pound
deadly weapon it's more it's as deadly
as a firearm and if a person rams you
with that automobile or tries to run you
off the road with that automobile a
firearm may be your only choice to
defend yourself if you happen to have
like dave bushong had he had a very
small car
and the vehicle it was a toyota i can't
remember what model and the vehicle was
a giant four-wheel drive
huge it was either 250 or 350
three-quarter tonight three-quarter
maybe even a one-ton truck
that was trying to ram him
so a firearm sometimes you have to use
whatever self-defense tool is at hand
and in the case of a small toyota it
didn't have the horsepower to outrun
this large truck
and so
i think when you talk about using a
firearm people
generally use that as a last resort or
to warn off danger
and so i think if you are facing a five
thousand pound or three thousand pound
missile coming at you at 30 40 50 60 or
80 miles an hour on the highway that a
firearm may be an appropriate
self-defense tool and i can't think of a
better self-defense tool because you're
not going to have a police officer right
behind you on the road at all times
and sometimes people have tried
um in the dave bushong case it was
father's day and he determined not only
was he not able to outrun this truck but
if he tried to get in a lane to get back
out on the highway just to get away from
this man there was a
huge line of cars he couldn't get
through him he would have been rammed
from the rear so
you know i respectfully invite people to
look at that case if anyone wants to
email me i'll email you some articles
i've written on the case
but the answer is
more and more people for whatever reason
are engaging in road rage and it's
unfortunate but it's a fact and they've
determined that these vehicles are again
missiles that you can ram people off the
road run into people
and having a firearm to warn away
that type of situation is sometimes
perfectly appropriate so i see it being
allowed to be used in this instance and
it should a person shouldn't be charged
when all they're trying to do
is warn away an aggressor who's
or in the case of a motorcycle i should
add
i should add that i rode a motorcycle
most of my life and i've had vehicles
try and run me off the road on my
motorcycle
i want to
i see no no additional hands raised i
want to thank the
witness for testifying and
taking a lot of very difficult questions
next witness is the next witness is
i do not see him mr chairman peter
reynolds
what was the first name deidre hedra
yeah there it is i'm sorry
yes she should be um
okay thank you uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today my
name is deidra reynolds i'm a volunteer
with the new hampshire chapter of mobs
demand action and resident of nashua i
am testifying in opposition to house
bill 197
new hampshire's effort to expand our
already dangerous stand your ground law
through h bill 145 and h bill 197 is not
about self-defense but is rather based
in a racist policy and a disregard for
the safety of granite staters
these two bills further codify shoot now
ask christians later and give bad actors
a pass to unnecessarily use lethal
violence against protesters neighbors
and community members with whom they
have disagreements
h bill 197 would expand the section that
currently permits the use of deadly
force in order to protect yourself in
your own home to allow the use of deadly
force to defend other person in any
vehicle or dwelling or an area
immediately outside any dwelling from a
person they think is likely to use
unlawful force in the commission of a
felony
this bill would also also authorize the
use of deadly force to protect any
person in any vehicle or dwelling or
area immediately outside a dwelling from
a person they think is likely to use
unlawful force in the commission of a
riot a misdemeanor offense now i know we
went into the discussion of riot i would
like to say that it's uh the definition
is extremely broad and could easily
encompass non-violent protests and
demonstrations whose chanting or
marching could be viewed as tumultuous
imposing a risk of causing public alarms
this dangerous bill would give people
who witnessed such nonviolent protests a
license to kill as they could use deadly
force shooting first even at unarmed
non-violent demonstrators based merely
on their claim they fear the protesters
were likely to use force at some point
in the future
as a gun owner it is alarming to see
legislation come up year after year that
weakens or repeals any existing common
sense gun safety laws that we have in
new hampshire regarding firearms
responsible gun owners see the need for
reasonable gun laws and regulations we
see the gun violence that kills more
than 100 people in u.s every day and
more than 230 that are shot and wounded
ms reynolds we do have to limit
testimony to
two minutes per witness
so if you don't mind like just
concluding your testimony
sorry i'm back
um i urge you to vote no on hospital
197. i've also submitted to the
committee a petition signed by 540 new
hampshire residents who join me in
opposition of this bill
uh in his veto message for background
checks waiting periods in empty school
zones governor sununu said existing gun
laws fit new hampshire's culture of
responsible gun ownership and individual
freedom i'm holding the governor at his
word and expect that he will veto hb 197
hb 145 and any other gun bill should
they reach his desk this year
thank you for your time and i apologize
i can't take questions because i
actually have to be at revere college in
we will respect our the wishes of the
witness and uh excuse it from any
questions um
yes
[Music]
can you hear me all right
yes yes we can
great thank you thank you again for the
opportunity to testify my name is dina
romero i live in hannover new hampshire
and i was born here and have lived most
of my 70 years in new hampshire
i am opposed to house bill 197
if the state of new hampshire is going
to allow
ordinary civilians regular folks to
protect themselves with weapons then i
think it is incumbent on the state of
new hampshire to prove that this is
absolutely necessary so far i haven't
found that
in my research on crime in new hampshire
i also found that new hampshire is one
of the safest states in the in this
country and has the third lowest violent
crime rate and the low
excuse me the lowest property crime rate
in the nation so my question is why
would we need this bill
we also
um in this state given that we have
permit less carry and we don't have
universal background checks the public
has no guarantee that the person with
the fire arm a knows how to use it
b is mentally sound and would not shoot
indiscriminately
and c we have no guarantee that that
person is someone who would do
everything in their capacity to avoid
discharging the firearm
commission of a riot against a person in
a vehicle i found that very difficult to
understand
could one person's version of a riot
actually be another person's peaceful
protest i think we have seen in recent
events that this this has actually
happened um
and that would be a violation of our of
the constitutional rights to assemble in
miss romero we do have to limit
testimony to two minutes uh for
whiteness if you don't mind
concluding your testimony with one
thank you i was trying to make the
two-minute
the two-minute rule um so i'll conclude
my testimony absolutely i think you have
um
i think if i were sitting in your
seats i would be looking at competing
interests the competing interests of the
right to bear arms and the right of the
public to be safe
me i would come down on the side of the
public just because somebody has the
right to bear arms doesn't mean that we
should be passing 197. thank you very
seeing your hands raised i thank the
no
yeah why
this is bill kingston can you hear me
now
mr chairman members of the committee i'm
bill kingston the ex-marine from
newcastle i'm speaking for myself and
echo the concerns of the other witnesses
in this proposed change to our current
legislation the author wishes to invent
an entirely new and radical
interpretation of the right to
self-defense
this change eliminates the requirement
for all of us to use good judgment and
instead introduces the
flimsy and vague phrase likely to use
any unlawful force
this change attempts to empower any
person
to decide for himself but another person
is a bad guy and homicide is justifiable
this bill does not even mention the
words violence or threat
a simple verbal assault would qualify as
an unlawful force
this is contrary to our constitutional
doctrine of self-defense there's a
radical departure from all our previous
statutes and court decisions
again this is not the new hampshire way
therefore ladies and gentlemen i urge
signal hands raise uh the witness is
excused
also with us all day
yeah thank you mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is joe hannon
i'm the vice president for gun owners of
new hampshire
and i'd like to testify in support of hb
i'd like to start by saying my life and
the lives of my loved ones are no less
important when we're freely traveling in
our car than we're in than when we are
in our homes
uh that distinction should not be made
in the law we are guaranteed under the
new hampshire state constitution the
right to protect our lives and our
property
and um this law does not give someone
indestrument ability to use vigilantism
or to seek out trouble
if anything it's it's only when the
trouble has been brought to you
uh the people talking about riot who
determines what a riot is
if you read this the statute itself it
doesn't say you know what the person
perceives to be the right you know
there's a certain element of men's ray
of the understanding of the criminal
intent does the person committing the
act think they're committing a riot now
they may not know the legal definition
but if they know that they are
um
purposefully committing a crime with
them themselves or other people than
they they would be but the person it's
not just one or two people coming up to
your car and starting trouble a riot is
two or more other people so there has to
be at least three people coming to you
and someone in their vehicle is at a
distinct tactical disadvantage they're
in a seated position they are belted in
they are unable to move and if someone
is coming with a violent intent
and and using force in the commission of
a felony against that person in their
vehicle or someone else
they're very there's very little
recourse other than running them over
with the vehicle which we've heard is
just as dangerous not more than
dangerous
uh do we want someone in a in a crowded
situation where there's a riot or some
kind of mass protest and there are some
rioters at a peaceful protest do we want
that driver to just hit the gas and run
through the crowd and probably hurt some
innocent people
or do we want that person to be able to
respond specifically to the threat at
hand and i think this bill is something
very necessary to make that
allowable in this state and very clear
to people
um
pretty much we also heard that you know
you can defend yourself on your property
some people against this bill said they
have no problem with defending yourself
on your property this kind of just
changes it to defending yourself in your
property
in a sense
so um
i'm in strong support of this bill and
representative marston thank you mr
chairman
thank you for taking a question i didn't
understand your last statement are you
in favor of the bill or opposed
strongly in favor
let me ask a question by dr him yes
so where where i get
concerned is just i mean it really this
is this is something again i it pretty
exists as the this
hp 197 is
from the definition of
rioting
which is the members of the committee
it's rsa 644
1.
my concern is
what happens when you have a thousand
people in the street
and
all of a sudden
just because people are protesting very
loud or
four or five people out of those
thousands deviate from the protest and
all of a sudden become very violent
is how do you know i i'm having trouble
distinguishing how everyone's staying
separated i understand if you're
you know on one opposite end of the
crowd as opposed to the other but if the
person sitting next to me starts
pounding on your window or
trying to break your car window
i i obviously wouldn't um
i wouldn't support that type of action
but first it's next thing so i'm
wondering how do you
separate that and maybe we need to work
on the definition of rioting as opposed
to the policy itself
the rioting chapter thank you for the
question the writing chapter was
initially written in 1971 the same year
that the
section on justified use of force
section was written so there probably
was some uh thought given given in that
year of the legislature but um if
someone's say on the ground not in a
vehicle and they're being beaten by a
crowd of people and there's 20 people
around them but only five of them are
kicking that person in the head
and you know they have a knife or a gun
on them does that person have to
specifically determine who's kicking
them in the head decide to decide to
defend themselves their life is at risk
the lives of any potentially innocent
bystanders would be on the shoulders of
the people that are kicking them in the
head and maybe the crowd that's cheering
them on or videotaping it to put on
youtube
um you know i don't have the answers for
all of those scenarios but i do think
that when someone's life is in in grave
danger or um they have been in a
situation where they're they're in a
substantial they've been put in a
position where there's a substantial
risk of uh public alarm
um
i don't think that needs to be uh worked
out in the le in this law any
further i just may ask you a follow-up
please
make sure i work this correctly so i'm
so
if we if there was an amendment to
maybe
narrow the definition of writing to
clarify
the concern that i have
um
i'm wondering if you have read
a
paragraph to a person that's just upon
using deadly force upon another person
women reason who believes that such
other person a is about to use unlawful
deadly force against the factor of this
person
now that seems to me
cover
uh
what is being told
except that
in proposal
uh
we're talking about unlawful force
rather than deadly force
and uh while you're there can you maybe
give me a definition of uh unlawful
force
um
actually i
don't know if i can give you the
specific definition but it would be it
would have to be unlawful force in the
commission of a felony i can say that
much because that is in the language of
the propos of the existing law
um
the other thing i would say is uh you
know when someone is seated in a vehicle
they are at a distinct disadvantage if
someone approaches me on the sidewalk
and i'm about a 200 pound moderately fit
you know
guy i i can probably defend myself
against a single attacker without lethal
fort without a lethal weapon
but say i'm in a wheelchair or i'm
strapped into a chair sitting on the
sidewalk i'm in a distinct disadvantage
so having a law to protect someone
sitting in a vehicle that you know is
assumingly seat belted in and unable to
move is at a distinct disadvantage so i
think the law has to allow for more
leeway for that person to defend
themselves
thank you for the question
seeing no additional questions i want to
thank thank uh the doctor for his
testimony and
appreciate your basis and spend the
whole day with us
oh there we
go uh
thank you uh mr chair i'm not gonna
cover anything that was uh that's
already been mentioned
i am a co-sponsor on this bill i
understand that members have an issue
with
uh proposed part e
and i think that the
deletion of that line wouldn't uh
adversely affect it just leaving a
inclusion of any person's vehicle
should be fine to accomplish what we're
what we're trying to accomplish
i will give members an example of a case
from june 2nd 2020.
um the news coverage has kind of changed
around a bit but this this was the one
of the famous cases
where um
a group of black lives matter protesters
in tulsa
occupied the freeway but they occupied
not just the side they came in and
blocked part of traffic part of the
lanes
and the
according to the story the driver was
accompanied by his wife and two
daughters in the truck according to
tulsa world photographer mike simmons
who was on the scene protesters first
blocked the path of the truck and driver
which forced him to come to a sudden
stop
uh the driver then put a handgun on his
dashboard which angered the protesters
who began throwing water bottles at the
rig
the driver then accelerated through the
crowd and that sent two people to the
hospital with minor injuries
some of those facts are disputed and you
know who started first as disputed but
they
they attacked the
the driver they broke his rear window um
and it was later determined that there
wasn't a horse in the horse trailer at
the time but
the concern is
is here's someone who's under attack and
he has his wife and kids in the vehicle
at the time
are we telling
private citizens who are simply trying
to escape a violent attack
that they have that that
uh criminals or violent people or
rioters can attack injure commit uh
felony level crime against a driver or
their family
and uh the reason that we have
self-defense laws in case is that we
don't allow criminals to use the state
as a weapon to victimize other people we
don't allow criminals to attack people
i'm i'm going to object to all the
comments made earlier about self-defense
laws being racist i've introduced
self-defense laws specifically to help
people of color
poor people and people who have a very
difficult time defending themselves in
court
people of color have had a very
raising a self-defense claim in court
they're less likely to believe be
believed they're more likely to be
charged they get charged uh more
severely
and i think that the part of the intent
of improving our self-defense laws is so
that people of color not being
overcharged over sentenced and losing
their right to defend themselves i think
that a lot of the crime that occurs
in some poor and predominantly minority
communities is happening because the
right to self-defense is being
representative abrams i thank you for
your question i if you don't mind i have
a question
you may have heard me ask a few of the
prior witnesses about
more concerns i have
not with their goal i understand the
goal what um
hb 197 was attempting to accomplish
i'm just concerned with by accomplishing
that goal and then applying it to the
definition of variety
but do you
do you have any thoughts on perhaps that
being a misunderstanding because even
what you described as the example that
happened in was it tulsa
it sounds to me that
i'm not sure how many people were there
but i'm sure not every single person
there
was
supportive of the violent past it's
that's i'm just trying to distinguish
between
the two because we are this will allow
deadly force to to use or physical force
speed
and we just want to make sure that it's
clear that a person who
is not intending to be involved in this
at least the violence part of this is uh
right uh and the the law already pretty
well covers that it's not self-defense
and it's never been self-defense if you
go out and attack like if they if
somebody swerved in their car and
attacked a bystander
well you may be
uh acquitted or maybe not even charged
for hitting the people attacking your
vehicle the problem in the tulsa case
and npr had another story i didn't
mention uh been a a big spike in
rioters attacking vehicles
in that case the two attackers who were
hit and sent to the hospital with minor
injuries were in front of the vehicle
they ran in front of the vehicle in the
video they're both attacking
the vehicle the attackers who were
behind who smashed the rear window and
were throwing bottles
um and who knows what other things were
in the chemicals were in the molotov
cocktails or what have you in some of
these attacks keying up cars attacking
vehicles ripping the you know rear view
mirror off things like that um
in in that type of emergency we're only
looking at the driver we're only looking
at the what we call the actor this is
the person who is
not attempting to harm others but they
are simply trying to survive and protect
their own family
uh an actor or a reactor is someone who
is reacting to an attack that happens
that they didn't cause they didn't bring
about the attack they're reacting to an
attack on their person or on their
family
so
there's another defense 627 section
three which is competing harms which
says if you have say three or four
people in the vehicle
that's a different defense
that you can raise
um if there are more people in the car
and you have to drive away
um or if you had to drive drunk to
escape a violent crowd or some such
thing you're allowed to do that under
competing harms um but i don't
um
i think the understanding of the law of
self-defense law has been for and i
don't just mean for american history but
for thousands of years if you're under
attack the law steps back and allows you
to protect others moses killing the
egyptian soldier in the old testament
and so on that you've always had the
right to defend yourself for others if
you're under immediate immediate attack
it's unfortunate if a bystander
gets
hit but it's i've never seen a case
where somebody jumps out in the road and
attacks a vehicle or is in front of the
vehicle and is just an innocent
bystander it's only supposed to be cars
representative i may ask this to follow
i think when it comes to
the actual individuals that are engaging
in the violent behavior
that's that's not the concern i have
it's but it my concern is in the
definition of rioting is that multiples
where
in that scenario
that person
may be
engaging in conduct that is not
necessarily
approved of but it's not violent
but the person next to them
becomes violent
i'm worried about the tumultuous person
who despite
what they're doing they're not engaging
in violence
or committing bringing any unlawful
force against the person in the vehicle
that's what i'm concerned with so
perhaps
what is your opinion on an amendment
that would maybe
the purpose of rioting you would exclude
tumultuous
um
well as i mentioned earlier i would
simply strike out
because i'm really not sure that it's
necessary strikeout proposed part e
because i think that the additional
wording in part d is sufficient to
accomplish what the prime sponsor is
trying to do so that would avoid the
problem
rioting in new hampshire
is two or more people engaged in the
concerted attack
and
as it's used in this proposed
statute in this bill
that use of the word right is further
narrowed as right against a person in a
vehicle demanding its privilege and in
in this one it says is likely to use any
unlawful force in the commission of a
riot against a person in a vehicle
dwelling or its privilege so it's even
further narrowed to just a group of
people two or more attacking the vehicle
dwelling or the people in the dwelling
or cartilage
it's not any riot that occurs it's only
thank you representative everson for
um
you seem to be a well-read person
especially in law
can you define what i know what the
definition of deadly force is but i
don't know the definition of what uh un
unlawful force is can you provide me
with a definition
uh it's not explicitly defined but in
rsa 627 force includes both deadly force
and non-deadly force so you could have
uh somebody while you're in your vehicle
with your family um once they've
started sorry my cats
decided to take
there isn't an explicit definition but
it could be any type of attack on you
or a family member under this bill in
the vehicle
representing representative
so
illegal
unlawful of course if you're in your
vehicle for example and uh uh two or
more people came up and broke off the
hood ornament would that not be illegal
force and uh does this law didn't give
you opportunity to use deadly force
no it doesn't because under the bill it
would have to be unlawful force against
a person as it's not unlawful force
just against the hood ornament it's part
of a concerted attack
uh where it's likely that
they're you know the group has become so
violent we understand the uh
um better the
the group think that's involved in mob
violence
and so i think what the sponsor is going
after is once you have an angry mob or a
violent mob
that once the violence starts when
they're part of a mob when they're part
of a group of people if they feel like
other people are escalating the violence
that there's a kind of competition to
escalate that very very quickly and if
you don't drive off at that time uh
you're in much much greater danger of
being attacked
um
or possibly dragged out of the vehicle
is in
the um reginald benny beating where he
see no further hands raised i want to
thank the representative for his
testimony
thank you
hello can you hear me
yes yes we can um you okay cool so my
name is ismael mini i'm speaking
strongly against this bill
um first i want to say that this is not
about gun rights so i wish we'd stop
focusing on that
i heard many people including lawyers
who know how to use legalese to try to
convince us
that you know it's okay to kill people
and get away with it um several things
john roman a senior fellow at the urban
institute justice policy center recently
conducted a study examining racial
disparity using fbi data and roman found
that the killings of black people by
whites are more likely to be considered
justified than the killings of white
people by blacks
second i am a sexual and domestic
violence advocate and i am appalled that
the lawyer uses women's rights to
promote violence when we're fighting
violence in all its forms so hearing
this lawyer use her skills of language
was quite disheartening also i've been
in many protests and i thought um if i
knew that people are able to use this
law to harm me because they can get away
with it that's terrifying right so i
hope you understand you have a duty to
protect my constitutional right to
safety and to protest again i'm aware
that there's already stand your ground
laws in place but we must defeat this
bill that further extends the stand your
ground and we must as a state return
back to the castle doctrine eventually
that would make it impossible for people
to shoot now and think later and also
wouldn't allow people based on racism to
harm people and get away with it so
please vote against this bill that will
thank you very much for your testimony
we are
we're calling roger
roger we do need your full first and
last name
uh where you're from and whether you
whether you you will be testifying in
opposition or in support of hp 197.
hello yes my name is roger richard i
live in newberry new hampshire oh three
two by five
um i am in support of this bill
i gave all my information i also gave
all my information to to
talk late earlier and i do believe we
need to go back to the public hearings
inside the state house i am computer
illiterate we need to be able you need
to be able to see my hand not
my face or my hands whatever it is
however you find out okay with that said
i'm in favor of this bill
we have heard way too many times of
people
stopping other people on bridges you
have no place to go they come they take
you out of your car and they beat you or
whatever you cannot let people do that
to us
we need the right to protect ourselves
wherever we're at
we have that right and i'm not saying we
need to go and just do whatever to
people protect yourself from being
beaten or killed in your automobile and
also i'd like to say i am one of those
people for the statistic on feeling
unsafe
they didn't have any statistics count me
in i feel unsafe in my country in my my
state right now because we have
organizations that are calling us racist
and they are beating us they are
threatening us and they are trying to
subdued us it's not correct
um
hope i have a little bit more time
and i'm happy that the state is being
proactive on this because instead of
hearing a representative or somebody a
police officer or something say well i
wish we would have taken care of this
early it shouldn't have happened well
hopefully it won't happen because we're
proactive i'm glad to see the state is
proactive
that's all
and i highly recommend we go back to the
i will deliver the message
i will follow up on it too thank you
very much we know
no hands raised by the witnesses excuse
me thank you for your testimony thank
you
hi my name is tracy hambriquette can you
okay thank you i'm tracy han burkett
speaking for myself and as the leader of
the gun violence prevention working
group of the kent street coalition thank
you for uh allowing me to speak with you
today
um i'll
try and make this uh as quick as i can
the entire group of bills that are under
consideration today to expand the stand
your ground law give the whole group
gives me concern
the bills just and the law justifies
vigilantism and laws like these bills
have been used again and again
throughout the country to justify murder
with particularly egregious racial
impact
they encourage people to act before
thinking by giving them a ready-made
excuse to invoke
they don't have a place in a society
that's based on community and individual
responsibility um a lot of what i was
going to say about 197 really has
already been said so i'll just put a
point on a few of the um
a few of the things that have been
talked about
197 is frankly terrifying especially
from
the point of view of an organization
a group that does what we do it takes a
law with an already broad application
and it expands it to situations where
someone could potentially use deadly
force
where things might just be tense or
uncomfortable but have no need to be
deadly at all
and just to talk about the
demonstrations point one might recall
and i'm sure people will all recall this
the situation that took place this
summer with the mccloskeys who had a
peaceful demonstration going by their
house but saw fit to step out in front
of their house
both of uh it was a couple
both carrying firearms and point them at
that peaceful crowd something that could
easily have escalated and which would be
all in all likelihood
which would have
this bill would have provided them with
an excuse for their behavior that is
something that's really threatening to
people who are active
ms burkett
we have to limit testimony to uh two
minutes uh per person so you don't mind
just completing your testimony
[Music]
oh
i'm sorry i didn't realize you had muted
me
sorry
last sentence was just members of my
organization peacefully
act and actively demonstrate on a
regular basis and so i would ask you to
seeing seeing no hands at the witness's
excuse
good afternoon chairman adas
for the record j.r hall can you hear me
yes we can hear you okay
i am speaking on behalf of my self as
well as the new hampshire firearms
coalition we are in support of this bill
um in particular section d has drafted
and e with potentially small
modifications
i think the important portion has been
stated by some of those in opposition to
this bill several times during the
the preceding hearing
they've mentioned on a number of
occasions that new hampshire is the
third safest state in the nation
actually i think if i look at the latest
fbi data we're actually now number two
not number three
but i don't know that it matters whether
we're number two or number three the
reality is new hampshire is much safer
than states where they have the laws
that they're advocating for chicago for
instance which as of today has had 54
murders
a population roughly twice the size of
us and they've had 54 murders in the
last
whatever 30 some days
new hampshire doesn't see that level of
crime because people are allowed to
defend themselves
and the mere fact that people can
protect themselves is a huge deterrent
and i i can't emphasize that enough it's
an enormous deterrent to crime which is
why new hampshire is so safe
so i would ask that this committee
passed the bill
um
section d is is an important change and
i want to testify as a dad one of the
things that is not covered currently is
what happens about a kidnapping which is
clearly a felony level crime if i'm
strapped into the front seat of my car
and maybe we're in a parking lot but for
some reason my kids have unstrapped
themselves and someone opens the door
and grabs them that's a real issue and
we should be allowed to protect
our families so i would ask that this
committee passed the bill as filed thank
you
seeing no hands raised
the witnesses excuse i want to thank
excuse me
representative burt
thank you mr chairman and thank you uh
former representative for
you know speaking today
um
i've heard
testimony from other people or one
person that's talked about those people
you know the husband and wife that stood
in front of their house with the guns
and that they were going to be charged
with a crime
until
the
state attorney general stepped in and
said no no no
could you elaborate on that because i
believe they the
peaceful protesters were on their
property ripping stuff down like gates
and threatening etc
you know so i was just wondering if you
could elaborate on that
thank you representative burke it's a
great question um the couple was in fact
charged initially um with a crime
ironically of all this
the
um handgun that the lady had was a
disabled replica or
model that was used in a prior court
case
as i understood it
and they were trying to keep people away
from their property where they had
already broken in
cartilage i think is the proper legal
term right we're on their grounds
already in a threatening way
now
we take away from this that was probably
not the best thing in terms of trying to
deter them but what we do know is no one
got hurt and the hyperbole from
those in opposition to this bill is the
moment someone uses a firearm or he
brings one out that someone's going to
end up in the hospital or dead here's a
good example where a couple right with
firearms was able to prevent further
escalation and i think we have great
evidence in new hampshire that those our
current um constitution carry law our
current um statutes that exist have made
us one of the safest states in the
nation
and as was pointed out by by several
people opposed to this bill while new
hampshire's the the third safest state
we are and we are as a direct result of
having good policies that allow people
to protect themselves and i think it's
something we should continue
there was clearly an oversight in the
law that doesn't allow you to protect
from other level felonies
um
in the midst of a mob
whether it's the term is riot mob we
should figure that can be figured out
but if your car is surrounded by people
if you put it in drive and start driving
away you'll be accused of manslaughter
with a vehicle so that's no longer an
option to protect
the occupants of the car and i think we
do need to allow for some level of
protection especially if you're
surrounded on all sides by
by a mob
so that's why the bill was put in and it
thank you
thank you uh mr hull for taking uh
my question
are you aware under
uh
uh under two paragraph c
that deadly force is allowed to use
if a person is committing or about to
commit kidnapping or forcible sex
offense
thank you um yes the the bill that i'm
looking at is it does not have the
entire section right um it only
and i don't have 624 627 colon 4 in
front of me
i think the important part is
the current list is
abbreviated on what could be felonious
level activity and and this is a
thank you mr
um
so
i don't have a big problem about the
rest of the
areas in this paragraph and under column
two but
this
this one
and c
uh uh extends the use of
deadly force
and now we're only talking about
uh unlawful forms
uh has not mentioned that
there is deadly forces involved and
it is quite an expansion of the
president
so let me just i brought up 6 27 4 right
which is this is uh
opponents of this of these statutes want
to call it stand your ground but it
really is a justification section in our
statutes and i quote in this is roman
numeral two a person is justified in
using deadly force upon another person
when he reasonably believes such person
is and then there's a list
right and
item one is to use unlawful deadly force
um
if
current section d just says unlawful
force already right it's unlikely to use
unlawful force in the commission of a
felony against the actor
the problem is what about the third
party person in the car um
and i think this was clearly an
oversight when this statute was put in
that it should be
being able to protect themselves as well
as another third party if they're trying
to protect them i don't expect my
children to be carrying firearms around
chairman abbas i think representative
bernay renee wants to ask you another
question
representative ordnate
do you recognize
yes
um
but if you look in paragraph a under the
same section
is about to use unlawful
deadly force
against actor or third person so that
their child would be covered under that
third person would they not be
correct i guess the question is right
where in the line d unlawful force and
and and
i could think of
potential felony level crimes that are
not necessarily
um
kidnapping or
um the threat is with a firearm that
you've got to look at this through the
eyes of a prosecutor the broken bottle
well that just happened to be a broken
bottle is very different a broken bottle
can be a very dangerous weapon in if
representative ordnay
thank you mr chair
um
well i'll i would like to give you to
give me uh actually thank you i want to
actually ask you the same question i've
asked who other uh
and that is
can you define
i am not sure that i can necessarily
define unlawful force i believe
and i would leave this up to the
committee to take a look i believe there
is some level of discussion in the
statutes regarding
um
use of force use of lethal force
and but
um i i leave this up to the committee to
seeing no hands up
seeing no no hands up i
i want to thank uh thank the witness for
mr german i'm not seeing her again she
was here too
no she's not on the list anymore or on
we'll make sure we get this right is
on the attendees that wish to testify
oh i saw one hand go up hold on uh alan
rice
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee
i'll state for the record my name is
alan rice and i am a resident of bedford
new hampshire
and i am here as the state director for
gun owners of america and we are in
support of
house bill 197
which is a relatively simple bill um i
really am going to avoid repeating what
others have said
i just want to draw the committee's
attention to
the fact that riot is a specific crime
it's defined by statute
and in certain cases it is a violent
felony a violent felony
in new hampshire
people have always had the right to use
force
against violent physical assault
this just clarifies that if the physical
assault takes place
in a statutorily defined riot
a person can also use
force
the fir the first part of it in the
vehicle as others have said if you're in
your vehicle you're seated you're
vulnerable
we saw a lot of bad things
all over the country last year
new hampshire was lucky that we didn't
have those type of events and i think
this is a proactive and preemptive bill
to prevent
new hampshire citizens or visitors
from being victimized i'm happy to hear
that the people on the other side who
disagree with this bill acknowledge
uh that new hampshire is a very safe
state
and it's a safe state
because we let people carry firearms for
legitimate self-defense
and that is a powerful deterrent and
that's why we're a safe state
with respect to the mccloskeys those
people weren't just protesting it was a
violent mob that knocked down a fence
and was trespassing
the beauty of it is is they defensively
displayed some firearms and warded off
physical harm and i think that's a good
thing i would ask the committee to vote
house bill 197
ought to pass without any amendments and
representative calmly
uh sir that was
seeing no hands raised
uh the witnesses is excused i want to
thank you for your testimony
welcome
just to click just as let's make sure
that any members of the public that are
in the attendees
that i wish to testify that haven't
look at this one
son
can you hear me
yes
hi thank you my name is andrew rice
hawkins i'm the director of gun sense
new hampshire a project of granite state
progress i'm here today to testify in
opposition to both house bill 145 and
197 which expand the use of deadly force
stand your ground laws otherwise known
as kill it will do nothing more than
justify murder as millions of americans
demand solutions to violence and racial
injustice these bills double down on the
same white vigilantism that led to the
murders of trayvon martin and ahmed
aubry
new hampshire already has a so-called
stand-around law giving people a license
to kill when confronted with a perceived
threat without even considering walking
away or de-escalating the situation
house bill 145 completely removes the
already narrow exceptions
this would legally justify the use of
deadly force in circumstances in which
there's an opportunity to safely retreat
where one can render property to a
person claiming it's theirs or when a
person's initial regression ingress and
confrontation house bill 197 broadly
expands where and when deadly force is
permitted it could be used to justify
shooting at protesters the phrase likely
to use any lawful force is particularly
egregious and basically leaves the
entire decision of whether or not there
is legal justification to shoot and kill
someone up to how the shooter perceives
things in the moment
we absolutely cannot legalize the murder
of people who pose quote perceived
threats when systemic racism has
weaponized blackness as a perceived
threat
we all know what happens when states
pass the underground laws people who
look like mud aubry and trayvon martin
are killed and murderers walk free
house bill 197 also references lethal
response against unlawful force which is
the power or violence is directed
against a person without that person's
consent but it is not deadly force which
is a separate definition
again like house bill 81 earlier today
these bills seek to expand the use of
deadly force in response to
non-life-threatening situations
all they do is protect white vigilantes
and embolden reckless gun owners to
shoot first ask questions later and
claim self-defense to avoid cocability
for murder
stand your ground bills are not about
defense they are about legalizing murder
one of the earlier testifiers said it
best traditional self-defense does not
require that a person retreat from a
situation if doing so would put them in
danger it only requires a person to
ms hawkins we do have to limit testimony
to two minutes per person your time
constraints so if you don't mind
concluding your testimony
absolutely i'd encourage you to take a
look at the original poster child for
new hampshire's underground law who had
brandished a firearm during a road rage
incident years prior and who was
arrested again in 2019 after shooting
another man in front of his family in a
similar road rage incident these are the
types of people who want these laws on
the books this was a person looking for
an excuse in this legislature's
permission to kill it will please do not
pass these bills thank you
thank you
representative recognized to ask a
question
thank you very much and thank you for
taking my question
i i'm
i understand you've been listening to
the testimony throughout the afternoon
uh and i'm curious
if you've had the same reaction that i
have where
most of the
most of the incidents that are being
pointed out uh involve black lives
matter protesters
um
in a state that's 95 white
i'm just curious uh
if you think that they're what if you
think that there is a
a racial component to bills like this
that we should be paying more attention
to
absolutely and thank you for the
question
there is so much evidence about how
stand your ground laws are
disproportionately
impacting and murdering black and brown
people in our community and how
white perpetrators are getting away with
those murders now even in similar
situations when the roles are reversed
that is not the same outcome uh in
in other cases we also know that these
laws really allow folks who already have
a disposition to be prejudiced to be uh
to be racist in their orientation to
use laws like this for what they would
perceive as threats to murder other
people
and i would direct folks to look at
southern poverty law center which has
an a great video that they did with the
giffords coalition that really talks
about the application of these laws
across other states and what the
experience has been it is not an
um
something else that i'm interested in
too and one of the possibilities that
that bothers me too is i i have heard of
incidents where
in cases where laws like this have been
passed
where
people might
you know might actually
uh put themselves into a situation where
they could cut confront um people during
protests during peaceful protests and
actually uh incite those people into a
situation uh where they could basically
go hunting
is that something that you think this
bill would open the door to
i do and i think that the situations we
had in new hampshire last summer um show
that that is a very real possibility
when you had
particularly when we had black lives
matter
rallies and people calling out racial
injustice and you had individuals
lined across the street heavily armed
and trying to generate conflict or when
black lives matter manchester
stopped and were talking to police
officers during one of the first rallies
they had in manchester and you had two
individuals driving back and forth in
their truck taunting yelling
you know racial slurs and basically
trying to provoke uh those in the crowd
to engage with them um
at which point they stopped their car
and uh jumped out and pulled out weapons
these are the types of situations that
we do not want to give legal
justification for there to be deadly
representative conley
thank you mr chairman thank you ms rice
hawkins for taking the question
uh one of the things i've been thinking
about testimony unfolded is
proportionality
is it your understanding under this
provision that
perception
of threat
would allow for deadly
response
so the feeling of concern would then
justify deadly
action
yeah that is certainly probably the
scariest part about this bill is that it
is really based off of perception versus
anything
based in reality now i'm going to tell
you as a woman who you know
pulls out my car keys and holds it in
her hand as i walk to my car late at
night like many other women do
and per and rightfully is very cautious
about my surroundings
um
i do not want to have a situation for
for somebody who is in a situation like
that and without doing due diligence or
without having any actual threat
uh would feel justified to shoot and
kill somebody else in a situation like
that um just because they themselves
were nervous or again at the
intersection of how um racial injustice
plays into here again
you know people
we have people in our society who view
our black and ground brothers and
sisters as threats just for being the
people who they are and these are the
concerns that we need to have so
the language here is is
very very broad it basically opens up a
license to kill for anyone at any point
um and this is not the type of bill that
we should have uh go through in new
hampshire
i just want to remind the members
that the difference whenever remember
the public is testifying they're free to
state their opinions but the members are
not supposed to speak or comment or
imply what the motives of other members
of the body are so for the members
of the community to apply the motives of
the
other members who sponsored this bill
that would not be a program and i just i
just want to
make that warning to the members of the
community
representative harper
and thank you mr chair and thank you
miss price um
all day long i've been getting a little
bit agitated
because all day long uh you included
have implied that there's uh massive
racism all throughout new hampshire and
that the people of new hampshire can't
be trusted or the right to defend
themselves because they're going to use
it against people of color
where do you come up with those that
prep premise
i know you quoted the southern poverty
law center but that's not new hampshire
so where do you come up with this idea
that we're you know the people in new
hampshire are so racist they can't
representative hopper i would love to
answer your question but i think that
you and i have a fundamental
disagreement about whether or not
i'm still here that was my response
see no no further hands up i want to
thank the witness for their testimony
i just want to remind the members too
here on this this bill before the
committee the reason why i'm concerned
about speaking about the motives of
other members there is a member of this
committee who's a co-sponsor of the bill
and
i don't think we should imply that i'll
imply anything about that particular
we do have one more person
in the attendee list with the hand
raised
mrs
hi thank you for allowing me to testify
my name is louise spencer i'm from
concord new hampshire
i was going to testify on the next bill
but my comments apply to both so i
thought in the interest of time i would
go ahead and testify now
i have to say that
it's already scary enough at times to
walk around in new hampshire and see
people carrying open carrying long guns
and with my having to assume that they
have nothing but good intentions toward
me
the idea that somebody doing this
would um
now be able to
assess me as a threat in a totally
subjective way
is
terrifying and i can only imagine that
for people of color
who are
way too often perceived
as threats that this would be
very extremely terrifying um i would
note that in response to one of the
questions earlier
uh in the past
um
with the past speaker that most of the
comments being made about the threats
are from black lives matters events that
took place outside of the state i just
want to make note of that
and then finally i would say
that
it seems to me that if my loved one were
killed by somebody claiming
subjectively claiming in an untestable
legally legal way
that
they had killed my loved one because
they felt threatened
that
i would hope that
it would not be the case that they would
not be
able to be charged as the prior attorney
who spoke talked about the need for
these laws was that people should not
have to be charged when they act in
self-defense i think that is something
that really needs to be tested in a
court of law and that if somebody is
willing to use deadly force and they
kill somebody
that person
is a human being and they also are
entitled to justice it should not be
assumed that they were the person in the
wrong
so
i really
you know to ask someone to have to go to
court to justify the action that they
took i think is a small price for taking
somebody's life so thank you those those
are my comments and i'm happy to take
questions but i'm
seeing no hands raised
this
seeing no additional members of the
public that wish to testify
this would help
close the hearing on hb 197.
uh on house bill 197
there were 79 people who signed in in
support of the bill and there were 900
thank you representative muse
before we go any further i did tell
everyone that the goal of this committee
clearly that that didn't work out so
well
there are members there is enough i mean
for the public hearing purposes we don't
need to have a
form in order to proceed
so
i'm going to proceed with
but i'm just planning it well no it's it
is it's a friday and it's 5 30 but it is
scheduled and
i know the
bill sponsors
president
i just want to get a feel for the
committee because i didn't make a
promise and i
try to honor my work but
representative morrison
i can't hear enough of what you're
saying to understand
so i made a i told the community that we
were not going to
we would not have any hearings past five
o'clock and here we are it's almost 5 25
on a friday and we have one bill left
that we haven't even began the public
hearing before
so
trying to be as close to keeping my word
as possible
i will say that if people do need to
leave
i understand but for the purposes of the
public hearing
we don't need to have a quorum for that
so
it i would prefer to keep
i would prefer to have the public
hearing these the people
were here to testify
this was scheduled right leave at 2 30
and they're still here waiting so i
really think out of respect for the
members of the public we do it but
i just want to get a feel for the
committee on that because
it's friday
it's
friday it's 5 24 p.m
or is that a marston
mr speaker i do have a question in
regards to of kingston texas
and are we exacting anything tonight no
well
that that we will need a uh
a quarter floor i i will say that for
the people that aren't here
i
i would not do i will not do an
executive session without the blessing
of the ranking member of the other
caucus
uh in fairness to all the people that
are participating because it is late it
you so that's just that's my discretion
i normally would never do that but this
is a scenario
considering how many bills we have in
committee i really would like to see
representative rose
thank you mr chairman
my opinion is we are here to
do a job and we're here let's finish
i understand it's friday but you know
legislation doesn't happen basically
necessarily
monday through friday
[Music]
mr chairman i believe that this
committee has always waited long enough
to hear the public when they had
something to say and if people are
present i'm more than willing to stay to
listen to the people that are present
i'm and i'm happy to hear that you're
not going to hold an executive session
it would not be done without the i would
give my word on it would not be done
without the blessing of the ranking
member
fine i will be here for this as well and
i do think we need to finish the
work of the day because people took the
time to be here and some of the people
probably been here for a very long time
i i i agree 100 what's saying i just
want to get a feel for the committee i
respected the members who've
been uh
all
sitting here patiently represented night
i think we can we can start with uh
so
at this time at
5 26 pm we are now opening the public
hearing
representative abramson
uh thank you mr chair uh
uh and thank you members of the
committee for staying late on this um
house bill one representative max
abramson
representing hampton hampton falls and
seabrook introducing house bill 145
which
is intended to simply remove
[Music]
completely remove the duty to retreat
and enhance stand your ground i did
include an amendment that i emailed to
all members of the committee to respond
to some of the concerns by some of the
defense attorneys and members of the
house
but i want to give you a real quick
talk as quick as i can um
the uh
the reason for this bill is that
currently there's an exception to
self-defense law that basically says
that um you don't you do have a right to
stand your ground you don't have a
what i call a duty to die
there's no duty to die there's no
requirement that you get get attacked or
killed
if you're in your home or any place you
have a legal right to be under rsa 627
section 4 part 3.
but that part three has a lot of
exceptions to it
um and
people have a tendency to believe
that it's based on what actually did
happen but um the law self-defense law
is not based on what did happen it's
what your attacker claimed
and what prosecutor is able to argue and
get away with
um
so in the violent brawl that i i've
brought up a number of times before
when the brawl the fight broke out in my
home people were trespassing by their
own admission they took the stand and
admitted
uh contrary to their own interest that
they were told to leave
a couple of people said that they were
told to leave
a couple of times when the fight broke
out so that opens up a legal question
uh now that they're trespassing
in the middle of this brawl woman came
down with an upturned knife and beer
bottle threatening to kill people
she had an outstanding arrest warrant
numerous priors
the woman she was trying to stab the
large woman she was trying to stab in
the throat
she also had an outstanding arrest
warrant numerous priors and some of the
other people had outstanding arrest
warrants and numerous priors prior
convictions and uh chart criminal
charges
so the question is
so those people are now trespassing on
the property
um
excuse me
do they now lose the right
to use either non-deadly force or deadly
force to defend themselves when a fight
breaks out
and and this could be anywhere this
could be
at a sports game or a bar
or anywhere else a bar after last call
or a sports arena
when people have been
told to leave or any other you know
public park or public place where they
had a legal right to be but then they've
lost the legal right to remain maybe
they've been asked to leave and now
they're legally trespassing
do they lose the right to self-defense
unfortunately under the current law
uh you do lose the right to self-defense
as soon as you're you're told to leave
so you could be attacked and you
wouldn't be able to do anything this
might seem like a small or a very rare
case
um but it it it really isn't so in the
amendment
um i
oh my gosh my head's getting tired it's
so late
i proposed
uh in the amendment simply clarifying
the law to simply say what they say in
arizona and florida utah and other
states quote there is no duty to retreat
from threatening
or using physical force or deadly
physical force justified by this chapter
so this would extend this is a stand
your ground law the other bills were not
stand your ground
issues this is part three
so it's it simply says
um that
no matter what the circumstances are um
under either non-deadly force or deadly
force there's never an in there would
never be an insta
situation where you lose the right to
self-defense simply because you don't
have the right to be there a typical
case in point would be
uh in the middle of the road
um if somebody's driving at you for
example to use uh some of the other
cases you don't have a legal right to be
in the middle of the road so does that
mean that you lose the right
to self-defense
if you're if you're jaywalking or or
some other situation prosecutor could
argue anything and i'll tell you in any
self-defense case your attackers are
always going to say
they're going to trivialize whatever it
has been shown that they did trespassing
attacking fighting
what have you even with blood on the
ground and
other witnesses saying that their blood
on people's face and arm and so forth
whatever evidence that they bring up
they're going to trivialize their own
attack and then they're always going to
say well i wasn't going to do anything
worse than what i've had already done
almost all
murders
kidnappings rapes
deadly force level
crimes are preceded by non-deadly force
um intrusion trespassing smashing a
window of something else so force tends
to escalate very quickly and sometimes
in less than a second you can go from
non-deadly force danger to a deadly
force danger
i did add in part two of the amendment
um
allowing the
defense or more accurately allowing the
jury to consider
as they do in utah the nature of the
danger the immediacy of immediacy of the
danger the probability that the unlawful
force would result in death or serious
bodily injury
the other person's prior violent acts or
violent propensities whether known to
the actor or not any pattern of abuse or
violence in the party's relationship
any crime committed at the location
before the police arrive or would have
arrived if notified
in my self-defense case
the prosecutor finally turned over after
the trial started over 200 pages of
criminal records on these gang members
and
the reason that many states allow you to
to
to put that in front of the jury is so
that the jurors have a better idea of
how much danger you may have perceived
typical case would be you have a rookie
police officer with his partner
the partner might know
about the violent criminal history of
the suspect criminal suspect that
they're dealing with but the the partner
might know might not know about that
individual so
if the officer kind of shooting or
shooting back
doesn't um
have the criminal records it's very very
difficult to explain in court
how much danger there was i asked the
witnesses at trial you know how much
danger was there and none obviously none
of the witnesses were able to articulate
using words how much danger there was so
a really difficult time
trying to say it's already escalated to
this level and then it's escalated it's
exponentially worse and now it's going
to escalate to the point where people
could get killed or seriously injured
and it's hard especially when some of
the witnesses are or criminals or gang
members they don't necessarily have the
legal vocabulary to articulate that and
so a lot of other states allow you to
put in all all of that evidence
uh i
obviously there's a rumor that this bill
is either going to be
retained or itl to be reintroduced next
year
i would definitely suggest in this case
retaining the bill in order to allow
members of the committee to sit on a
subcommittee to
discuss
the the details of this as we've seen
all day rsa 627 section 4 part 1
non-deadly force part 2 deadly force and
part 3 the exceptions
have uh
they open up a whole
can of worms
and that needs to be
discussed and gone over and some of the
new new case law and self-defense that's
come out of the new hampshire supreme
court
needs to be looked at
so i'll abbreviate it right there but i
will take
thank you mr uh chairman um
i'm not sure if there's a question for
you or uh
a porn of order but um
this particular bill is uh
is going into a section of this uh
of 627 column four that we haven't paid
any attention to this today
uh we're over nine hours no
ten hours into this
uh hearing
uh
and i am sort of brain dead i'm not sure
i can uh listen to any more testimony or
ask reasonable questions at this time
i would
like to see us adjourn this hearing and
re-uh
started sometime next week
point of order mr chairman
yes
thank you mr chairman um mr chairman i
mean we're all here
uh people are testifying and i think
there are other people willing to
testify that has waited hours to speak
on this bill i just
you know the public you know just see it
bad for us to end it i mean if a
representative's brain is fried and he
cannot go any further
i i think it's okay if he
you know that we still continue with the
ones that can function and i'm one of
them
recognized
his brain is frightened
so well there may be a lot of that going
around but i just
representative i don't believe that
that's a
i i'm saying it is the discretion of the
chair if the chair wants to adjourn this
until another time
is there a second for the motion
there's
well
we kind of discussed that right before
we began the hearing
and i will tell you that
the consensus of everyone who was
speaking
my understanding was the people the
members that didn't speak actually all
were unanimous in wanting to continue
out of respect members of the public
i i do share the uh fatigue with
you know that everyone's facing i'm sure
we're all tired but what i would say is
for the people here too that wish to
respect to the members if we do spend an
hour on questions this is this is like
deja vu from the last time we stayed
afterwards
so that was like
let's just understand that if you're
going to have 7 to 10 to 20 follow-up
questions
that's not going to be very productive
so
what i'm going to do is
is there any representative do you have
oh uh representative newman has a
see seeing no no further he has raised i
want to thank representative evanson for
assessment
thank you chairman evans and committee
members i'm going to make this like a
third of my testimony because a lot's
been said i would just like to note that
in the
fbi supplementary homicide report 2014
to 2018
uh it showed that for states with stand
your ground laws it did include new
hampshire by the way
um
homicides in which white shooters killed
black victims are deemed justifiable
five times more frequently than when the
situation is reversed and i just want to
make one other point and you've got my
written testimony for the rest of it um
last year when the um governor's
commission on accountability uh
uh community and transparency finished
its list of recommendations in the
report many are already being
implemented there were three training
issues recommended training in implicit
bias
ethics
implicit bias and cultural awareness
ethics and
de-escalation training
um
manchester police that's where i'm from
they're great i've already i've already
read an article about what an excellent
program they're implementing that's
wonderful
the public doesn't get anything like
that doesn't get anything in
de-escalation training doesn't know the
law can't figure out what's justifiable
not justifiable felony misdemeanor safe
not safe
i'm just saying taking all guardrails
away
um is like giving a license to kill and
i i oppose uh
house bill 145 especially in combination
with house bill 197 thank you for your
time
seeing no hands raised the witness is
excused
hi thank you i actually um ended up
giving my testimony earlier um and so
that you could all try to get home so
thank you very much
thank you thank you ms spencer for your
testimony it will be noted that you are
in opposition to uh
all right
what's the first name mr trump
it's better like d-e-n-a
yeah excuse me
i am not seeing
her
i do recall when uh ms romero testified
she stated she was in opposition to 1 45
and it's also listed
on our list
that
she is in opposition to 145 so
except that she's not in the attendees
it has been well documented that she
opposes the bill
hb 145
i will say looking
what i just said about ms romero that he
could make a similar
identical statement to
porn
i do not see him either
the record reflected he was also in
opposition to this bill uh hb 145. he
did say that during his testimony on
the fireballs
yep
that's a new new one we got one
yeah bill kingston here
can you hear me
yes we can
okay
mr chairman members of the committee i'm
bill kingston from newcastle i'm
speaking for myself and an opposition i
am a gun owner and a marine corps
veteran with combat experience and i
know what it is like to be in a deadly
situation
ladies and gentlemen whatever happened
to thou shalt not kill
this bill aims to repeal the
long-standing legal principle that use
of deadly force has to be justifiable
this is way over the top even for the
gun lobby
i thought this committee's purpose was
public safety
there's public knowledge that in every
state that enacted staying your ground
legislation crime did not decrease the
opposite happened
these laws encouraged the escalation of
violence
in everyday conflicts resulting in more
shootings
prior to the enactment of this
legislation a person who shot another
person because of a perceived threat
would be considered to be paranoid and
get treated for a dangerous mental
illness
now that kind of conduct is permitted
and people are dying
in conclusion
as a marine corps combat veteran i can
assure you that even in combat it makes
sense sometimes to simply retreat
i respectfully submit that this
committee should bear that in mind when
considering whether it makes sense to
thank you mr kingston for your testimony
and your patience you've also been with
us all day so we uh we thank you for
that
i see no questions from mr kingston
though the witness is excluded
thank you i won't repeat my credentials
even though it's been a long day i'm i'm
sure enough people remember i'm a
practicing attorney and in case i didn't
say so i'm speaking for myself and i'm
out of concord new hampshire
and i would ask that you itl this bill i
am in support of the concept of this
bill the concept is great here's the
problem
this bill has been copied verbatim
from a utah code section
which is
and here's the problem i just saw this
bill yesterday
and what we have is not perfect and it
certainly needs to be fixed at some time
but this i do not believe is the
solution for several reasons
number one
it was the utah bill was most recently
tweaked in 2019
giving my general experience from date
of charge till trial is one to two years
there hasn't been enough experience with
the tweaks of this bill to look at it
but if you look at what's called the
shepherds report and for those of you
who don't know what it is cases are that
are reported through the courts meaning
if someone's convicted and they appeal
to the government appeals
the conviction or the acquittal
those cases are categorized by a service
called shepherds and so they take all
the cases in the country and they list
them if they pertain to a particular
phrase or a particular law there have
been 95 reported cases with the utah
code
that means 95 people have been convicted
and when you use the word self-defense
in there you get 90 of them
and so the question is is this law
working in utah and quite frankly i
don't know because reading 90 cases when
i was given this bill late yesterday
afternoon and it's just not possible
to go into this and put something forth
like this that truly hasn't been vetted
and looked at and see if it's for good
or evil is quite frankly reckless
i would respectfully say it should be
steve we appreciate your testimony uh
you have exceeded the two minutes and uh
it's
almost six o'clock so we're gonna
the bottom line is that this law is
quite frankly too complex and enters
into a lot more fact-finding which will
make it more difficult and more likely a
person may be convicted and it really
leaves the instructions up to a judge so
again i respectfully agree with the
concept completely but disagree with
this solution
seeing no hands raised
the
jr
i would ask that members of the public
who do wish to testify if they if they
do raise their hand
electronically it would be very helpful
for the committee members balance the
schedule if they raise their hand with
the beginning of the hearing
so it just would be very helpful to all
can you hear me
yes i can okay
thank you i'll make my testimony short
we've had a number of bills today in the
same regarding the same material for the
record j.r hull former state rep
from the town of dunbarton
secretary for the new hampshire firearms
coalition
i like this bill in concept i think the
language probably needs tweak given some
of the other bills this year i would
advocate that we pass the other ones and
retain this one so we can work on the
language it's a good idea but still need
some tweaking
um but i i and i'll send this to the
committee i've pulled the fbi violent
crime data
for new hampshire versus the country
and i want everybody on on the phone to
realize
the peak of the violent crime in new
hampshire was the 2011 time period
and after passing this law we have seen
a gradual decrease in violent crime
meaning new hampshire has gotten safer
over the last 10 years
this is not me biasing data this is the
fbi uniform crime data report
so i think it's important that we
realize that the laws that we passed in
2011 have made new hampshire a safer
yes
we may have lost
uh oh yeah he's right off the radar
mr chairman it's all right
i've got a phone bill
good afternoon mr chairman um once again
alan rice a resident of bedford new
hampshire
state director for gun owners of america
we are opposed to this bill uh the
original bill as introduced
yes it repeals
the person's
requirement to retreat
but it also repeals all the exceptions
to retreat that go along with it and
therefore the courts would likely fall
back on the common law which requires a
defender to avoid a conflict at all cost
the amendment that i was provided a copy
by attorney dean uh
we haven't had a chance to review it
with our council
it seems long complex and a carbon copy
of laws in other states
that could be impacted by court
decisions and in light of the other
bills that on this topic that your
committee is uh considering
we would respectfully request that you
vote house bill 145 in expedient to
legislate
thank you for your testimony
i see seeing no hands raised the witness
this is
dr joe hannan
i'm sorry um i know it's late joe hannan
vice president for
uh gun owners of new hampshire
i i don't want to get
too involved in testimony on this
because it's already most of what i was
going to say has already been said by
former representative hall and penny
dean
and alan rice uh it's well intended the
bill i think um
we need to spend more time uh talking
about it as it's written we oppose it
and if i'm incorrect didn't these prime
sponsors bill ask for it to be retained
for more work to be done and if that's
thank you
and good night all
seeing no hands raised the uh the
witnesses excused thank you again for
hi thank you
can you hear me
yes we can okay thank you
um
speaking for myself and uh the gun
violence prevention working group of the
kent street coalition
um
uh speaking against hp 145
it simply puts guns and um other deadly
weapons in people's hands and gives them
permission to shoot people without
imposing any obligation or
responsibility to respect the lives of
their fellow human beings at all
and much as um don't really like the
stand your ground laws um at least in
627.43 there is at least some effort to
recognize that before using deadly force
on another person individuals need to
try to make sure that there aren't
alternatives to killing think before you
shoot think before you end someone's
life
you know reality isn't rambo or the wild
west
in real life you take a moment or even a
second if you have it and make sure that
you don't have the option of retreat or
handing over a piece of property or
something like that before you kill
someone
but hp 145 would take away that civic
and moral obligation
it says if you feel threatened go ahead
and shoot and ask the questions later
there's no accountability if this law is
passed because you the shooter have no
obligation to think about that
to think about that feeling of being
threatened
you felt you shot someone is dead a
family and a community is devastated but
you go on with your life as before
i'm not saying that finding yourself in
a scary or a potentially violent
situation doesn't happen of course it
does and genuine mistakes occur as well
but
as much as i dislike the current law and
i think it needs amelioration
it at least attempts to strike a balance
between interests of the various parties
in a situation
hp 145 would wipe all of that away and
ensure that the shooter is always right
even when he or she is the one who
starts the altercation and that's not
balance it's a shooter's fantasy so
uh
ms burke i want to thank you for your
testimony uh you have reached the uh two
minute mark so i asked you just conclude
the second half of that sentence was i
seeing no hands raised uh the witness is
excused and i want to thank you again
for your testimony and your patience i
[Music]
seeing no members of the public that
wish to testify
uh at this point in time
uh we will close the blue
if you call dina romero because she's
here yes
we did
she might be gone i'm just saying she
was on the list for 1.52
again mr
chair i do not see dina
she if she's on that she could raise her
hand
representative says his hand raised and
i finally know why
you you guessed all right um
uh
for house bill uh
uh 145
there were
six individuals who signed in in support
of it and 888 who signed in in
opposition
thank you representative
at this time we are going to close the
public hearing
and
what
at this time what we're going to do and
this will be the only
executive session we have we're going to
have an executive session on hp
we'll open the the chair is going to
open the executive session on hb
145.
and just just to clarify it as i said
say this
i'm doing this also with the with the
blessing of the brand new member of the
office of caucus
i immer the chair is recognizing
representative
the
motion to itl and explain to legislate
has been
seconded by
representative gathering representatives
you wish to speak with a motion
i think it was pretty obvious 800 people
i will say for a day where there was a
lot of testimony that were on opposite
ends to end on a bill where all that
testimony came together to
agree on the topic was
refreshing
any other members wish to speak on the
motion guide
idea
see no further discussion
the clerk will call the role if you are
in support of the motion i mean
in expedient to legislate
please say yay if you are opposed
please say nay and
i will say although we don't have a full
vice chairman helped
yes
representative burke yes
representative hopper yes
representative wallace
yes
representative pratt
representative marston
yes
the clerk goes yes representative
harriet gathright yes
is he frozen
yes
representative news
representative newman
yes
i'm sorry
representative connolly yes
representative klein knight
yes
representative bradley
chairman addis
the chair votes yes
can i make a motion to con move to
consent
yes just
yes you may you represent tonight you
are
recognized for most of the consent but i
it's not emotions aren't required for
that so uh represent your
2018.
[Music]
thank you representative byrne has uh
volunteered his services to do the
report
um
and at this time we can we can um
will make sure you
left your book on your desk
yes by design i didn't think there'd be
any more committee hearings between now
i hope not
if there is they're welcome to use it
just for the members that are going to
be present
at the house session
later in february just please
communicate
because i'm going to carry as many books
as i can but if you're there
i'm going to
i'll make sure i have those and we can
arrange to
distribute from them if you're not going
to be there and we need to have a mailed
or whatever we'll just
figure that out as we go
great
all right
everyone please enjoy the weekend and
see everyone here first thing monday
morning
is that a motion to adjourn
a motion to adjourn is not necessary i
know that there was some chatter about
that last time it's it's not in the
members that serve on the committee
last term i don't recall a single time
that there was a motion to adjourn any
executive session
okay
oh very good then
everybody have a good safe weekend enjoy
the snow just everyone knows any motion
must be done by roll call if you can't
do the voice
so that's
part of it so it's not uh what's